ONE GOOD MORNING I'D LIKE TO
BRING THE BUDGET IN FISCAL
REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE.
NUMBER TWO ON RESOURCES ENERGY
AND TRANSPORTATION TO ORDER --
JUST A REMINDER -- ISSUES
THAT'LL BE HELD OPEN FOR ALEX
HAVE THE PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE
END OF THE DEPARTMENTS --
PRESENTATION ON ALL OTHER ISSUES
IF WE'RE ACTUALLY GET TAKE A
VOTE ON IT I'LL DO THIS I'LL
HAVE PUBLIC.
COMMENT OBVIOUSLY BEFORE THE
VOTE -- WE HAVE OUR VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR CONSISTS OF ELEVEN
ISSUES THIS EVERYTHING IS ON THE
VOTE ONLY CALENDAR -- OTHER ANY
MEMBERS PRESENT A WHAT'S CALLED
THE ROLE TO ESTABLISH A COURT.
THERE WERE COUNTY HERE YOUR
JONES SAWYER WIRE.
BONDS REMINDING HERE CENTER
STERN.
OKAY ARE THERE ANY MORE ON THE
VOTE ON THE CALENDAR WHICH ARE
ISSUES ONE THROUGH ELEVEN OTHER
ANY ITEMS THAT MEMBERS WOULD
LIKE -- TO WITHDRAW [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
THE THERE'S A MOTION A VOTE ON
THE COUNTER PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MY COUNTY I KNOW MONNING.
CENTER STERN.
ALL RIGHT WILL KEEP THE MATTER
OPEN FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS
LET'S SAYS START ON A DISCUSSION
FROM THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY WITH CALL
UP -- UNDERSECRETARY CHRISTINE.
GET AWAY.
AND THE TEAM.
LA -- FINANCE.
WELCOME TO YOUR PLACES.
WE HAVE.
WE JUST HAVE ONE MATTER.
WHICH IS THE NORTH COAST
RAILROAD AUTHORITY ASSESSMENT.
SURE SENATOR ACQUIRE BE HERE
SHORTLY [inaudible]
BUT OVERALL [inaudible] EIGHTY
EIGHT OUR CAL STOCK TO FILL THE
REQUIREMENTS OF CHAPTER NINE
THIRTY FOUR STATUTES OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN OR SENATE BILL.
TEN TWENTY NINE SENATE BILL TEN
TWENTY NINE REQUIRES CAL STAR IN
CONSULTATION WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY. TO CONDUCT AN
ASSESSMENT OF THE NORTH COAST
RAILROAD AUTHORITY TO DETERMINE
THE MOST APPROPRIATE WAY. TO
DISSOLVE THE AUTHORITY AND TO
DISPENSE WITH ITS ASSETS AND
LIABILITIES.
SPECIFICALLY WE ARE REQUESTING
ONE POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
TO DJ US TO COMPLETE PROPERTY
ASSESSMENT. FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE OFFICE OF
STATE AUDITS AND EVALUATION TO
CONDUCT DEBT LIABILITIES
CONTRACTUAL OBLIGATIONS AND
LITIGATION ASSESSMENTS.
AND ONE MILLION DOLLARS TO
CONTRACT FOR THE PRELIMINARY
ASSESSMENT OF THE VIABILITY OF
CONSTRUCTING A TRAIL.
THIS INCLUDES RECOMMENDATIONS
RELATED TO OPTIONS FOR REAL
BANKING.
WE'VE ALREADY STARTED DIALOGUE
WITH D. G. S. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NATURAL RESOURCES AND
CALTRANS ON THE WORK REQUIRED TO
COMPLETE THESE ASSESSMENTS.
AN AUDIT FOR THE DEBT
LIABILITIES OBLIGATION AND
LITIGATION ASSESSMENT HUSBAND
SCHEDULED WITH -- SAY TO BEGIN
JULY ONE TWENTY NINETEEN UPON
APPROVAL OF THIS B. C. P..
AND AS PART OF THE EARLY WORK.
OUR GROUP IS LEARNING ABOUT THE
HISTORY OF THE REAL THE STORIES
COMPANIES JOINT POWERS AND
DISTRICT INVOLVED ALONG WITH THE
EXISTING CONDITION OF THE
CORRIDOR.
WE ARE VETTING SPECIFIC SCOPE OF
WORK AND DELIVERABLES WITH EACH
AGENCY.
SO THAT WITH APPROVAL OF THE BCP
WE CAN BEGIN ASSESSMENTS IN
EARLY JULY.
INCOMPLETE A REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE BY JULY.
ONE TWENTY TWENTY AS REQUIRED BY
SB.
TEN TWENTY NINE THANK YOU AND
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS BEFORE GET TAYLOR I
HAVE A DIFFERENT QUESTION.
IT'S A REAL ROAD.
I'M GOOD I PRESUME YOU TAKE OUT
THE RAIL HE PUT THE TRAIL IN
THIS YOU KNOW I I REALIZE IT'S
BEEN THERE AWHILE BUT BUT I
THINK THAT'S HOW IT WORKS.
SO.
TELL ME ABOUT THE DISTINCTION
THAT YOU'RE MAKING BETWEEN
CULINARY ASSESSMENT ON THE
VIABILITY THAT MILLION DOLLARS
VERSUS THE THE PROPERTY
ASSESSMENT THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN POLYPHONY.
IF YOU DO THE PROPERTY
ASSESSMENT WOULD MEAN YOU
NORMALLY SAY I THINK WE'RE GONNA
HAVE PROBLEMS WITH THE TRAIL
HERE AT THAT LOOKS LIKE IT GOES
STRAIGHT AND DOES THE LEFT LOOKS
LIKE THAT.
THAT'S HOW THE TRAILS GET AGO
HOW DOES THAT YOU KNOW BECAUSE
WE'RE THAT'S OUR JOB YOUR
RESEARCH YOU WATCH DOGS SURE AND
AND THERE'S THEY ARE RELATED.
THE PROPERTY ASSESSMENT WOULD
LOOK AT THE OWNERSHIP THE RIGHTS
OF WAY THE EASEMENTS INVOLVED OF
THE APPROXIMATELY SEVENTEEN
HUNDRED PARCELS THAT ARE NORTH
OF WILLITS.
AND THEN THE VIABILITY OF
TURNING IT INTO A TRAIL WITH
THEN LOOK AT THE THE ABILITY FOR
IT TO BE A VIABLE -- TRAIL
PRIORITIES -- ALSO THE CONDITION
OF THAT CORRIDOR IN TURNING IT
INTO A TRAIL BECAUSE THERE ARE
SOME PLACES WHERE.
THE CONDITION IS.
LESS THAN OPTIMAL.
YEAH I I GUESS I ASSUME THAT
SINCE THE REAL ROADS THERE YOU
ALREADY HAVE THE THE EASEMENT
OVER WHOEVER'S PROPERTY IT WILL
IT BE THAT DIDN'T JUST GO AWAY
SO THAT HALF MILLION DOLLARS.
WORK MIND I I WANTED CROSS ALL
THE TEASE SO.
IS IT IS IT THIS.
I MEAN YOU'RE ON THE TRAIL I
GUESS PEOPLE WANNA GET OFF THE
TRAIL SO THERE'S AT THIS THAT
CLARIFICATION OF WE'RE YOU CAN
STAY ON THE TRAIL BECAUSE THE
EASEMENT IS ONLY ON THE THE RAIL
LINE.
AND THEN THIS IS PUBLIC PROPERTY
OR THIS IS THIS.
THE SNACK SHOP OR WHATEVER
WHATEVER PEOPLE WANT TO DO WITH
THIS THING -- YEAH OKAY WE'RE
GONNA COME YES IT.
QUESTION IN LINE WITH THAT SURE
MISTER VICE CHAIR THANK YOU --
KIT IS ACTUALLY BIKE TRAIL WAS
ONE OF THE NOTES THAT I MADE --
IT AND THE CHAIR MENTION
EASEMENT SO.
DOES THE REAL.
THIRTEEN OUR THEIR PERCEPTIONS
IS JUST AN EASEMENT OR DOES THE
REAL THIRTY OWN ALL OF THE LAND
THAT THE RAIL IS CURRENTLY ON I
THINK THAT'S PART OF WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO ON TO LOOK INTO AS PART
OF THESE ASSESSMENTS.
ON THE EVE SO SOME OF IT MIGHT
BE AN EASEMENT ON PRICE ON
PRIVATE OR OTHER.
TYPES OF LAND.
WE'RE GOING TO THAT'S PART OF OF
OUR ASSESSMENT IS TO FULLY
UNDERSTAND ALL OF THAT OF MR YOU
KNOW PART OF THE CHALLENGE OR IF
IT IS IN THESE MINUTES LEGAL
EASEMENT MIGHT BE RESTRICTED TO
RAIL USE.
YOU KNOW WE MAY HAVE TO GO BACK
TO THE ORIGINAL LAND OWNERS.
TO BURKE TO CONVERT TO BY WHICH
I WOULD CERTAINLY SUPPORT
CONVERTING IT TO A BIKE TRAIL
BUT NO I DID THAT WOULD BE THE
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND PART OF
THE REQUEST IT'S THE OTHER. TWO
HUNDRED TWO POINT FIVE MILLION
THAT DEALS WITH THE THAT WHETHER
IT CAN BE A TRAIL ON WITH THAT
RAILROAD WOULD DO BECAUSE BUT
PEOPLE HAVE THAT AND I'M SORRY
ONE MORE QUESTION YES YOU
MENTIONED RAIL BANKING SO IS
THERE A IS THERE A THOUGHT THAT
THIS MIGHT.
AT SOME POINT TIME BE PUT BACK
INTO USE SO WHY NOT.
THIS IS ALL THAT CAN.
BUT THE THE BILL DOES REQUIRE US
TO LOOK AT OPTIONS FOR RAIL
BANKING SYSTEM WAS THAT WE'D
LIKE TO LOOK AT TWO X..
YOUR MY THOUGHTS WAS AS PART OF
THE AND MAYBE YOU'RE GONNA LOOK
INTO THIS JUST CONVERT.
TRANSFERRED TO STATE PARKS.
ARE COUNTY PARKS FOR THE PURPOSE
OF A VICTIM SO THAT'S THANK.
YOU HAVE A COMMENT.
I'M WE WE DID NOT RAISE ANY
CONCERNS THAT WITH THIS PROPOSAL
AND THE THE SITUATION ALONG THE
NORTH COAST A REAL.
I'M CORRIDOR AS AS THE NUMBER
YOU ARE YOUR NOSE IS THIS IS
BILL AND IS IS ACTUALLY FOR FOR
REALLY COMPLICATED AND SO ON
THAT THE VARIOUS COMPONENTS OF
THE STUDY DID SEEM CONSISTENT --
WITH THE LEGISLATION THAT WE
DIDN'T HAVE ANY CONCERNS.
ADD TO YOUR QUESTION REGARDING
THE PROPERTY ASSESSMENT VERSES
I'M LOOKING AT THE VIABILITY OF
THE TRAIL.
AND THAT THERE THERE ARE -- IT'S
OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT THERE ARE
SAM AND IT LIKE I'M INDIVIDUAL
AGREEMENTS THAT MAY HAVE BEEN
ENTERED INTO BETWEEN THE NORTH
COAST RAIL AUTHORITY AND
PROPERTY OWNERS.
AND AND GIVEN SORT OF THE
FINANCIAL CONDITION OF THE NORTH
COAST RAIL AUTHORITY IT'S SORT
OF UNCLEAR WHAT EXACTLY THEY'VE
ENTERED INTO AND SO IT WENT IF
WITH THE INTENT TO BEING TO
ESSENTIALLY DISSOLVE THAT.
WHAT'S A SPECIAL DISTRICT AND
CREATE SOMETHING NEW
UNDERSTANDING THE LEGAL
RAMIFICATIONS OF WHAT WHAT
THEY'D ENTERED INTO IS IMPORTANT.
SO THAT'S THE ONE PIECE OF IT
THE VIABILITY OF THE TRAIL AND
THIS IS A VERY LONG CORRIDOR AND
IN SOME CASES -- THERE'S BRIDGES
SPANNING RIVERS AND AND SOME
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT IS NOT
CURRENTLY BEING USED FOR RAIL
AND IS AND POTENTIALLY IN A
STATE OF DISREPAIR.
THE OTHER ISSUE IF IT'S COST
SEEN -- PRIVATE PROPERTY ON YOUR
PRIVATE PROPERTY AND YOU HAVE
PEOPLE SAY HIKING ON A MULTI DAY
HIKE YOU WOULD NEED FACILITIES
AND THAT YOU WOULD NEED TO
MAINTAIN THOSE FACILITIES YOU
NEED MAYBE CAMPING FACILITIES
BATHROOMS THINGS LIKE THAT.
AND SO THOSE ARE SORT OF THE TWO
DISTINCTIONS ONE IS ALMOST MORE
OF LIKE AN OSCAR PROCESS OF
UNDERSTANDING THE LEGAL
RAMIFICATIONS ON THE PROPERTY
AND THE OTHER ONE IS.
ON THE BUILD OUT OF THE TRAIL
COULD BE YOU KNOW COULD BE VERY
EXPENSIVE IT CAN BE IN THE
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
YOU MAY HAVE TO BUILD BRIDGES
AND OTHER FACILITIES AND THAT
PROCESS PRIVATE AGREEMENT SINCE
THE RAILROAD HAS NOT BEEN
OPERATING MAY HAVE LAPS UNDER
TWO CONDITIONS.
THAT THEY WERE ENTERED INTO A
HUGE IT YES BE CONTINUE ISSUES
HE ADDED THAT ANY OTHER.
CENTER MCGUIRE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR
AS WELL AS A VICE CHAIR FOR SO I
JUST WANT TO I TAKE A MOMENT TO
SAY THANK YOU.
TO THE GOVERNOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE TO TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY I CALTRANS BEEN DIRECTOR
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WE HAVE THE DIRECTOR THE CDC
HERE TODAY -- IT IS BEEN AN ALL
HANDS ON DECK EFFORT HI SINCE SB
TEN TWENTY NINE HAS BEEN PASSED.
IN IT IS A COMPLICATED ISSUE AND
I JUST CANNOT SAY THANK YOU HAVE
TO ALL INVOLVED.
ON THIS.
LONG STORY SHORT THIS AGENCY WAS.
DEVELOPED I DECADES AGO -- IN
WHEN IT WAS ORIGINALLY CREATED
THE STATE AUTHORIZED FOR THE
CREATION AGENCY BUT NEVER FUNDED
IT.
I IN SO -- I THEY ARE
FUNCTIONALLY BANKRUPT.
I AND TO BE ABLE TO KEEP THEIR
COFFERS -- FLOWING A BEEN
SELLING OFF RIGHT AWAY. TO
DEVELOPERS IN DIFFERENT CITIES --
IN CHARGING IF A HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT WAS GONNA BE ON ONE
SIDE OF THE TRACKS IT ACROSS.
THEY WOULD A SELL OFF THOSE
RIGHT AWAY RIGHT.
IS NINETEEN HUNDRED APPROXIMATE
PARCELS FROM THE SAN FRANCISCO
BAY ALL THE WAY UP TO EUREKA AS
A WE ESTIMATE.
THAT IS GONNA HAVE TO BE A
BOUNDARY SURVEY OF THE ENTIRE
RIGHT AWAY.
I IN C. R. A. OWNS THE ENTIRE
IN SPECIFIC FEET ON EACH SIDE SO
IT IS ACTUALLY -- UNDER PUBLIC
OWNERSHIP NOW.
WHAT THIS IS GOING TO FIND IS
NUMBER? ONE TO DO THAT BOUNDARY
SURVEY WHICH WE NEED TO BE A
COMPLETE AND CANDIDLY IT'S GOING
TO BE A PAIN IN THE **** BECAUSE
THIS RARE ROAD IS BEEN OPERATING
FOR ABOUT A HUNDRED YEARS.
AND AS YOU CAN IMAGINE FOLKS OF
SNUCK UP ON TO THE RIGHT AWAY --
OVER THE YEARS AND WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO BE TO SORT THROUGH THAT --
NUMBER -- TWO WE'RE GONNA WIND
DOWN IN CRLA AND THAT PROCESS IS
ALREADY STARTED THANK YOU TO THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE TRANSPORTATION AGENCY.
IS WELL.
AT THE NC ARE A WILL TURN INTO
THE GREAT REDWOOD TRAIL AGENCY --
AND AS PART OF THE BILL -- THE
IN C. R. A. BOARD IS NOW
TRANSITIONING INTO THE G. R. T.
A BOARD.
IT WILL STILL BE A PUBLICLY
APPOINTED BOARD.
THERE IS ACTIVE RAIL ON THE
SOUTHERN PORTION OF THE LINE AND
THAT'S THE SNOW MARIN AREA RAIL
TRANSIT AUTHORITY WHICH IS A
PUBLICLY FUNDED PASSENGER RAIL
LINE.
THAT IS SUPPOSED TO GO FROM IRAN
ALL WE HAVE TO CLOVERDALE.
IN ALL THIS ENDED RIGHT HERE IS
THAT -- ATTACK WITH MOTION HEY
THERE WE GO -- IS THAT -- WHAT
IS MASTER PLAN WILL ASSIST IS?
TO BE ABLE TO DO OPERATIONS LONG
TERM OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE
OF THE TRAILS WELL -- AND WHO
WILL ACTUALLY GOVERNMENT LONGER
TERM -- ENDED HERE THE NINETY
TWO BILLION DOLLAR INDUSTRY THAT
WE HAVE IN CALIFORNIA'S OUTDOOR
RECREATION THIS TRAVEL LINE
THROUGH SOME OF THE MOST
IMPOVERISHED COMMUNITIES.
IN OUR STATE AND THIS WILL TURN
INTO AN ECONOMIC DRIVER I TOLD
SAY THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FOR
STRETCHING ON THIS.
HI KAREN FAN HAS BEEN AMAZING TO
BE TO WORK WITH -- AND KNOW THAT
SHE IS NOW ARE RECENTLY RETIRED --
AS WELL AS THE CDC AND THE
DIRECTOR OF CALTRANS IN LOOK FOR
THE WORKING WITH THE CHAIR AND
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ADVANCE A
MOTION AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME
THERE IS A MOTION LET'S OPEN UP
FOR PUBLIC HEARING -- I STEVE
YOU HAVE THIS NUMBER AND EVERY
REAL TRANSIT DISTRICT WERE ALSO
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THIS --
PREPARATION AND URGE YOUR
SUPPORT IT'S IMPORTANT TO GET
THIS ASSESSMENT COMPLETED
[inaudible]
OKAY.
CLOSE PUBLIC HEARING THERE IS
BEEN IN MOTION THIS IS APPROVED
IS BUDGETED PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MY COUNTY.
HI JONES.
GAR.
STERN.
THAT'S FIVE ZERO THE MATH AND
THE PROVO.
PROPOSALS APPROVED.
CAN WE OPEN THE VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR THIS IS ITEMS ONE
THROUGH ELEVEN LIKE TO OPEN THE
VOTE ON IT ON THE COUNTER FOR
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ON THE VOTE ONLY CALENDAR
[inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
WHY ARE?
CLOSE VOTER I COUNTED AS FIVE
ZERO AND NOW WE'LL GO TO ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEMS.
THE CALIFORNIA.
SYSTEM THIS IS ITEM NUMBER.
THIRTEEN TRANSPORTATION JUST
SYSTEM OVERSIGHT.
AND CITY SEE.
GOOD MORNING -- DIRECTOR --
BRANSON GOOD TO SEE YOU.
MORNING.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
HERE TODAY.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MET AND
SENATORS.
CAN YOU HEAR ME OK.
OKAY THANK YOU.
AS SENATORS WITH THE WITH THE
PASTOR SENATE BILL ONE IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THE LEGISLATURE.
INCREASE TRANSPORTATION FUNDING
BY MORE THAN FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
SB ONE HAS HAD A SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT ON THE WORKLOAD OF THE
COMMISSION.
IT IS A SIGN RESPONSIBILITY TO
THE COMMISSION FOR MORE THAN
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
FOR A EXISTING AND NEWLY CREATED
PROGRAMS.
IT IS ALSO INCREASE THE
COMMISSION'S OVERSIGHT
RESPONSIBILITIES FOR HOLDING
CALTRANS AND LOCAL AND REGIONAL
GOVERNMENTS ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE
EFFICIENT INVESTMENT OF PUBLIC
FUNDS.
THE COMMISSION UNDERSTANDS
RESPONSIBILITY THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS INTERESTED IN.
WITH RESPECT TO SENATE BILL ONE
AND HAS WORKED HARD OVER THE
LAST TWO YEARS. TO ADOPT
GUIDELINES FOR SENATE BILL ONE
PROGRAMS COMMIT FUNDS TO
PROJECTS.
IN ALLOCATE FUNDS FOR
TRANSPORTATION IMPROVEMENTS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
THE COMMISSION HAS PERFORMED
THIS WORK THROUGH VERY OPEN AND
TRANSPARENT MANNER.
IS HELD OVER FORTY PUBLIC
WORKSHOPS IN ADDITION TO HIS
REGULAR BUSINESS MEETINGS TO
DEVELOP AS HE WON PROGRAM
GUIDELINES.
THAT ULTIMATELY LED TO THE
DEDICATION OF MORE THAN TWENTY
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS. TO STAY
OUT OF STATE FEDERAL
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING
THROUGHOUT COLLEGE FOR
TRANSPORTATION IMPROVEMENTS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
THE COMMISSION ALSO ADOPTED
SENATE BILL ONE ACCOUNTABILITY
AND TRANSPARENCY GUIDELINES
WHICH DETAILS SPECIFIC
REQUIREMENTS TO HOLD CALTRANS
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ACCOUNT OF
ACCOUNTABLE. FOR DELIVERING
PROJECTS AS PROMISED INCLUDING
EXTENSIVE PROGRAM MONITORING AND
REPORTING.
THE COMMISSION IS CURRENTLY
COMPLETING ITS WORKLOAD.
THROUGH EVERY DIRECTION OF
RESOURCES RETIRED IN NEW TENS
STING ASSISTANCE AN INCREASE
LEVELS OF OVERTIME AMONG STAFF.
THE COMMISSION IS REQUESTING AN
INCREASE IN HIS BUDGET AUTHORITY.
FOR THREE PERMANENT POSITIONS IN
A LIMITED TERM POSITIONS.
AS WELL AS THE REALLOCATION OF
FUNDING SOURCES WITHIN ITS ITS
EXISTING BUDGET AUTHORITY.
THESE REQUESTED POSITIONS WERE
ADDRESS INCREASED WORKLOAD IN
SEVEN TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS
AND ONE POSITION WILL ADDRESS
CLIMATE CHANGE ADAPTATION
SUSTAINABILITY ENVIRONMENTAL AND
SOCIAL JUSTICE AND OTHER RELATED
ISSUES.
THE CROSS CUT ALL OF THE
COMMISSION'S PROGRAMS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES.
AND ON BEHALF OF THE COMMISSION
I'M HERE TODAY TO RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR APPROVAL OF THIS
REQUEST.
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS MEMBERS OF THIS ITEM
NUMBER THREE THIS IS THE
OVERSIGHT [inaudible]
THE THREE PERMANENT POSITIONS
AND A TWO YEAR LIMIT TERM
POSITIONS ALEJO.
WE DON'T HAVE ANY CONCERNS WITH
THE SPECIFIC PROPOSAL BUT JUST
WANT TO KNOW THAT AND AS
DIRECTOR BRAD EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
BRANSON SAID THERE IS A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN WORKLOAD
BOTH IN TERMS OF THE AMOUNT OF
FUNDS AT CTC IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
ALLOCATING.
AS WELL AS A GREATER LEVEL OF
PROJECT LEVEL OVERSIGHT THAT THE
COMMISSION IS DOING ON ON BOTH
THE NEW SB ONE MONIES AS WELL AS
ALL OTHER PROJECTS.
THAT GREATER LEVEL OF OVERSIGHT
WAS SOMETHING THAT OUR OFFICE
HAD RECOMMENDED FOR ON A LONG
TIME AND WAS INCLUDED IN THAT SB
ONE TRANSPORTATION FUNDING.
PACKAGE AT THE TIME WE HAD
RECOMMENDED THAT WE DIDN'T KNOW
THAT IT WOULD REQUIRE AN
INCREASE IN STAFF ON TO THE
COMMISSION SINCE OUR STAFF IS
RELATIVELY SMALL.
AND THE PROPOSAL INCLUDES SIMON --
PERMANENT AND SOME LIMITED TERM
POSITIONS THIS WORKLOAD IS GONNA
BE ON GOING AND SO YOU'RE YOU'RE
GONNA HAVE TO REVISIT THOSE
LIMITED TERM POSITIONS IN THE
FUTURE.
BUT THE REASON THEY'RE PROPOSED
AS LIMITED TERM IS THERE'S A
CURRENT REVIEW GOING ON BETWEEN
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
AND THE CTC TO DETERMINE EXACTLY
THE MAKE UP -- SO THEY'RE IN THE
WORKLOAD IS NOT LIMITED TERM IT
IS I'M GOING I WOULD GUESS THAT
THE CHAIR IS INTERESTED IN THAT.
CLIMATE ADAPTATION POSTUM
WHETHER THERE WOULD BE A NEED TO
HAVE MORE THAN ONE PERSON WORK
ON THAT IN THE FUTURE AFTER THEY
THEY GET IN THERE MEMBERS
QUESTIONS ON THIS MATTER THE
REQUEST [inaudible]
CENTER STERN.
THANK YOU MISTER.
I THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR BRANSON --
WE'RE VERY EXCITED I WOULD SAY
AT LEAST -- IN MY NECK OF THE
WOODS CO AT MORE ACTIVE ROLE FOR
THE CDC AND BUT WAS WAS SORT OF
A STRATEGIC ARM IS NOW BECOMING
REALLY TAKEN STRATEGY IN TRYING
TO BECOME OF OF FUNDING A REAL.
LONG TERM SORT OF FUNDING
ENTITIES RIGHT I THINK IT'S A
POSITIVE DEVELOPMENT -- THERE'S
A LOT OF KNOW HOW BUILT IN THERE
I'M WONDERING THOUGH HOW YOU.
HOW YOU'RE LOOKING AT YOUR
STRATEGY AS OF RIGHT NOW?
BOTH ON A SORT OF ON ON A
REGIONAL BASIS WITH.
WHAT WHAT OUTCOMES YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR HOW ARE YOU
APPROACHING THIS THIS POT?
YOU KNOW THE COMMISSION OF IT'S
INTERESTING SENATE BILL ONE IS
IT DID HAVE A CALL FOR THE
COMMISSION TO DEVELOP AND ADOPT.
CONGESTED MULTI MODAL CONGESTED
A COMPREHENSIVE MULTI MODE LOOK
AT CORD OR PLANTS.
IT'S TO THE COMMISSION HAS NOW
ADOPTED GUIDELINES OVER THIS
LAST YEAR IN CONSULTATION WITH
ALL STAKEHOLDERS.
ON WITH THOSE PLANS WOULD LOOK
LIKE HOW THEY SHOULD BE
DEVELOPED.
THE LONG TERM VISION WOULD BE
THOSE PLANS ARE IN PROCESS RIGHT
NOW AMONG THE REGIONAL AGENCIES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
THEIR MULTI MODAL PLANS THAT
WOULDN'T ENCOMPASS NOT ONLY
HIGHWAYS BUT TRANSIT RAIL ACTED
TRANSPORTATION.
ADDRESSING THE OVERALL STATE
GOALS AND OBJECTIVES THAT WE
HAVE.
BEEN SO IN THE LONG RUN WHAT I
SEE IN THE COMMISSION IN
CONSULTATION WITH THEM.
IS IT THOSE PLANS ARE VERY
IMPORTANT THERE LOCALLY AND
REGIONALLY DEVELOPED.
THROUGH A PUBLIC PROCESS WITH
PRIORITIES FOR INVESTMENT.
AND THEY SHOULD ONLINE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION PLAN.
AND SO IDEALLY NOW THAT WE KNOW
THAT WE HAVE ON GOING
SUSTAINABLE FUNDING THANKFULLY.
TO THE THE DIFFICULT WORK THAT
YOU ALL DID HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE.
NOW WE HAVE CERTAINTY IN FUNDING
OVER THE NEXT DECADE WE CAN WORK
TOWARDS IMPLEMENTING THOSE THOSE
MULTI MODAL CHORD OR PLANS.
BECAUSE WHEN YOU WHEN YOU LOOK
ACROSS THE ENTIRE STATE NOT
EVERY PROJECTS READY TO GO TODAY.
SO IF THERE'S A WAY THAT WE CAN
LINE UP FUNDING STRATEGICALLY TO
MOVE THOSE PLANS FOR THAT'S WHAT
WE NEED TO DO SO THAT WOULD BE
THE VISION.
WITH THE REQUEST THAT WE HAVE
TODAY -- WE DO NEED -- WE ARE
LOOKING AT OUR ORGANIZATIONAL
STRUCTURE AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE HAS BEEN WORKING WITH US
IN THAT REGARD WE ARE A VERY
SMALL STAFF.
AND WE'RE FINDING THAT WITH THIS
NEW -- INCREASE RESPONSIBILITY
TO DO THIS RIGHT WE NEED TO
ALLOW OUR MANAGERS THE TIME TO
STE TO SET THAT STRATEGY.
AND IMPLEMENT THAT STRATEGY AND
THEY'RE NOT NO LONGER ABLE -- TO
YOU KNOW WE'VE ALWAYS PRIDE
OURSELVES UNLESS STAFF BUT
THEY'RE NO LONGER ABLE TO CARRY.
ALL THE WORKLOAD AND STILL STEP
BACK AND CONSIDER WHAT IS THAT
STRATEGY WORKING WITH OUR
REGIONAL PARTNERS.
SO DID YOU DO DO YOU CONCUR DO
YOU SEE THE A POTENTIAL --
BOTTLE NECK IF YOU WILL IN TERMS
OF THE LEVEL OF RESPONSIBILITY
IN LEVEL CAPACITY.
YES SIR SO AND THAT THE THE
COMMISSION IS DOING WE KNOW
PRIMARY THEIR PRIMARY ROLE
THEY'RE SETTING PROGRAM
GUIDELINES ARE DEVELOPING
PROGRAMS OR SOMETIMES SELECTING
PROJECTS FOR COMPETITIVE
PROGRAMS.
AND THEY ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
ALLOCATING FUNDING SO WHEN YOU
APPROPRIATE MONEY FOR
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS YOU'RE
APPROPRIATING A BIG LUMP SUM.
AND THEN **** PROJECTS BECOME
READY FOR AND THE DIFFERENT
STAGES OF DEVELOPMENT AND
CONSTRUCTION THE PROJECT SPONSOR
OFTENTIMES ON CALTRANS SOMETIMES
A A LOCAL TRANSPORTATION AGENCY
WILL GO TO THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION SAY HERE'S OUR
PROJECT.
HERE'S THE STATE ROUTE WE NEED
THIS MUCH MONEY FOR DESIGNER
THIS MUCH MONEY FOR CONSTRUCTION
AND THE COMMISSION AND STAFF.
IS EVALUATING EACH OF THOSE
PROJECTS SO IN ADDITION TO
SETTING OVERALL STRATEGY IN THE
PROGRAM THEY'RE ALSO DOING THIS
PROJECT LEVEL WORK.
SB WHEN INCREASED ON THE%
COMMISSION'S RESPONSIBILITY SORT
OF ON ALL FRONTS THERE'S NEW
PROGRAMS FOR THEM TO MINISTER
AND ABOUT GUIDELINES FOR THERE'S
NEW RULES LIKE THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR JUST MENTIONED.
AND THAT PROJECT LEVEL OVERSIGHT
PIECE HAS ALSO INCREASED TO A
HIGHER LEVEL OF ACCOUNTABILITY
AND OVERSIGHT AND SO ALL OF
THOSE THINGS ARE GOING TO
REQUIRE MORE STAFF THEY HAVE YOU
KNOW ANYWHERE BETWEEN LIKE
FIFTEEN AND SEVENTEEN PEOPLE TO
DO ALL OF THAT.
AND SO IT'S A VERY SMALL STAFF
AND REALLY THERE TO HAVE
SUFFICIENT LEVEL OF OVERSIGHT OF
YOU KNOW FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
ARE TRANSPORTATION FUNDING EVERY
YEAR YOU KNOW YOU'RE GOING TO
NEED TO HAVE THAT INCREASED.
WHAT'S OPEN UP THE PUBLIC
HEARING THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION
IS TO PROVE HIS.
AS BUDGET THIS IS ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM
OVERSIGHT.
THING NOBODY THERE WILL CLOSE
THE PUBLIC COMMENT IN.
ENERGY MOTION.
THERE'S MUCH BY CENTER STERN
PLEASE CALL ROLL.
CASKEY BY JONES.
WHO ARE?
MONNING.
STERN.
RIGHT THAT HAS FIVE VOTERS
APPROVED FIVE ZERO NOW ITEM
NUMBER FOURTEEN IS THE ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION -- PROGRAM AT
ANTICIPATE SOME ACTIVITY ON ATP
WE DID GET A NICE SENATE REPORT
HERE THAT I'D GIVE ME SOME CHEAT --
CHEAT SHEETS ON WHAT I SHOULD BE
ASKING WHAT THE COMMISSION
SHOULD BE DOING ON THE
RECOMMENDATIONS BUT PLEASE LET'S
HAVE YOUR PRESENTATION.
LET'S START WITH THE LA L..
THANK YOU AND SO THIS IS AN
INFORMATIONAL ITEM ON YOUR
AGENDA AND OUR OFFICE WAS ASKED --
TO AS PART OF THE CURRENT YEAR
BUDGET PACKAGE TO DO AB REVIEW
EVALUATION OF THE ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM.
AND IN ADDITION THAT SENATE
OFFICE OF RESEARCH HAS ALSO DONE
A REVIEW -- LOOKING SOMEONE AT
DIFFERENT QUESTIONS AND SO I'LL
PRESENT FIRST ARSES SORT OF MORE
OF THE OVER ARCHING.
AND WHAT'S GOING ON WITH THE
PROGRAM IN THE LAST FIVE YEARS
SENSE AND IT'S BEEN CREATED.
AND AND THEN MISTER LIKE
OBERSTAR'S PRESENTATION IS MORE
FOCUSED ON SOME SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS.
HI I'M CALLING.
THIS IS OURS CORRECT YES YOU'RE
GONNA HEAR A SUMMARY OF TWO
DIFFERENT REPORTS TODAY SO.
AND AND I THINK THE GOOD NEWS
FOR YOU IS THAT I DON'T THINK
THERE'S REALLY ANY
INCONSISTENCIES BETWEEN OUR
FINDINGS OF THE PROGRAM THAT
WHAT THE SENATE UP OFFICE OF
RESEARCH HAS FOUND.
AND THEY WERE IN ANSWERING SOME
WE WERE TASKED WITH DIFFERENT
QUESTIONS -- AND SO IN SOME
CASES WE'VE COME UP WITH
DIFFERENT OPTIONS OF THINGS TO
THINK ABOUT BUT I THINK
EVERYBODY'S AT LEAST ON THE SAME
PAGE ABOUT.
I'M SORT OF THE STATUS OF THINGS.
THAT CAN CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG
BUT I'LL JUST DO AS HE ARE OF
THE SENATE THE RESEARCH OFFICE
IS RIGHT THERE AT DAIS.
SO I WILL JUST GIVE YOU A BRIEF
BACKGROUND ON THE PROGRAM SO THE
ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM
WAS CREATED AS PART OF THAT
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN BUDGET PACKAGE.
AND AND REALLY WHAT THIS DID WAS
TAKE SEVERAL SMALLER I'M
PROGRAMS SAFE ROUTES TO SCHOOLS
A BICYCLE TRANSPORTATION
ACCOUNTS AND PEDESTRIAN ACCOUNTS.
AND COMBINED ALL OF THESE FUNDS
TOGETHER AS WITH SOME FEDERAL
FINES I'M TO CREATE ONE LARGER
PROGRAM WHICH REALLY THE GOALS
BEING TO PUT MORE FOCUS ON
ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION.
OFTENTIMES THE PROJECTS FUNDED
FROM THESE ACCOUNTS WERE SORT OF
LANGUISHING IN NOT BEING DONE IN
A VERY TIMELY MANNER IS MAYBE
THEY WERE AT THE HIGHEST
PRIORITY IS SOME OF THE LARGER
PROJECTS. TO PUT THAT FOCUS ON
AS WELL AS GIVING THE STATE SAM --
ROLE IN SETTING PRIORITIES ARE
EVEN SELECTING PROJECTS FOR
TRANSPORTATION THESE ARE TEND TO
BE VERY SMALL PROJECTS AND WERE
TYPICALLY THOUGHT OF AS SORT OF
LOCAL PROJECTS AND WERE
GENERALLY SELECTED THE LOCAL
LEVEL AND SO.
GIVING THE STATE SOME ROLE IN IN
SELECTING ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS.
I AM SO IN THE ATP WAS CREATED
IN THESE FUNDS WERE CONSOLIDATED
THERE IS ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
FUNDING FOR THE PROGRAM.
SB ONE ADDED ANOTHER HUNDRED
MILLION TOHAVE ABOUT A TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY MILLION
DOLLAR PROGRAM AT THIS TIME.
I'M UNDER THE WAY THE PROGRAM
WAS STRUCTURED THERE'S BASICALLY
THREE POTS OF MONEY AND THERE'S
A 50% POT WHICH IS THE STATEWIDE
COMPONENT OF THE PROGRAM THOSE
PROJECTS ARE SELECTED BY THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION.
THERE'S A 40% PART OF MONEY.
I THERE'S A 40% PART OF MONEY
I'M FOR THE METROPOLITAN
PLANNING ORGANIZATIONS ARE NPOS
AND THEN 10% OF THE FUNDING IS
FOR PROJECTS IN THE SMALL URBAN
AND RURAL REGIONS OF THE STATE.
SO THAT'S THE WAY THE PROGRAM IS
STRUCTURED SO IN OUR REVIEW OF
THE PROGRAM AND WE WERE ASKED TO
LOOK AT WHAT TYPES OF PROJECTS
HAVE BEEN FUNDED WHAT OUTCOMES
IN BENEFITS HAVE BEEN ACHIEVED.
SO IM IN TERMS OF PROJECTS
THERE HAVE BEEN SEVEN HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY SIX PROJECTS TO DATE
PROGRAMMED INTO THE ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM.
AND IT SEVENTY FIVE ABOUT 75% OF
THOSE ARE INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS SO THIS COULD BE
BUILDING A BIKE LANE IMPROVING A
SIDEWALK INSTALLING IT I'D
TRAFFIC CROSSING PEDESTRIAN
CROSSING SIGNAL THOSE TYPES OF
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS.
I'M AND THE REMAINDER OF THE
PROJECTS TEND TO BE -- PLANNING
WORK AS WELL AS FINDING THAT
WITH THE STATE'S ON ACTIVE
ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION RESOURCE
CENTER WITHIN CALTRANS -- WHEN
WE LOOK AT THE TYPES OF PROJECTS
THAT HAVE BEEN FUNDED ACROSS THE
DIFFERENT -- COMPONENTS OF THE
PROGRAM THE STATEWIDE MPO AND
THE SMALL URBAN AND RURAL.
AND THE TYPES OF PROJECTS BEING
FUNDED IN THESE DIFFERENT POTS
ARE ARE PRETTY SIMILAR AND WE'RE
SEEING A LOT OF THE SAME TYPES
OF PROJECTS THE SAME SORT OF
DOLLAR AMOUNT DOLLAR VALUE OF
PROJECTS.
ON AND SO THERE IS NOTHING THAT
REALLY JUMPED OUT TO US FIVE
SAYING WELL THIS COMPONENT THE
PROGRAM TENDS TO BE FINDING
CERTAIN TYPES OF PROJECTS OR
MEETING CERTAIN GOALS.
AND THIS PROGRAMS READING
SOMETHING DIFFERENT SO IT'S VERY
SIMILAR.
I'M ANOTHER THING THAT WE WOULD
KNOW IS THAT SINCE THE INCEPTION
OF THE PROGRAM AND THE PROJECTS
ARE ALL THESE TEND TO BE VERY
SMALL DOLLAR VALUE PROJECTS THEM
IMPROVING A SIDEWALK OR PUTTING
IN A BIKE LANE IS.
A MUCH SMALLER DOLLAR AMOUNT
THAN SOME OF OUR LARGER
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
IMPROVEMENTS.
BUT OVER TIME WE ARE SEEING THAT
THESE PROJECTS HAVE GOTTEN
SOMEWHAT BIGGER IN TERMS OF THE
DOLLAR VALUE.
I'M AND IT THAT THAT WOULD ALL
BE EXPLAINED JUST BY SORT OF
RISING CONSTRUCTION COSTS AND SO
IT DOES APPEAR THAT AS THE
PROGRAM IS IS BECOMING MORE
ESTABLISH THAT.
PROJECT SPONSORS ARE MOVING I'M
MORE AND MORE TOWARDS A LARGER
PROJECT ONE OF THE GOALS WHEN
THE PROGRAM WAS CREATED.
AND WISE OR ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT IT WOULD ALLOW FOR WOULD BE
REALLY THESE LARGER MORE
TRANSFORMATIVE TYPES OF PROJECTS
WITH THE GOAL OF HAVING ENOUGH
OF A INFRASTRUCTURE CHANGE OR
IMPROVEMENT. TO REALLY ALLOW
TRAVELS TRAVELERS TO HAVE A MOOD
SHIFT -- SO THAT THEY COULD TAKE
SOME TRIPS NOT BY DRIVING BUT
INSTEAD BY WALKING OR BIKING AND
YOU YOU HAVE TO HAVE ENOUGH OF A
SORT OF A NETWORK OF
IMPROVEMENTS IN MANY CASES FOR
THAT TO ACTUALLY.
I'M BE WORKABLE FOR PEOPLE.
AND SO IT DOES APPEAR THAT THE
PROGRAM COULD BE MOVING TOWARD
SOME OF THOSE LARGER PROJECTS.
AND THE OTHER THING WE'RE ASKED
TO LOOK AT IS AND BENEFITS OF
THE PROJECTS ARE OUTCOMES OF THE
PROGRAM HOW EFFECTIVE IS A AT
THAT MEETING AT SCHOOLS.
AND I'M WITH THE PRIMARY GOAL
THAT WE WOULD YOU KNOW CARE
ABOUT IS IS IT INCREASING
WALKING AND BIKING THAT'S THE
WHOLE POINT OF THE PROGRAM I'M
NOT WHAT.
I TOLD POINT BY IN THE MAIN LINE
I'M AND WE DON'T KNOW -- THERE
AT THE DATA THAT'S BEEN
COLLECTED RIGHT NOW IS REALLY
INSUFFICIENT TO BE ABLE TO TELL
US WHAT THE OUTCOMES ARE AT THE
PROGRAM IN THAT REGARD.
AND I WILL CARRY OUT THAT ALSO
WAS SAYING THAT I'M JUST GIVEN
THE TIMING AND THE RELATIVE
NEWNESS OF THIS PROGRAM IT'S
BEEN IN EFFECT FOR FIVE YEARS
BUT BECAUSE IT TAKES MANY YEARS
FOR PROJECT TO BE DESIGNED AND
CONSTRUCTED AND COMPLETED --
THERE HAVE ONLY JUST IN THIS
PAST YEAR BEEN THE FIRST ROUND
OF SORT OF PROJECT COMPLETION
REPORTS THAT HAD BECOME
AVAILABLE SO WE'RE LOOKING AT A
SOMEWHAT LIMITED DATA SAID AND
THIS IS A REALLY GOOD.
TIME LINE FOR YOU ALL TO BE
LOOKING AT IF THERE NEEDS TO BE
TWEAKS ARE CHANGES TO THE WAY
INFORMATION IS REPORTED BECAUSE
IT'S STILL RELATIVELY NEW SO
THERE WERE ABOUT. SIXTY FIVE
PROJECTS THAT HAVE REPORTED OUT
AT THAT SEVEN HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SIX THAT ARE COMPLETED
AND I'VE COME TO THE REPORTERS
THAT REPORTING.
PART OF THAT THE PROGRAM.
I'M IS SO UNFORTUNATELY WE DON'T
KNOW IF THE PROGRAM IS MAKING
MEANINGFUL IMPROVEMENTS AND
WALKING AND BIKING.
AND EVEN IF YOU HAD THE YOU KNOW
ON THE STREETS THEY PUT DOWN
THOSE -- WIRES OR CORDS THE U.
CARS GO OVER IN A COUNT HOW MANY
IT IS THE PET PEDESTRIANS WOULD
JUST WALK OVER THAT THERE WOULD
BE LIKE A OKAY WALK OVER THIS I
DON'T KNOW WHY IT'S THERE.
JUST GO AHEAD YEAH AND SAYS YOU
HAVE RECOMMENDATIONS FOR US
RIGHT.
WE DO AND IF IF I COULD JUST
BRIEFLY FINISH THERE THAT THE
FINDING SO WE WERE ALSO ASKED TO
LOOK AT WHETHER ONE OF THE GOALS
OF THE PROGRAM IS ARE PROJECTS
BENEFITING DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES A MINIMUM OF 25% OF
THE FANS HAVE TO BENEFIT.
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES THE
PROGRAM DOES APPEAR TO BE
MEETING THATGOAL AND 88% OF THE
PROJECTS THAT WERE EITHER IN A
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY OR WERE
OUTSIDE A DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITY THAT HAD A BENEFIT. TO
A DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY
[inaudible]
BUT LIKEWISE.
IT MAY HAVE BEEN BUILT A
DISPENSED MANY BUT WE DON'T KNOW
IF ANYBODY'S GETTING ON THEIR
BIKE OR THEY'RE WALKING AFTER
IT'S BEEN BUILT BECAUSE THE DATA
IS.
PRESSING OKAY GOT IT.
AND THAT WE WERE ASKED TO LOOK
WHETHER THERE'S BENEFITS TO THE
HIGHWAY SYSTEM THERE'S NO ON
THESE TEND TO BE LOCAL PROJECTS
SO THERE'S NO SPECIFIC CARVE OUT
FOR BENEFITING THE STATE HIGHWAY
SYSTEM.
I'M AND THERE'S OTHER GOALS OF
THE PROGRAM HAS I'M GHG
REDUCTIONS PUBLIC HEALTH
BENEFITS THOSE TEND TO SORT OF
BE TIED TO IF YOU'RE SEEING AN
INCREASE IN WALKING AND BIKING.
I'M MORE YOU'E SEEING THA MODE
SHIFT AND SO AGAIN IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT TO TELL THOSE
ESPECIALLY WITHOUT ANY ACCURATE
DATA ON ON THE WALKING AND
BIKING.
AND IF WE WERE ALSO ASKED TO
LOOK AT YOU KNOW IMPLEMENTATION
IT CHALLENGES AND AND AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON IMPROVING THE
PROGRAM.
IN TERMS OF IMPLEMENTATION
CHALLENGES AND ONE OF THE THINGS
THE WAY THE PROGRAM IS SET UP AT
LEAST IN THIS LAST SPENDING
CYCLE IS WHY YOU HAVE THESE FOUR
POTS OF MONEY.
AND YOU HAVE A AND P. O. COULD
CHOOSE AND PRIORITIZE OUR OWN
PROJECT WITHIN THEIR PART OF
MANY.
THEY ARE LIMITED TO THE PROJECTS
THAT OUR FIRST COMPETED IN THE
STATEWIDE COMPETITION.
AND THEN THE PROJECTS THAT DON'T
GET FUNDED THROUGH THE STATE
WIDE PORTION OF THE PROGRAM.
GET SENT DOWN BASICALLY TO THE
I'M PL IS FOR THEM TO CHOOSE AND
SO BECAUSE THERE IS AND IN SOME
PROJECT SPONSORS ARE HIRING
CONSULTANTS TO HELP THEM GET
THROUGH THE APPLICATION PROCESS.
IT CAN BE I AND I IN OTHER SOME
WORKLOAD THAT GOES ALONG WITH
APPLYING GO INTO THAT.
CTC PROCESS EVIDENTLY IT'S A
DIFFICULT APPLICATION PROCESS TO
GET THROUGH.
OUR YEAH I THINK WE HAVE.
YEAH WE HAD HEARD THAT FROM A
FROM SOME OF THE PROJECT
SPONSORS THAT WE TALKED TO I
THINK THE CDC HAS TRIED TO
RESPOND BY CREATING.
MORE STREAMLINED VERSIONS OF
APPLICATIONS FOR SMALLER
PROJECTS BUT THERE IS STILL
DEFINITELY LIKE AN
ADMINISTRATIVE WORKLOAD THAT
THEY'RE GONNA HAVE TO GO THROUGH.
AND SO THAT COULD SORT OF SCARE
OFF SOME PROJECT SPONSORS MAYBE
OR IT'S JUST NOT WORTH IT TO
THEM TO APPLY TO YOU COULD BE
HAVING A SITUATION WHERE.
THE NPOS ARE BEING SORT OF
ARTIFICIALLY LIMITED AND NOT
ABLE TO PICK THE PROJECTS THAT
ARE THEIR HIGHEST PRIORITY
BECAUSE THEY'RE LIMITED TO THE
PROJECTS THAT ARE COMING OUT OF
THE STATEWIDE COMPETITION.
SO IN TERMS OF OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS AND THE OBVIOUS
ONE IS MAKE SURE WE'RE
COLLECTING THE DATA -- YOU'RE
GONNA WANT TO UNDERSTAND HOW
THIS PROGRAM IS INCREASING
WALKING AND BIKING TO UNDERSTAND
THE EFFECTIVENESS OF THE PROGRAM
I'M GOING FORWARD. ONE OF THE
THINGS TO BE MINDFUL OF IS TO
REALLY UNDERSTAND THE WALKING
AND BIKING INCREASE YOU HAVE TO
DO SORT OF COUNTS GO OUT BEFORE
THE PROJECT AND HOW MANY PEOPLE
ARE WALKING HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE
BIKING AND LIKE YOU SAID MISTER
CHAIR YOU CAN'T JUST BUT WHEN.
OTHER STRIPS DOWN INTO ACCOUNT
SO THERE'S OTHER METHODOLOGIES
FOR DOING IT -- BUT THAT CAN BE
EXPENSIVE ESPECIALLY IF YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT A VERY SMALL
PROJECT TO MAKE VERY SMALL
IMPROVEMENTS.
YOU'RE GONNA WANT TO THINK ABOUT
WHICH PROJECTS DOES IT MAKE THE
MOST SENSE SIGN MAYBE IT'S THE
BIGGER PROJECTS MAYBE AT CERTAIN
TYPES OF PROJECTS.
I'M A COLLEGE STUDENT JOB
DOESN'T IT FOR THE SUMMER TO SIT
THERE WITH THE TICKER KICKING
QUE QUE COUNT ON THEN YOUR FINAL
THOUGH AND THEN.
THE LAST TWO RECOMMENDATIONS SO.
CONSIDER WHAT THE ROLE OF THE
STATEWIDE COMPONENT OF THE
PROGRAM IS SO WHEN WHEN THIS IS
CREATED THE IDEA IS TO PROVIDE
MORE HIGHLIGHT MORE IMPORTANT
SIGN ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION.
AND GIVE THE STATE A ROLE IN
SETTING PRIORITIES AND SELECTING
PROJECTS.
AND THESE TEND OTHERWISE WOULD
BE VERY LOCAL PROJECTS THAT
WOULD BE DETERMINE WHAT THE
PRIORITY IS AT A LOCAL OR
REGIONAL LEVEL.
AND SO IF YOU'RE GONNA HAVE THE
STATE MAKING THAT THAT PRIORITY
SETTING ARE PROJECTS SELECTION
THE SETTING AND HAVING NOT ROLL
THINKING ABOUT WHAT MAKES THE
MOST SENSE FOR PROJECTS THAT ARE
SELECTED AT THE STATE LEVEL.
SO WHEN WE LOOKED AT A HER
THOUGHT IS HAVING THESE LARGER
MORE TRANSFORMATIVE PROJECTS
WHERE YOU MAY BE REALLY BUILDING
OUT A NETWORK OF BIKE LANES OR
MAKING ENOUGH IMPROVEMENTS THAT
YOU WOULD SEE AS SIGNIFICANT
MODE SHIFT.
THOSE TYPES OF PROJECTS AND WE
TEND TO BE A REALLY GOOD FIT FOR
THE STATEWIDE COMPONENT.
OF THE PROGRAM AND IT MAKES
SENSE BECAUSE A LOCAL COMMUNITY
MAYBE A CITY WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO
PULL TOGETHER ENOUGH FUNDING TO
DO THAT TYPE OF A PROJECT ON
THEIR OWN AND SO IT IT MAKES
SENSE THAT THE STATE WOULD COME
IN AND HAVE A PROGRAM FOR DOING
THOSE.
TYPES OF PROJECTS I'M YOU MAY
HAVE OTHER GOALS THAT YOU WANT
THAT -- COMPONENT OF THE PROGRAM
TO ACHIEVE -- YOU MAY WANT TO
THINK ABOUT THE HAVING THE
DIFFERENT COMPONENTS ACHIEVE
DIFFERENT GOALS HAVING THREE
COMPONENTS OF THE PROGRAM.
WITH AND DIFFERENT GROUPS
SELECTING THE PROJECTS BUT
THEY'RE ALL KIND OF MEETING THE
SAME GOALS AND THEY'RE ALL
TRYING TO SEX SELECT THE SAME
PROJECTS.
GOING TO BEG THE QUESTION OF
WHAT DO YOU GETTING OUT OF THE
STATE HAVING THIS OVERALL ROLE
IN IT IF WE'RE JUST PICKING.
MUCH OF THE SAME TYPES OF
PROJECTS WE WOULD PICK ANYWAYS
IF YOU JUST YOU KNOW LET THAT
THE REGION'S AND LOCAL AGENCIES
SELECT THE PROJECTS.
AND AND SO YOU MAY WANT TO THINK
ABOUT.
I'M IN A SETTING DIFFERENT GOALS
RE FRAMING THE STATEWIDE
COMPONENT AND AS YOU DO THAT
THEN YOU'RE GOING TO ALSO NEED
TO ADDRESS ISSUES OF HOW THE
PROGRAM IS ADMINISTERED.
I'M RIGHT NOW HAVING EVERYTHING
FLOW THROUGH CTC WITH THE WAY
THE PROGRAM SET UP KIND OF MAKES
SENSE -- BUT IF YOU'RE CHANGING
YOU KNOW YOU DON'T WANT
EVERYBODY HAVE TO APPLY FOR IT
THE STATE WIDE PROGRAM FIRST.
IF THERE REALLY IS A DIFFERENT
KIND OF PROJECT A REGION YEAH
THE THE EIGHTY SO IF YOU'RE
GONNA WANT TO THINK THROUGH THAT
THE ADMINISTRATIVE IMPLICATIONS
ON THE PROGRAM AS YOU THINK
THROUGH THAT.
YOU'RE SUGGESTING THAT THE STATE
STREAMLINED THE PROCESS.
SO THAT THE THE LOCAL PEOPLE GET
TO HAVE THE MONEY IN WILL BE
ABLE TO COMPETE AT THE OLD THE
REGIONAL LEVEL YEAH SO THAT'S
OUR LAST RECOMMENDATION IS
CONSIDER PROVIDING MORE
FLEXIBILITY IS TO THE M. PO'S.
SO RIGHT NOW THEY'RE LIMITED TO
THIS POOL OF PROJECTS IT DIDN'T
GET FUNDED THROUGH THE STATE
RIGHT COMPETITION SO WE THINK AT
A MINIMUM MAYBE LIKE OPEN THAT
UP ON AND PROVIDE MORE
FLEXIBILITY THERE SO THAT.
THERE'S NOT PROJECTS THAT MIGHT
BE A HIGH LOCAL PRIORITY THE END
UP GETTING EXCLUDED FROM
ELIGIBILITY FOR THE PROGRAM.
I'M AND YOU COULD MAKE A CHANGE
AS SIMPLE AS THAT WERE YOU COULD
DO MORE WERE YOU INSTEAD OF
HAVING AND RIGHT NOW WE TALKED
IN THE LAST SAME ABOUT SORT OF
PROJECT LEVEL OVERSIGHT IN THE
C. T. C. ALLOCATING FUNDING BY
PHASE OF A PROJECT -- THERE
DOING THAT FOR ALL OF THESE
ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS --
YOU COULD MOVE AWAY FROM THAT
AND YOU COULD MOVE TO MORE OF
YOU KNOW SORT OF A BLOCK GRANT
TYPE APPROACH AND HAVE AND OTHER
TYPES OF REPORTING THAT YOU HAVE
THE NPOS REPORT BACK OR EVEN THE
SMALLER REGIONS REPORT BACK TO
THE STATE ON HOW THE FUNDS WERE.
SPENT BUT WE DO THINK GIVING
THEM MORE FLEXIBILITY AND AND AT
LEAST SOME WAY IS SOMETHING THAT
YOU'RE GONNA WANT TO CONSIDER
AND AGAIN AS YOU THINK ABOUT
CHANGING THAT THE REGIONAL POT
OF MONEY IN THE STATE PART OF
MANY AGAIN THAT'S GOING TO HAVE
IMPLICATIONS FOR HOW THE PROGRAM.
IS JUST.
TURN OVER ALL.
THANK YOU I'M SURE MY MEMBERS
WILL HAVE QUESTIONS NOW WE HAVE --
KID LINK OVER SIR FROM THE
SENATE OFFICE RESEARCH WELCOME
MR LINK OVER STAR THANK YOU
MISTER ENTER THE REPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I APPRECIATE
YOU HAVING ME HERE TO DISCUSS --
OF THE PROJECT AND THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE
SUGGESTIONS THAT WE THAT WE MADE
FOR FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION --
JUST BUT YOU KNOW A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT -- HOW THIS PROJECT CAME
ABOUT AT THE REQUEST F YOUR
STAFF WE WERE ASKED TO LOOK?
SPECIFICALLY AT THE THE PROGRAM
PERFORMANCE BUT SPECIFICALLY
ADDS THE PROJECT SELECTION AND
ALLOCATION OF FUNDING AND AND
HOW THAT'S WORKING AND WHETHER
THAT COULD BE -- IMPROVED AND SO
OUR RECOMMENDATIONS SUGGESTIONS
I KEEPING RECOMMENDATIONS BUT
OUR SUGGESTIONS FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION -- FOCUSED
PRIMARILY ON ON THAT AREA -- IN
CONDUCTING THIS -- WE
INTERVIEWED STAFF FROM BOTH THE
COMMISSION AND FROM CALTRANS AS
WELL AS ABOUT A DOZEN
STAKEHOLDERS OR MORE.
REPRESENTATIVE OF OF DIFFERENT.
DIFFERENT ENTITIES SOME OF THE
MPO THE SOME OF THE CITIES AND
COUNTIES WHO APPLIED FOR FUNDING --
ADVOCACY GROUPS TO SUPPORT
ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION AND SOCIAL
EQUITY -- IN ORDER TO TRY AND
GET THEIR INPUT ON WHAT'S
WORKING AND WHAT COULD BE
IMPROVED -- IN ADDITION WE
LOOKED AT THE THE DATA THE
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE DATA ON THE
PROJECTS SUBMITTED IN THOSE
SELECTED THE THAT THE COMMISSION
PUBLISHES -- AND I ALSO
INDEPENDENT THIS PROJECT IN
PRIOR THIS PROJECT HAD SERVED AS
A PHONE TWO REVIEWER -- FOR FOR
THIS PROGRAM LOOKING AT PROJECTS --
DURING THE THIRD AND THE FOURTH
CYCLES -- BECAUSE I WANTED TO
GET MORE -- UNDERSTANDING OF HOW
THE PROGRAM WAS WORKING SO I WAS.
BASING AYE.
AYE TAKING INTO ACCOUNT THAT
INFORMATION AS WELL ANOTHER
SENATE EMPLOYEE WITH HANDS ON
KNOWLEDGE STILL VERY GOOD -- ARE
KEY FINDINGS -- NUMBER ONE THE
PROGRAM IS EXTREMELY POPULAR
IT'S VERY MUCH OVERSUBSCRIBED
LOTS MORE REQUEST FOR FUNDING
THAT IS AVAILABLE -- AND A
HIGHLY ENGAGE STAKEHOLDER GROUP
THERE IS A LOT OF PARTICIPATION
A LOT OF UP.
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO HAVE A HANDS
ON IMPACT ON THE PROCESS.
AMONG THE STATE BECAUSE WE
TALKED TO A VIRTUALLY EVERYBODY
SUPPORTS THE COMPETITIVE NATURE
OF THE PROGRAM NOBODY WANTED.
TO BASICALLY JUST ALLOCATE THE
FUNDING STRICTLY BY FORMULA AND
NOT HAVE A COMPETITIVE PROCESS --
A LOT OF PEOPLE SAY IT DOES
ALLOW US TO FIND THE BEST
PROJECTS REGARDLESS OF WHERE
THEY ARE IN THE STATE -- IT
ALLOWS SMALL COMMUNITIES TO
PUNCH ABOVE THEIR WEIGHT -- TO
GET MORE FUNDING THAN THEY MIGHT
UNDER HAVE ANY CHANCE OF GETTING
ON THEIR EVEN SEVERAL YEARS OF A
A FORMULA ALLOCATION -- AND SOME
PEOPLE ALSO SAID THAT THE STATE
WIDE.
STRUCTURE OF THE PROJECT OF THE
PROGRAM -- REDUCES LOCAL.
LOCAL POLITICS AND IN THEIR VIEW --
RESULTS IN MORE OBJECTIVE REVIEW
OF OF THE PROJECT BENEFITS -- WE
DID ALSO HEAR FROM A LOT OF
STAKEHOLDERS THAT -- THE
APPLICATION PROCESS IS VERY
COSTS AND LABOR.
INTENSIVE ONE OF THE MOST --
COST LABOR INTENSIVE
APPLICATIONS THEY DO SEVERAL
SEVERAL APPLICANTS TOLD US THAT --
IN PART OF THE REASON FOR THAT
IS THAT.
THE CDC IS TRYING TO GATHER A
LOT OF DATA -- TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT THE PROJECTS ARE
ACCOMPLISHING AS WELL AS A
NARRATIVE TO UNDERSTAND WHAT IS
THIS PROJECT REALLY TRYING TO DO
BECAUSE WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS.
INCREASE WALKING AND BIKING IT'S
NOT NECESSARILY WITHOUT A
COMPELLING NARRATIVE IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY CLEAR.
HOW THESE PARTICULAR
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS ARE
GONNA DO WHAT WE'RE WANTING THEM
TO DO SO THERE'S A LOT OF WORK
THAT GOES INTO IT -- AND BUT
THAT THAT WE RECOGNIZE IMPORTANT
BECAUSE WE NEED THAT FOR DOING
PROJECT EVALUATION -- BUT THAT
IS A CHALLENGE.
SOME OF THE OUR VERTICALLY THE
REGIONAL STAKEHOLDERS TOLD US
THAT -- THE CHALLENGES THE
STATEWIDE HALF OF THE PROGRAM IN
PARTICULAR DOESN'T.
CONSIDER THEIR REGIONAL
PRIORITIES EVERY -- MPO -- EVERY
VETERINARIAN THE STATE HAS OUR
GOALS AND PLANS THAT THEY HAVE
TO INFLUENCE TO STABLE COMMUNITY
STRATEGIES CONGESTION MEDICATION
AIR QUALITY LOTS OF DIFFERENT
THINGS THAT.
WE EXPECT THEM TO DELIVER ON BUT
WHAT THEY TOLD US IS THAT THIS
STATEWIDE WHICHEVER HALF MONEY
THIS PROGRAM COMES FROM.
DOESN'T.
NECESSARILY TAKE IN THE
CONSIDERATION WHICH PROJECTS ARE.
ARE GOING TO HELP THE REGION'S
MEET THOSE GOALS -- SO THAT'S A
CHALLENGE FOR THEM THEY THEY GET
WHATEVER COMES OUT OF THE THE
STATEWIDE COMPETITION BUT IT MAY
OR MAY NOT BE SOMETHING THAT
MOVES THE NEEDLE -- THERE ALSO
SOME QUESTIONS RAISED ABOUT THE
SELECTION PROCESS VERY COMPLEX
REFLECTION PROCESS.
LOTS OF OVER FIVE HUNDRED
PROJECTS THAT ARE THAT ARE
SUBMITTED -- AND TO WHETHER THAT
PROCESS IS ABLE TO REALLY SELECT.
THE BEST PROJECTS THE AS I SAID
THE COMPANY THE PREMISE OF THE
PROGRAM IS WE SHOULD BE FINDING
THE BEST PROJECTS WHEREVER THEY
ARE IN THE STATE -- BUT UNDER
THE STATE'S SELECTION PROCESS
THERE ARE. TWO REVIEWERS THAT
LOOK AT EACH PARTICULAR PROJECT
AND THOSE ARE HERE THEY COME
FROM A WIDE RANGE OF EXPERTISE
YOU MAY HAVE ENGINEERS YU MAY
HAVE PUBLIC HEALTH PEOPLE.
ADVOCATES A WIDE RANGE OF OF
FOLKS BRING THEIR PERSPECTIVE --
AND THOUGH THE GROUP THE
COMMISSION HAS PUT TOGETHER A
VERY ROBUST RUBRIC.
THERE IS STILL OBVIOUSLY A A
ROOM FOR SUBJECTIVITY ANYTIME
YOU HAVE MULTIPLE PEOPLE COMING
FROM DIFFERENT BACKGROUNDS WE
HAVE A PROGRAM THAT'S SO
COMPETITIVE THE ONE POINT.
IS THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN -- IN
MANY CASES BEING FUNDED OR NOT --
IF.
YOU HAVE A REVIEWERTHAT LOOKS
AT IT AND IS MAYBE A LITTLE MORE
GENEROUS REVIEWER MAYBE COMES AT
IT FROM A DIFFERENT -- EMPHASIS
AND YOU DON'T HAVE.
SOMEONE SORT OF BALANCING THAT
OUT FROM A WIDE RANGE OF OF
EXPERTISE.
YOU CAN GET SOME SOME VERY
ABILITY OR SAID SOMETHING IF I
AM VERY ABILITY THAT WE THINK
MIGHT.
MIGHT IN.
INFLUENCE WHY SOME PROJECTS.
SCORE HIGHER THAN OTHER VERY
SIMILAR PROJECTS SO -- THAT'S A
CHALLENGE WITH THE WAY THAT THE
PROJECT WITH THE PROCESSES.
IS STRUCTURED.
IN TERMS OF LOOKING AT THE DATA --
WE DID FIND THAT MOST AT LEAST
AMONG THE 40% THAT GOES TO THE
THE LARGE NPOS I DO WANT TO
CLARIFY ONE THING THAT LA --
SAID -- DIRECTLY EIGHTEEN M. P.
O.'S IN THE STATE THE THE 40%
SHARE IS THOSE TEN NPOS.
THAT -- ARE OF TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND OR MORE.
THERE'S EIGHT OTHER NPOS THAT
ARE SMALLER.
THEY ARE CAPTURED IN THE 10% OF
RURAL AND SMALL URBAN COMPONENT
OF THE PROGRAM.
THEY DO HOWEVER.
HAVE.
SUSTAINABILITY GOALS AND OTHER
OTHER REQUIREMENTS THAT THAT THE
LARGE ONES TO AS WELL TALK ABOUT
THAT LATER -- BUT AMONG THE
LARGE POS MOST OF THE TEN OF
THIS TEN SEVEN OF THEM DID
RECEIVE A SHARE OF THE OVERALL
STATE POT OVER THE LIFE OF THE
PROGRAM.
THAT'S COMMENSURATE ROUGHLY WITH
THEIR SHARE OF THE POPULATION OF
THERE WERE.
THREE AREAS THAT HAVE HAVE
UNDERPERFORMED AND I DIDN'T DIG
INTO.
DEPTH INTO SPECIFICALLY WHAT
WHAT WHAT THEY HAVE IN THE FOR
THE FACTORS THAT THAT'S A MATTER --
FOR FOR SITUATION BUT THREE OF
THEM DID SIGNIFICANTLY UNDER
PERFORMED -- WELL THE SMALLER
MINERAL -- AND THESE HAVE AS A
COLLECTIVE -- PERFORM PRETTY
WELL THEY REPRESENT 8% OF
POPULATION BUT ABOUT 13% OF THE
PROJECT FUNDING. TO THAT'S GOOD
BUT IF YOU LOOK AT IT -- A LOT
OF THAT FUNDING GOES TO JUST TWO
OR THREE OF THE REGIONS AND A
COUPLE OF THE OF THE SMALLER HER
DOING VERY WELL BUT THERE'S A
LOT OF FOLKS WHO AREN'T SO
THAT'S JUST SOMETHING TO KEEP IN
MIND.
AS WE LOOK AT HOW WELL THE
PROGRAM IS IS IN IS THAT BECAUSE
A LOT OF THE WEATHER SMALL
PROJECTS IT JUST.
COSTS SO MUCH MONEY ON THAT AND
AND THE SMALLER PROJECTS MEAN
WHEN YOU SAY IT'S 13% OF THE PIE.
AND IT'S ONLY PERCENT POPULATION
I SORT OF THINK IT'S IT'S OKAY
BY I GUESS IT'S RURAL SO IT'S
SPREAD OUT AND SURE THAT'S THE
THAT'S THE EIGHT SMALLER NPOS
AND ALL OF THE RULES TOGETHER I
THINK IT'S ABOUT THOSE REGIONS
HAVE.
GOT ABOUT A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS OVER THE FOUR CYCLES IN --
IN STATE FUNDING IT THEY WOULD
HAVE GOTTEN IF YOU DID IT BY A
STRICT.
POPULATION MODEL THEY WOULD HAVE.
GOTTEN.
THAT THAT THAT PART OF THE THOSE
AND THESE COLLECTIVELY WITH
ABOUT SEVENTY MILLION NOW HOW
THAT GOT.
DISTRIBUTED IN PARTICULAR
PROJECTS I DON'T KNOW AND ARE
THERE MORE.
RURAL PROJECTS IN JUST IN BALK
NUMBER BECAUSE YOU JUST WARY
ATTEND THE URBAN AND SUBURBAN
PROJECTS OR IS THAT.
IS THAT'S NOT IT REALLY I
HONESTLY HAVEN'T LOOKED AT OKAY
WE HAVEN'T LOOKED AT YOU KNOW
HOW THAT BREAKS DOWN IN TERMS OF
CONTINUE.
AND IF YOU DO A JURISDICTIONS
DID PARTICULARLY WELL -- FOR
WHATEVER REASON MAYBE THEY
THEY'VE.
GOT VERTICALLY GOOD AT AT YOU
KNOW WORKING AT THIS AT THIS
PROGRAM BUT THERE ARE A LOT OF
REGIONS ARE BEING -- YOU KNOW
THERE HAVE NOT PERFORMED ALL
THAT WELL SO THAT'S JUST ANOTHER
FACTOR TO CONSIDER.
ANOTHER THING WHEN LOOKING AT
THE DATA AND THIS WAS ALREADY
REFERENCE BY -- THE LA OVER THE
AVERAGE PROJECTS SIZE BOTH OF
SUBMITTED PROJECT APPLICATIONS
AND THOSE AWARDED HAS.
GONE UP SIGNIFICANTLY IN
PREDICAMENT CYCLE THREE TO CYCLE
FOR IT DOUBLED FROM AN AVERAGE
PROJECT SIZE ABOUT TWO POINT
THREE TO FOUR POINT SIX MILLION
SO.
A PART OF THAT IS CERTAINLY THE
COMMISSION HAS.
A AS A POLICY MATTER OF SAID
THEY WANT TO FIND MORE
TRANSFORMATIONAL PROJECTS BUT
AND THAT'S THAT'S IMPORTANT.
POLICY GOAL TO CONSIDER -- GIVEN
THE CURRENT FUNDING IT HAS
CAUSED A PRECIPITOUS DROP IN THE
NUMBER OF APPLICATIONS HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO FIND AND THAT'S JUST A
DURING YOUR RESEARCH WAS THAT
BECAUSE LET'S SAY IT'S A SMALL
PROJECT.
INSTEAD OF DOING FOUR MILES OF
BIKE PATHS ARE DOING FIVE MILES
TO BY PASS CYLINDER SMALL.
I SIZE OR IS IT BECAUSE ONE MILE
OF BIKE PATH COSTS MORE MONEY
THAN IT DID. FOUR YEARS AGO.
WHERE DID I GET NOW INTO THAT
LEVEL OF GRANULARITY BUT I WOULD
SAY OVER TO A TWO YEARS OF SUCH
CYCLE TO SEE?
THE A DOUBLING OF THE PROJECT
SIZE IS PROBABLY CAN'T BE.
ACCOUNTED FOR BY SIMPLY -- THAT
BUT MAYBE MAYBE THE COMMISSION
HAS DONE MORE.
DIGGING INTO THIS WE GET TO THAT
LATER.
I DON'T THINK IT'S COMPLETELY
EXPLAINED BY JUST INCREASING
CONSTRUCTION COSTA OKAY.
HI CONTINUE SO.
SO ANYWAY TO OUR OUR SUGGESTIONS --
AND I WOULD SAY I THINK THE LA --
SAID WE WE DON'T NECESSARILY WE
WERE LOOKING SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT
THINGS WE DON'T NECESSARILY
DISAGREE.
WITH THEIR SUGGESTIONS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS EITHER -- A LOT
OF IT DEPENDS ON WHAT POLICY
OBJECTIVES YOU WANT TO ADDRESS --
ONE THING WE SUGGEST IS OF
INCREASING THE SHARE OF THE
FUNDING THAT GOES TO THAT LARGE
NPO COMPONENT CURRENTLY IT'S 40%
OF THE TOTAL BY -- BUT THE SAME
TIME.
EXCLUDING THEM FROM THE THE
STATE WIDE PORTIONS OF
ESSENTIALLY THE STATEWIDE
COMPONENT WOULD BECOME SOMETHING
FOR THE RURAL REGIONS IN THIS
AND THE SMALLER REGIONS OF THE
COMMISSION WOULD WOULD.
OVERSEE -- THIS WOULD ACCOMPLISH
A COUPLE OF COULD ACCOMPLISH A
COUPLE OF THINGS -- THE REASONS
AGAIN HAVE THAT RESPONSIBILITY
IN THIS WOULD GIVE THEM MORE OF
A TOOL TO TO ADDRESS THE ADDRESS
THEIR GOALS -- IT WOULD ALSO
ADDRESS THE REGIONAL EQUITY
QUESTION TO THE BECAUSE IT WOULD
ENSURE THAT EACH.
OF THE LARGE REGIONS WAS GETTING
THEIR REPORT PROPORTIONATE SHARE
WHILE THERE WOULD STILL BE A
COMPETITION WITHIN THE REGION --
AND YOU WOULD HAVE REVIEWERS.
WITH GREATER FOR WHO HAD GREATER
PRESUMABLY GREATER FAMILIARITY
WITH THE LOCAL ENVIRONMENT AND
THEN MIGHT.
BRING A DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE
THAN THE STATEWIDE REVIEWER WHO
MAY NOT.
HAVE ANY FAMILIARITY WITH WHAT
THE PARTICULARS OF THE ISSUES IN
THE REGION ARE IN IT WOULD
PRESUMABLY HELP THAT MEET THOSE
REGIONAL PRIORITIES THEY UPSET
BUT THAT NORTE MIGHT HAVE MORE
SENSITIVITY TO WILL HOW THE
REGION ITSELF WAS TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH REGION PRIORITIES AND
HOW THE PROJECTS.
THAT WERE BEING PROPOSED FIT
INTO THAT OVERALL REGIONAL PLAN.
SO AND EIGHTY A SIDE EFFECT OF
THIS WOULD BE OBVIOUSLY A
SMALLER POOL OF PROJECTS THAT
THE COMMISSION WOULD BE MANAGING
STATEWIDE -- AND SO THAT LEADS
INTO OUR SECOND RECOMMENDATION
WHICH IS THAT IF THE COMMISSION
HAD A SMALLER.
POOL OF PROJECTS -- THEY COULD
POTENTIALLY EXPAND THE SIZE OF
THEIR REVIEW TEAMS THERE WAS A
FRANK TO EARLIER YOU HAVE.
OF ONLY TWO REVIEWERS SO YOU MAY
NOT HAVE THE FULL RANGE OF
EXPERTISE -- LOOKING AT EVERY
PROJECT THIS MIGHT ALLOW THEM TO
HAVE A FIVE OR SIX MEMBER
REACHING THAT WAS LOOKING AT
EACH PROJECT WHICH WOULD MAYBE --
LIMIT LIMIT SOME OF THAT
SUBJECTIVISM -- YOU MIGHT ALSO
BE ABLE TO HAVE.
AT LEAST ONE OR TWO THE M. P.
O.'S AT THE REGIONAL PROCESS HAS
A A TWO STEP PROCESS WHERE THEY
HAVE REVIEW TEAM TO LOOK AT EACH
PROJECTS IN THE TOP.
GOING ONES GET ELEVATED TO THE
TO HAVE.
A SECONDARY PANEL SO THERE'S
DIFFERENT THINGS THAT COULD BE
LOOKED OUT THERE -- ARE THE
RECOMMENDATIONS -- WOULD BE TO
FIND A WAY TO GIVE THE SMALL
THOSE EIGHT SMALL NPOS SOME WAY --
TO INFLUENCE PRIORITIZATION THE
PROJECTS THAT THEY CARE ABOUT
THERE'S A FEW THINGS THAT WE
DISCUSS ABOUT THAT YOU MIGHT.
WE DISCUSSED THAT MIGHT GO INTO
THAT -- THE COMMISSION CERTAINLY
DOING A LOT.
TO STREAMLINE THE APPLICATION
PROCESS AND TO DO TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE WE JUST SEARCH THEY
CONTINUE TO DO THAT AND FIND
WHATEVER WAYS THEY CAN.
OUT TO INCREASE THAT TO TO HELP.
LOSING THE CRITICAL PROJECT DATA
AND WE WOULD PROPOSE A YES THE A
FUNDING CAP -- TO SORT OF
BALANCE THE NEED FOR THEIR
DESIRE FOR TRANSFORMATION
PROJECTS WITH -- ALLOWING SO
THAT YOU'RE ABLE TO FIND THIS TO
GIVING A NUMBER OF PROJECTS TO
MAYBE LOOK AT I DON'T KNOW
WHETHER IT WOULD BE A TEN
MILLION OR TWELVE MILLION DOLLAR
FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR.
CAP BUT IT CONSIDER THAT AS A
WAY TO TRY AND BALANCE THE THE
THE MOVE TOWARD LARGER AND
LARGER PROJECTS -- WHICH I THINK
IS EATING.
SMALLER IN READING OF EATING THE
PIE MUCH MORE QUICKLY.
I THINK THAT MUCH FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION -- HAVE ANSWERED
THE QUESTIONS BACK TO BRANSON I
UNDERSTAND LAURIE WATERS IS
SITTING NEXT TO YOU -- THIS THIS
THIS IS AN INFORMATIONAL -- ITEM
YEAH THE THE FUN PART IS THAT WE
GET TO DEFINE THE GOALS AND THEN
WE HAVE.
TO ASK YOU GUYS FOR THE DAD AND
FOR DIRECTIONS GIVE COMMENTS ON
THESE TWO REPORTS SERVICE WHAT
YOU'RE THINKING AND I DID BRING
SOME COMMENTS TODAY AND THEN WE
WENT TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THAT YOU HAVE.
THAT WOULD WORK SECOND SEASON
BRANSON THE COMMISSION AND
LAURIE WATERS STORY IS THERE TO
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM MANAGER
SON THANKFUL SHE'S HERE TODAY.
I FIRST I WANTED TO JUST I
WANTED TO THINK THAT -- YOU IN
THE OFFICE OF THIS AN OFFICER
RESEARCH FOR THEIR REVIEW OF THE
ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM.
AND YOU KNOW THE COMMISSION
DEVELOPED THIS PROGRAM IN ITS
THREE MUCH COLLABORATION
CONSULTATION AND DELIBERATION WE
HAVE MORE THAN SEVEN HUNDRED
INTERESTED.
STAKEHOLDERS IN THIS PROGRAM.
BY FAR THE LARGEST AMOUNT
INTEREST AMONG ALL OF OUR
PROGRAMS.
AND SO LAURIE IS WORKING WITH
THOSE STAKEHOLDERS -- HUNDREDS
OF THEM ON A REGULAR BASIS.
IT IS ALWAYS OUR PRACTICE TO
WORK IN PARTNERSHIP WITH ALL
INTERESTED STAKEHOLDERS TO
IMPROVE THE PROGRAM MOVING
FORWARD.
AND THE RICH THIRTIES REPORTS IN
THE FINDINGS AND RECOMMENDATIONS
WILL BE BOUGHT.
I'M SORRY IT WILL BE BROUGHT
FORWARD -- AS WE MOVE INTO FOR
MUCH DELIBERATION DISCUSSION AS
WE DEVELOP THE GUIDELINES FOR
THE NEXT A FUNDING CYCLE.
THERE ARE SOME ASPECTS OF THE
PROGRAM THAT WE SHARED WITH YOU
TODAY THAT I DID WHEN IT.
A IT IS SURE A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
OUR PROGRAM WITH YOU.
WE ARE WORKING ON IT WITH
RESPECT TO THE PROJECT%
APPLICATIONS EACH CYCLE OR
WORKING.
TO DO WHAT WE CAN TO REDUCE THE
COSTS OF THE APPLICATIONS.
BUT WE NEED TO HAVE BASIC DATA
TO MAKE DECISIONS.
THESE APPLICATIONS THAT WE HAVE
TODAY THAT ARE IN PLACE WHERE
WERE THE RESULT OF CLOSE
CONSULTATION AND COLLABORATION
WITH.
HUNDREDS OF STAKEHOLDERS
INCLUDING THE RURAL.
THE INSIDE THE THE URBAN SMALL
URBAN AND THE RURAL AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
WE DO HAVE APPLICATIONS
DEPENDING ON THE SIZE OF THE
PROJECT TO REDUCE THE COST IN
THE AMOUNT OF INFORMATION THAT
WE ARE.
ASKING FOR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
IS PROVIDED TO ANY AGENCY THAT
REQUESTED.
AND WE DO KNOW THAT AGENCIES
WITH VERY LIMITED RESOURCES HAVE
BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN THE PROGRAM.
IN THE MOST RECENT CYCLE WHAT
WE'RE SAYING IS THE APPLICATIONS
ARE IN A DETERRENT TO THE TO
APPLYING FOR THE FUNDING.
WE HAD NEARLY A HUNDRED MORE
APPLICATIONS A CYCLE THAN WE DID
IN THE LAST CYCLE.
WE RECEIVED FIFTY OF THE
APPLICANTS WERE BRAND NEW
APPLICANTS THAT WE HAD NOT SEEN
APPLY FOR FUNDING IN THE PAST.
BUT WE DO KNOW THERE'S
IMPROVEMENT TO BE MADE AND WE
ARE PLANNING TO CONTINUE.
MAKING IMPROVEMENTS IN WERE
GREATLY APPRECIATIVE AT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS MADE.
TODAY AND IN THESE REPORTERS.
WITH RESPECT TO OUR EVALUATION
OF THE APPLICATIONS WE DO YOU IS
A MULTI DISCIPLINARY.
ADVISORY GROUP THAT IS REQUIRED
IN STATUTE TO REVIEW THE
APPLICATIONS.
THE TEAM MEMBERS ARE TRAINED --
TO THROUGH A PROCESS THAT.
THEY ALL GO THROUGH TRAINING BUT
WE DO HAVE COMMISSION STAFF THAT
REVIEWS EVERY APPLICATION.
AND THE REASON FOR THAT IS TO
NORMALIZE THE SCORING AND TO THE
TO ENSURE CONSISTENT SOME LEVEL
OF CONSISTENCY -- WHERE THERE
ARE SIGNIFICANT DEVIATIONS THE
COMMISSION STAFF DOES MEET WITH
THE REVIEW TEAM?
AND DOES WORK OUT THOSE
DISCREPANCIES.
AS GUIDELINES ARE DEVELOPED FOR
THE NEXT CYCLE FUNDING WE WILL
WORK TOGETHER WITH EVERYONE. TO
EXPLORE OPTIONS FOR INCREASING
THE SIZE OF THE MULTI
DISCIPLINARY.
REVIEW TEAMS.
I DID WANT TO JUST HIT ON THOSE
FLOORS AND THE REVIEW TO IN THE
PROJECT GOALS.
PROJECTS THAT ARE FUNDED IN THE
AFTER TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM
THEY'RE REQUIRED TO BE
CONSISTENT WITH THE REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION PLAN.
SO THEY'RE ALREADY THAT'S A
REQUIREMENT BUILT INTO THE
PROGRAM THAT WE NEED TO KNOW
FROM PROJECT APPLICATION.
THAT THIS PROJECT IS CONSISTENT
WITH THE PRIORITIES OF THE
REGION.
GRAHAM DOES FUND VERY IMPORTANT
SAFETY HEALTH MOBILITY
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS.
AND WE DO AGREE WITH THE LA L..
THREE POURED IN WITH THE SAN
OFFICER RESEARCH REPORT THAT WE
NEED BETTER AND MORE ACCURATE
PROJECT DATA. TO QUANTIFY THE
PROGRAM BENEFITS THESE THESE
PROJECTS ARE JUST NOW COMING TO
COMPLETION FROM THE FIRST CYCLE.
THE COMMISSION IS IS SHARES THE
CONCERN.
AND WE ARE WORKING WITH CALTRANS
THE ACTUAL TRANSPORTATION
TECHNICAL ADVISORY COMMITTEE AND
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS THAT ARE
INTERESTED IN HELPING US ON
IMPROVEMENTS TO DATA REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS. TO ENSURE THE BIKE
AND PEDESTRIAN COUNTS ARE
UNIFORM AND THAT THE ACCOUNT FOR
IS. FOR EXAMPLE FOR SEASONAL
VARIATIONS.
WE ALSO THE COMMISSION FUNDS TO
THE STATE WIDE PROGRAM AN ACT TO
TRANSPORTATION RESOURCE CENTER.
NOT RESOURCE CENTER IS
PREDOMINATELY IN PLACE TO
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
BUT IT IS ALSO RIGHT NOW IN THE
PROCESS OF IMPLEMENTING A
PEDESTRIAN IN USER -- PEDESTRIAN
AND BICYCLE COUNTER PROGRAM TO
MORE THIS BORROWING PROGRAM WILL
BE IT IS EUIPMENT WILL BE ABLE
TO BE CHECKED OUT.
BY AGENCIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA TO UTILIZE FOR THEIR
BEFORE AND AFTER COUNTS SO WE
BELIEVE THAT SHOULD GREATLY HELP --
WHERE WHERE BLOCKING DATA AT
THIS POINT IN TIME?
I DO WE DID ONE ADDRESS THE
REASON WHY WE HAVE IT --
REQUIRED THE NPOS ARE THE
PROJECTS TO COMPETE IN THE STATE
Y. COMPONENT BEFORE THEY WERE
ELIGIBLE FOR THE MPO COMPONENT.
WANTED TO LET YOU KNOW THIS WAS
A BRAND NEW REQUIREMENT IN THE
FOURTH CYCLE.
OF THE REASON FOR THAT WAS IT WE
WERE WE WERE STRAIGHT WE WERE
STRIVING TO ACHIEVE.
BETTER STATEWIDE DATA COLLECTION.
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT WE NEED TO
REPORT ON THE RESULTS OF THIS
PROGRAM. TO THE PUBLIC INTO THE
LEGISLATURE IN OTHERS BUT IN
LIGHT OF THESE REPORTS WE WILL
GO BACK AND REVISIT THAT.
AND LOOK FOR ALTERNATIVE MEANS
TO CUT THAT COLLECT BETTER
STATEWIDE DATA.
WITH REGARDS TO THE TRANSFORM
INTO PROJECTS -- WE ARE YOU KNOW
THERE IS A DISCUSSION ABOUT YOU
KNOW IT'S A TRANSFORM INTO
PROJECT.
AND WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR IS
WHERE IN THE PAST YOU MIGHT OF
BEEN SINGLE COMPONENTS BROUGHT
FORWARD BUT THERE IT.
THERE ARE ENTITIES IN THE STATE
THAT ARE PUTTING TOGETHER
NETWORKS THEY'RE PUTTING
TOGETHER CLOSING GAPS CREATING A
LARGE NETWORK AND SO THE
COMMISSION IS IS AGREES WE AGREE
WITH THE LA US REPORT IN THIS IN
OFFICE RESEARCH THAT THOSE
PROJECTS ARE VERY IMPORTANT.
IN THE COMMISSION THIS LAST
CYCLE ENCOURAGED THOSE TYPES
APPROACH PROJECTS TO COME
FORWARD AND SO WE DID SEE AN
INCREASE IN THE APPLICATIONS FOR
THOSE TYPES OF PROJECTS -- WE I
GUESS WHAT I WOULD SAY THAT THE
IN A DAY AND THE CHRISTIANS
FUNDED MORE THOSE PROJECTS A
CYCLE.
BUT THE ENTIRE STATEWIDE PROGRAM.
HAS NOT BEEN DIRECTED TO
TRANSFORM INTO PROJECTS.
BECAUSE THE COMMISSION HAS
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
SMALL URBAN AND RURAL.
OF PROJECTS ARE WILL CERTAIN NOT
FORGOTTEN AND SO THAT IS A VERY
IMPORTANT TO THE COMMISSION --
SO I THINK EIGHT A I GUESS THE
LASTLY FIVE TWENTY TWO MUCH TIME
HERE LASTLY I WOULD JUST WANT TO
SAY THAT -- THE ONLY A REPORT --
DOES CONSIDER FUNDING THE
REGIONAL COMPONENT AS A LUMP SUM.
AND WE DO AGREE WITH THE LA L.
THAT IF FRIENDS ARE.
AND PROVIDED THROUGH THE LUMP
SUM IT IN THE REGIONAL COMPONENT
IT WOULD REMOVE THE PROJECT
LEVEL OVERSIGHT THAT THE
COMMISSION HAS.
THIS COULD HAVE IMPLICATIONS FOR
THE SENATE BILL ONE ACCOUNTING
ACCOUNTABILITY -- REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS AND THE
COMMISSION'S ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY GUIDELINES -- AND
I'LL GIVE YOU AN EXAPLE OF THE
COMMISSION AND THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT OF COURSE THE LEGISLATURE
CAN CONSIDER.
HOW TO DRESS BUT AS AN EXAMPLE
THE COMMISSION DOES REQUIRE TIME
LISA FUNDS TIMELY USE OF FUNDS?
AND SO IF A PROJECT IS DEDICATED
FUNDING IT DOESN'T MOVE FORWARD.
WITHIN A REASONABLE PERIOD OF
TIME.
THIS PROJECT FUNDS TO LAPSE AND
WERE ABLE TO REDIRECT THOSE
FUNDS TO A PROJECT THAT IS READY
TO GO.
AND THAT WOULD BE IT ONE EXAMPLE
OF THAT SO I AM HAPPY LAURIE AND
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE AND
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR HAVING US
WHEN THE MPO I MEAN WE COULD.
PUT THAT IN A LANGUAGE THAT THE
MPO IF WE GAVE THEM OUT TO THE
REGIONS AND THEY HAD A PROJECT
THAT LAPSE THE DATE COULD.
THEY COULD DIRECT THAT MONEY
INTO THEIR THEIR REGION FOR AND
THAT THE NXT PROJECTS READY GO
ARE YOU SUGGESTING THEY COMES
BACK. TO THE MOTHER SHIP AND
THEN WE ALL RIGHT NOW ON AND I
MAYBE ALL THAT LAURIE BECAUSE HE
AND HIS ALREADY HAVE A IN LIKE A
WAITING LIST OF SORTS.
CELEBRITY ONE YET EACH OF THE
MPO SAY HAVE A CONTINGENCY LIST
OF PROJECTS THAT IF SHOULD ONE
OF THEIR ONES THAT WERE
INITIALLY FUNDED.
IF THEY WERE TO FAIL OR I'M HAVE
SOME SAVINGS THEY CAN.
THOSE FUNDS WILL GO BACK TO ONE
OF THE PROJECTS THAT'S ON THEIR
CONTINGENCY LIST.
OKAY.
FINANCE DO YOU GUYS HAVE AN
OPINION ON IN ANY OF THIS.
NOT AT THIS TIME OKAY IS
INFORMATIONAL ON LAKE MEMBERS
SENATE MCGUIRE THANK YOU SO MUCH
I DO WANT TO TAKE MOMENT SAY
THANK YOU. TO THE TRACTOR FOR
ALL OF HER WORK -- ON THIS
IMPORTANT FIND.
IN AND OBVIOUSLY HAVING.
FOCUS ON BOTH URBAN AND RURAL.
I THINK ON THE RULES IDC Là
URBAN FOLKS COMPANIES.
RIGHT -- THE GREAT OUTDOORS A
COUPLE OF ITEMS WOULD LIKE TO BE
A TALK ABOUT DATA GATHERING YOU
KNOW THAT'S BEEN.
SOME OF THE GAPS.
I'M SHE ATE UP FOLKS IN THE
TECHNOLOGY I AM ONLY ITEMS THE
LA A MENTION IS OBVIOUSLY
WANTING TO BE CONSISTENT IN
PARTICULAR DURING PEAK SEASON
RIGHT.
IN HOW YOU ARE EDUCATING
ACTUALLY LOCALS ON THOSE COUNTS --
AND NOT DOING IT IN THE WINTER
WHEN WE SHOULD BE LOOKING AT
SUMMER FALL KATE CAN TALK ABOUT
THAT AND ONE MORE QUESTION
[inaudible]
DO YOU.
I LET.
THREE AS WELL -- YES SO WE THAT
WAS ACTUALLY ONE OF THE THE
COMMENTS THAT I APPRECIATED MOST
FROM THE LA THIS REPORT BECAUSE
THAT THAT IS A REALLY IMPORTANT
POINT AND WE ARE WORKING TOWARDS --
COMING WITH COMING UP WITH A WAY.
TO WERE A HAVE APPLICATIONS
GATHER CONSISTENT DATA AND THAT
IS WHERE YOU TAKE YOUR COUNTS
THE SAME TIME BEFORE IN THE SAME
TIME AFTER.
AND THEN USING A CONSISTENT
METHODOLOGY I WANT TO POINT OUT
THAT THERE IS NOT.
A STANDARDIZED METHODOLOGIES OUT
THERE ANYWHERE SO WE ARE WORKING
ON THAT TO OUR TECHNICAL
ADVISORY COMMITTEEAND TO THE
ACT OF TRANSPORTATION RESOURCE
CENTER TO DEVELOP THAT IN
CALIFORNIA THAT WILL -- I THINK
BE A STANDARD PROBABLY FOR THE
REST OF THE COUNTRY.
CAN YOU TALK ABOUT THE L.
ABILITY OF LOCAL FUNDS
UNDERSTAND IT DOES NEED TO BE
LOCAL MATCH.
ENABLE TO DEDICATE THOSE DOLLARS
TOWARDS THESE EIGHTY P. ELIGIBLE
PROJECTS.
IT SEEMS TO ME THAT THAT HAS
ALSO BEEN A LITTLE BIT OF A
HURDLE -- BUT CAN YOU TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT -- IN TAKE
A DEEPER DIVE.
IF I'M UNDERSTAND YOUR QUESTION
CORRECTLY WHAT WE SEE AND I CAN
GIVE MORE INFORMATION BUT WHAT
WE SEE IS A STATE WIDE COMPONENT.
WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO FIND SMALL
URBAN A REAL -- PROJECTS IN THIS
SMALL URBAN RIO COMPONENT BUT
THEY ARE ALSO COMPETING IN THE
STATE Y. COMPONENT.
AND SHOULD ON THAT STRUCTURE
CHANGE IN THE STATE Y. COMPONENT.
THOSE SMALL URBAN ROW.
ENTITIES WOULD HAVE GREAT
DIFFICULTY COMPETINGWITH SOME
OF THE THEY'RE DOING A GOOD JOB
IN THE STATE WHERE COMPONENT
ACTUALLY THEY'RE DOING VERY WELL.
BECAUSE THESE ARE THESE ARE
AREAS OF THE STATE THAT.
WOULD TAKE THEM MAYBE DECADES TO
SAVE UP THE MONEY TO BE ABLE TO
CLOSE THE GAP THAT THEY REALLY
NEED -- SOME OF THE PROJECTS
THAT WE'RE FINDING.
A LOT OF THE PROJECTS THAT WERE
FUNDING OUR STATE ROUTES TO ARE
SAFE PRESS TO SCHOOLS.
IN AREAS OF THE STATE THAT HAVE
GRAVEL THEY ARE AND YOU KNOW THE
THE NEEDS ARE GREAT THE NEEDS
ARE GREAT ACROSS THE STATE.
AND SOME OF THOSE NEEDS WE'RE
SEEING ARE ARE VERY PROFOUND IN
THE RURAL AND SMALL URBAN AREAS
AT THE STATE.
ABSOLUTELY.
I WOULD JUST ADD THAT THAT'S
THAT'S EXACTLY WHY WE DON'T
REQUIRE A MATCH AND THE REASON
THAT WE WE HAVE THIS DISCUSSION
EVERY CYCLE ON IF WE'RE GONNA
FIND JUST CONSTRUCTION OR NOT.
BUT WE FIND PRECONSTRUCTION
BECAUSE WE HAVE A LOT OF LOW
RESOURCE AGENCIES THAT WOULD NOT
HAVE THE FUNDS TO DO THE PRE
CONSTRUCTION WORK. NINE IN I
KNOW YOU GET THE FEEDBACK AND
THEN -- WE HEAR THE FEEDBACK IS
THE BAND WITH IS THE MOST
CHALLENGING PART RIGHT.
NOT JUST THE APPLICATION BEING
ABLE TO DO ALL THE PRE WORK IN
IN SOME OF THESE AREAS IN
SENSITIVE AREAS FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL ENGINEERING RIGHT.
AND IT COULD BE PAINFUL.
BOTH ON COBBLING TOGETHER
DOLLARS IN IN BEING ABLE TO GET
PROJECT READY SO.
I I KNOW THAT IS GREATLY
APPRECIATED IN I'M.
AT THE AGENCY REALLY STRETCHES.
TO MAKE IT WORK AND I JUST WANNA
COMPLEMENT YEAH AND SAY HOW
GRATEFUL WE ARE.
OTHER EIGHTY P. INTO CS YES
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
JOIN SENATOR MCGUIRE AND
THINKING ALL OF YOU FOR YOUR
WORK AND LA OWN OFFICE OF
RESEARCH FOR HELPING. TO DRILL
DOWN ON THIS A LITTLE BIT.
MAY BE YOU ADDRESS THIS BUT WE
HEAR THERE'S A BURDEN SOME
APPLICATION PROCESS.
AND THEN [inaudible]
DETERMINING.
FOLLOW UP FROM.
COUNTERS TO DETERMINE HOW MANY
PEOPLE ARE USING PEDESTRIAN BIKE
WAYS.
IS THERE ANY.
COMPONENT IN THE APPLICATION
PROCESS THAT REQUIRES HOW.
THE MEASUREMENTS WILL BE MADE.
AND SECONDLY.
ARE ANY THE MEASUREMENTS THAT
ARE REQUESTED.
IS THERE WAITED SHERMAN PEOPLE
THAT HAVE ACTUALLY GOTTEN OUT OF
A CAR.
AND ARE USING A BIKE WAY -- TO
COMMUTE TO WORK.
VERSUS JUST RECREATIONAL USE.
SO TO ANSWER THAT LAST PART DEAD
THAT.
IS REALLY GOOD QUESTION AND I
THINK THE ONE WAY THAT WE CAN DO
THAT IS -- BY THE TIME OF DAY
WHEN YOU'RE DOING THE COUNTS IF
YOU IF YOU IF YOU'RE HAVING HIGH
COUNTS DURING COMMUTE.
HOURS I THINK THAT YOU CAN MAKE
AN ASSUMPTION THAT YOU ARE.
TAKING SOME CARS OFF THE ROAD BY
PEOPLE USING THE FACILITIES TO
COMMUTE THAT WOULD BE ONE WAY
BUT I I THINK THAT THAT IS
SOMETHING AS WE START THINKING
ABOUT WHAT BETTER DATA WE SHOULD
GATHER AND WHAT BENEFITS WE
SHOULD BE ASSESSED SAYING.%
THAT WOULD BE A GOOD ONE THAT WE
SHOULD TRY TO USE ALL OUR
EXPERTISE TO COME UP WITH THE
WAY THAT WE CAN DO THAT.
YEAH I APPRECIATE THAT AGAIN.
THAT ME EN MORE LABOR INTENSIVE
EIGHTY TO THE PROCESS BUT IT
COULD BE THAT IN ADDITION TO
COUNTERS.
YOU DO JUST.
TO A SMALL SAMPLE OF THE
INTERVIEWS OF PEOPLE USING THE
TRAIL AND THEN EXTRAPOLATE FROM
A SAMPLE.
OF A SMALL SAMPLE OF PEOPLE DO
SOME EXTRAPOLATION.
AND REALIZING THAT A LOT OF
ENTITIES DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO DO THE EXTENSIVE
COUNTS THAT MAYBE.
SOME OTHERS DO THE ACTOR
TRANSPORTATION RESOURCE CENTER
THAT IS DIRECTED BY CALTRANS
THEY ARE DOING A REALLY GOOD JOB
OF TRYING TO TARGET AREAS THAT
NEED THAT HELP IN PROVIDING THAT
TO THEM.
IF I COULD JUST FOLLOW UP ON THE
FIRST PART OF YOUR QUESTION.
HELLO THE AND PERFORMANCE
OUTCOMES ARE ARE ANTICIPATED.
IS ACTUALLY SUBJECT MATTER THAT
WE ARE -- WE ARE DISCUSSING
ACROSS ALL OF OUR PROGRAMS RIGHT
NOW.
THIS IS A KEY COMPONENT TO
EVALUATION OF ANY PROJECT AND SO
WE'RE WORKING WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS TO TALK ABOUT WHAT
ARE THE ASSUMPTIONS THAT YOU'D
THAT THIRD THE AGENCIES ARE
MAKING.
AND TO PUT THAT IN WRITING AND
SO WE ARE WORKING I GUESS THE
COMMITMENT I WOULD WHEN I WOULD
WANT TO SHARE TODAY'S COMMISSION
IS COMMITTED.
ON HAVING THE THE PERFORMANCE
OUTCOMES.
AND THE PERFORMANCE REPORTING.
BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE THE
PUBLIC AND THIS INFORMATION
WE'RE DISCUSSING WITH THE ACTUAL
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM.
WE ARE IN THE NEXT CYCLE WILL
HAVE TO DELVE INTO THIS.
ALONG WITH THE DATA COUNTERS IN
THE USER ACCOUNTS BUT WE NEED TO
GIVE.
THESE AGENCIES ALSO THE MEANS BY
WHICH THEY CAN TAKE THE BEFORE
COUNTS SO THAT WERE YOU KNOW WE
SET THEM UP TO SUCCEED
PRESUMABLY THAT BECOMES PART OF
THE APPLICATION PROGRESS.
NOW THEY'RE GOING TO PROVIDE
THAT.
DATA BEFORE AND AFTER YES YES
THANK YOU MISTER THE GOALS IS
THE SENATE -- SB NINETY NINE WAS.
TOO IMPROVE PUBLIC HEALTH TO
REDUCE CHILD ABUSE IN ALL THAT
SO SO I GUESS IF YOU'RE DOING
THE SURVEY YOU'D PROBABLY WANT
TO BE.
WITH THE WALKERS RATHER THE
BIKERS AND SORT OF DRIVE ALONG
WITH THEM CENTER STERN YOU HAVE
A QUESTION.
YEAH VERY VERY.
QUICKLY THANK YOU FOR THE
INDULGENCE AND FOR ALL THE
THOROUGH WORK DONE BY SEN OFFICE
RESEARCH IN LA -- IN THE C. D.
C.'S BEEN A REALLY COMPREHENSIVE
EFFORT HERE SO.
I I JUST WANT TO GET A SENSE I
KNOW WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
NOT LEAVING.
THE SMALL FOLKS BEHIND.
WHILE TRYING TO MAINTAIN SOME
BIG VISION.
I LOOK AT LOS ANGELES IS A PLACE
THAT.
IT'S EASY TO GIVE UP ON WHAT IS
TAUGHT WHEN IT COMES TO ACTOR
TRANSPORTATION IS A THERE'S NO
WAY RIGHT IT'S JUST IT'S IT'S
THE LAND OF CARS BUT WE'RE
SEEING.
PROGRESS BEING MADE -- I LOOK AT
A PROJECT LIKE THE LA RIVER AS A
SORT OF CROSS JURISDICTIONAL.
TOUGH PROJECT TO GET EVERYONE
TOGETHER ON JUST BECAUSE THERE
ARE SO MANY AUTHORITIES AND IT'S
TOUGH TO DO.
THE KIND OF BIG VISION WORK THAT
THEY PUT IN AN ENHANCE
INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCE DISTRICT
TOGETHER FOR INSTANCES HEART
RIGHT BECAUSE YOU NEED A LOT OF
BUYING FROM DIFFERENT ENTITIES.
WOULD SOMETHING WE'RE WORKING ON
AND ALL THE WAY FROM THE ARMY
CORPS.
INTO YOU KNOW LA COUNTY PUBLIC
WORKS CITY D. O. T. TRY TO GET
TOGETHER.
DO YOU SEE CDC HAVING AN AT
LEAST IN.
THE A COLLABORATIVE RECORD
NATIVE ROLE IN SOME WAY TO TRY
TO GET FOLKS TO COME UP WITH
VISIONARY PROJECTS YOU SEEING
THAT THE THE KIND OF PROPOSALS
THAT YOU'D EXPECT FROM.
SAY THAT KIND OF SCOPE OF
PROJECT FOR YOUR CROSS CITY
LINES YOU YOU KNOW YOU'RE GOING
FIFTY ONE MILES LIKE.
WHAT DO WE NEED TO BE DOING
BETTER I GUESS IN LA?
TO COME UP WITH THAT BIG VISION
AND HOW CAN YOU HELP WITH THAT.
WE'RE IN THE FOR CYCLE OF THE
THE PROGRAM AND WHAT I THINK WE
SAW IN THE INITIAL CYCLES IS
THAT THERE IS A REALLY PAN OUT
NEED.
FOR KIND OF LIKE BREAD AND
BUTTER PROJECTS OUT THERE THERE
WAS A LOT OF NEED SO SO A LOT OF
THAT WAS ADDRESSED BUT SO IN
THIS LAST CYCLE IN PARTICULAR WE
ARE LOOKING TO NOT JUST GETTING.
A PROJECT BUT THE BEST PROJECT
SO TO THAT END WE ADDED A COUPLE
QUESTIONS IN THE APPLICATION FOR
THE LARGER PROJECTS THAT WE
WANTED TO HEAR FROM THE
APPLICANT'S HOW.
THEIR PROJECT WAS.
USING CONTEXT SENSITIVE
SOLUTIONS AND HOW IT WAS
TRANSFORMATIVE AND WE WE DID A
SOMEWHAT OF A TEST THIS TIME
BECAUSE WE DIDN'T WANT TO PUT
SOMETHING IN THERE THAT THE
APPLICANT'S JUST COULD NOT
ANSWER AND I WAS JUST SO
IMPRESSED BY THE ANSWERS THAT WE
GOT ACROSS THE STATE.
FROM HOW -- APPLICANTS WERE ABLE --
TO ANSWER THOSE QUESTIONS AND I
THINK THAT IS A SIGN OF HOW.
PLANNING FOR ACTOR
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS HAS
ADVANCED EVEN SINCE THE YEARS OF
THE ATP SO SINCE THAT WAS
SUCCESSFUL QUIRK THOSE WERE
SUCCESSFUL QUESTIONS IN THIS
CYCLE.
I THINK THAT WE WOULD TRY TO
EXPAND ON THAT FOR THE NEXT
CYCLE.
THERE WILL NOTE THAT THERE IS A
VERY GOOD BOOK WALKING IN LA
DESPITE THE SONG TO THE CONTRARY.
ALL RIGHT THIS IS.
THIS IS THIS IS ONLY AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING OF GOOD
WHEN I'M GOING TO OPEN IT UP FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT IF THERE'S
ANYBODY WHO'S HERE THEY WOULD
LIKE TO COMMENT.
ON THIS ARENA ON THE EIGHTY P.
PLEASE SIR.
MY NAME IS JEFF HARDY KIA I'M A
PUBLIC ADVOCATE I AM VERY
CONCERNED ON PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION.
AND ONE OF THINGS I WILL SAY AS
I'VE BEEN LIVING IN LA AND USE
THE BELLONA CREEK AND A FEW
OTHER THOSE THINGS WHEN I COULD
BUY CAN DO THOSE THINGS.
WHAT I AM WILL HERE'S A STRESSED
USES TWO THINGS?
UNINTENTIONAL CONSEQUENCES AND
ACCOUNTABILITY.
I WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU GUYS TO
GET SOME OF YOUR REPORTING BACK
OF WHAT'S GOING ON AND I'LL USE
THE EXAMPLE RIGHT NOW AND THIS
IS WHERE IT WAS SENATOR BEALE.
OF WHAT THE SUCCESS OF THE SB
ONE FUNDING.
THAT OCCURRED BUT FOR SACRAMENTO
IN THEIR RUSH TO DO THAT THE
FORCE BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T GET
THROUGH CALTRANS.
THE JAY STREET.
AS A BICYCLE PATH. ONE OF THE
THINGS YOU NEED TO LOOK AND SEE
WHAT IS WORKING AND SOME OF THE
PROBLEMS GROUP'S MISTAKES
WHATEVER I WOULD ENCOURAGE OTHER.
DISABILITY WISE.
SAY COG LOCALLY HERE DID NOT
REALIZE CONSIDER DISABILITY WHEN
THEY WERE DOING THE THOMAS
VEHICLES SO THE ECONOMIST THING
THAT IS GOING FROM SIXTY FIFTH
STREET. FOUR SACKS STATE. ONE OF
THEM WAS DESIGNED TO BE
DISABILITY OR IT NOW THE SEX
STATE ENGINEERING DEPARTMENTS
REALIZE THE USEFULNESS OF THAT
AND THEY'RE CONVERTING THE
OTHERS SO MANY CHARMS ON
ELECTRIC VEHICLES.
IT'S NOT BEING PLANNED TO
CONSIDERED.
AND YOU GOT THE NEXT TEN PLUS
YEARS WE ARE FAR MORE SENIOR
COMMUNITIES AND YOU HAVE FAR
MORE OF THE INDIVIDUALS.
THAT ARE LIKE WHAT HE'S NEEDING
THIS YOU ARE DEALING WITH AIR
TRAVEL BUT SOUTHWEST AND A
COUPLE OTHERS HAD THE PROBLEM.
TOO MANY OF THESE VEHICLES.
EIGHT THEM AROUND SO IT'S
SOMETHING I WOULD INVITE AS YOU
GUYS DO MORE WITH THE REAL
CONSIDERATION THE OTHER THINGS.
PLEASE GET YOUR REPORTS BACKS
YOU KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON ALSO
CATCH UP AS FAR AS KNOWLEDGE IN
THAT HATE.
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE MORE PEOPLE
THAT ARE GOING TO BE IN THESE
TYPE OF APPARATUSES AND THAT'S
WARY WAITED HERE FOR THIS.
BECAUSE I'VE GOT OTHER
COMMITTEES TO GO TO BUT BOB THIS
IS A VERY IMPORTANT TO EXPRESS
TO ALL OF YOU.
THAT PLEASE.
LOOK AT THAT AND LOOK THROUGH
THOSE OTHER SET OF EYES.
ANOTHER RESPONSE I'M THINKING AS
FAR AS YOUR CAR OWNERS IS THE
POOREST SYSTEM.
IS FOR DISABILITY ACCOUNTING
THROUGH THERE NOW THERE'S A
SECOND FEATURE WITH YOU PUSH ON
THE ADDITIONAL BUTTONS THE GIVES
YOU A CLUE ABOUT TYPICALLY THE
LOCATION.
AND I'M SUGGESTING MAYBE FOR
SOME PLACES FOR YOUR PEOPLE
COUNTERS BUT MAYBE YOU CONSIDER
SOME CARP OF INITIATING WHERE
YOU'RE GETTING THAT WERE COUNT
WHETHER IT'S DISABILITY WHETHER
SOMETHING ELSE.
WHETHER YOU'RE YOU'RE YOU'RE
BIKING OR SOMETHING ELSE FOR
SOME OF THE PLACES IN TRAILS
THAT YOU CAN GET AN IDEA.
YOU KNOW RATHER THAN JUST
SENDING A PERSON THERE AND
SITTING DOWN IT'S JUST LIKE HERE
WITH DEALING WITH THE MOBILE
APPS.
THE JUMP BIKES THE OTHER THINGS
MAJOR PROBLEM.
IS WHERE THEY'RE BEING PLACE SO
THE APT IS GOING THROUGH THEY'RE
TAKING THE PICTURE SHOWING THE
PROBLEMS.
IN GETTING LETTER LASTLY WILL
SAY TO YOU IS THIS SACRAMENTO
TRYING BY TWENTY TWENTY TO DO
GREATLY ELECTRIFICATION.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT MAY ALSO
BE COMING INTO THE STATE JADA
REVIEW AND SEE WHAT'S GOING ON
HAPPEN THERE AND SEEN A PRIVATE
AND SEEING WHAT ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION.
YOU CAN COLLECT BACK TO GUIDE
YOUR DECISIONS ON THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU WE HAVE NEXT WHEN I
KNOW THAT.
THE FITBIT IN THE GOOGLE WATCH
FOLKS WOULD LIKE TO NOT IGNORE
THE TECHNOLOGY THAT WE HAVE
EASILY AVAILABLE TO US
[inaudible]
YES [inaudible]
MORNING.
WHEN THE COMMISSION WITH A
CALIFORNIA BICYCLE COALITION WE
ARE A NONPROFIT STATEWIDE?
ORGANIZATION THAT HAS WORKED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE ATP REALLY
CATERS.
TO ALL THE NEEDS -- IN
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE WE
WERE ENGAGED WITH THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE PROGRAM AFTER
THE CONSOLIDATION OF THE FUNDS.
AND CONTINUE TO BE PART OF THE
THE IMPLEMENTATION AND AND
LOOKING AT ALL THE ISSUES THAT
HAVE BEEN DISCUSSED TODAY -- WE
APPRECIATE THE LA -- AND THE
SENATE OFFICE OF RESEARCH REALLY
TAKING A DEEP DIVE INTO WHAT IS
HAPPENING ANNA AND REALLY WHAT A
PROGRAM THAT'S INTO STILL IT'S
INCUBATING PHASE THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF GROWTH OVER THE PAST FOUR
CYCLES BUT WE STILL ARE YET TO
SEE THE THE THE PROJECTS REALLY
TAKE.
OFF BECAUSE WE'VE ONLY COMPLETED
THE FIRST ROUND.
THE NUMBER OF THINGS HAVE BEEN
SAID I HAD DIRECTOR BRANSON AND
AND MORE WATERS HAVE CLARIFIED
SOME SOME OF THE ISSUES -- BUT I
DO WANT TO EMPHASIZE A FEW
THINGS I APPRECIATE YOUR
LISTENING INTENTION.
SO FIRST OF ALL AT THE IT HAS TO
BE EMPHASIZED THIS IS A HEAVILY
UNIQUE STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT
PROCESS I'D DIFFERENT FROM OTHER
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS THAT WE
HAVE AN AND COMPETITIVE.
PROGRAMS AT THE STATE LEVEL AND
WITH THE CDC HAS DONE IS SERVED
AS A SORT OF A AN ENTITY THAT'S
CONTINUE TO KEEP THINGS
CONSISTENT.
AND IN THE DIRECTION OF
CONSENSUS BUILDING AMONG VARIOUS
STAKEHOLDERS LIKE ACROSS THE
STATE A AND AND VARIOUS
INTERESTS RIGHT SO IT'S IT'S
HELPED TO MANAGE ALL OF THOSE
TYPES OF ACCOMMODATIONS IT'S
BEEN A NEGOTIATION -- ENTITY
AMONG THESE.
THESE AT THESE SAY HOLDERS IT'S
HAS A A ROBUST AND ENGAGED A
TECHNICAL ADVISORY COMMITTEE
MEETING EVERY.
A QUARTER QUARTERLY REALLY --
CONSISTS A CONSISTING OF
VISITATION OF MPO SMALL RUN RULE.
LOCAL ADVOCACY AND STATE RIGHT
ADVOCACY SO AGAIN AT HEAVILY --
ENGAGEMENT HAD.
ON ON THAT SIDE SO THERE'S A
NUMBER OF EYES LOOKING AT THIS
PROGRAM REGULARLY AND HOW CAN BE
IMPROVED ANOTHER THING TO ADD.
AT LAST CYCLE THERE WAS TEN I
BELIEVE WORKSHOPS STAKEHOLDER
WORKSHOPS ACROSS THE STATE AND
THAT'S AGAIN AN UNPRECEDENTED
FOR SOMETHING ON THIS LEVEL SO.
THIS IS REALLY A PROGRAM OF THE
OF THE GRASSROOTS THAT THE
GROUNDWORK I ALL OF THE
DIFFERENT VOICES AT AT THAT ARE
WORKING ON THIS. ONE OF THE
BIGGEST ISSUES AND THAT WE SEE
IS THAT THIS IS AN
OVERSUBSCRIBED PROGRAMTHAT'S
BEEN DESCRIBED -- YOU KNOW AT
THIS LAST CYCLE THERE WAS ABOUT
A TWO POINT TWO BILLION DOLLAR
ASKED TOTAL -- AND ONLY ABOUT
FOUR HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION
AVAILABLE I AM BUT THAT'S JUST
WHAT'S APPLIED TO IF YOU LOOK AT
ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION PLANTS
ACROSS THE STATE ACROSS EVERY
COMMUNITY. FOR CITY OF THE OF
COLTON FOR EXAMPLE IN SAMBHAR
DINO AT THAT'S AFFECTED BY QUITE
A BIT OF OF TRUCK TRAFFIC SO YOU
KNOW THERE'S THERE'S A
DISADVANTAGE COMMUNICANT ON IN
THERE.
IT'S A FIFTY FOUR HUNDRED I
BELIEVE IT A FIFTY FOUR THOUSAND
IS THE POPULATION BUT THEY'RE
ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION PLAN TO
BUILD IT OUT IS FOURTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS AND SO.
THAT'S JUST A SMALL COMMUNITY IF
YOU LOOK AT RIVERSIDE COUNTY IN
THEIR ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION PLAN
THAT'S SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS SO.
BUILDING OUT OUR ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PLANS TAKES QUITE
A BIT OF INVESTMENT THAT THIS
PROGRAM CAN'T YOU KNOW MEET AT
AT ITS CURRENT FUNDING LEVELS SO
IT'S CREATED A COMPETITIVE --
QUITE A COMPETITIVE EDGE AND AND
SO.
THAT'S REALLY THE ROOT OF A LOT
OF THE ISSUES PROCESS WISE AND
AND HOW THINGS ARE EVALUATED
AGAIN THAT'S BEEN.
HEAVILY.
DESIGNED BY ALL OF THE DIFFERENT
ENGAGEMENT LEVELS AT EACH LEVEL
AND AND THE EVALUATOR TEAMS YEAH
THESE ARE.
NATIONALS THAT VOLUNTEER THEIR
TIME OVER THE COURSE OF SEVERAL
MONTHS TO REALLY THINK ABOUT HOW
CAN WE AS A STATE MEET THE STATE
BECAUSE OF THIS PROGRAM.
AND NOT AN END THE REGION AT THE
REGIONAL LEVEL THERE'S
DEFINITELY PRIORITIES -- BUT
SOME OF THESE COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE APPLYING OUR SMALLER
COMMUNITIES AREN'T THEY MAY NOT
THEY'LL BE OVERLOOKED IN
REGIONAL -- PRIORITIES OFTEN --
AND SO WE REALLY WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE CONTAINABLE THE THE
I'M INTEGRITY OF THE PROGRAM AND
ITS CONTINUED GROWTH AT THE
OTHER BEING THAT -- THERE'S A
LOT OF TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
THAT'S BEEN.
BUT IT HERE AND IT AND IT'S FREE
OFTEN WE ARE WE ARE OURSELVES
AND OUR STATE PARTNERS PROVIDE
THIS.
AND ALSO -- SEE FROM SCHOOL
NATIONAL PARTNERSHIP THAT'S NOT
HERE TODAY SO THERE'S THAT AND
AND THAT THE ACTOR
TRANSPORTATION RESOURCE CENTER
SO THERE'S DEFINITELY.
A DESIRE TO MAKE SURE THAT MORE
FUNDING CAN I GO TO PLACES OF
NEED AND BUT WE DO HAVE TO LOOK
AT WHAT IS THE SCALE OF THAT
NEED AND HOW REGION'S CAN LOOK
AT OHER SOURCES OF FUNDING TO
MEET.
MAYBE THE SMALLER -- AT TYPES OF
PROJECTS THAT ARE MORE YOU KNOW
LIKE WE SAID BROWN BUTTER BUT
LOOK AT BACK TO TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM IS TRYING TO ME A LOT OF
DIFFERENT GOALS RIGHT AT THE
SAME TIME SO.
I HAVE CREDIT MORE TO SAY DON'T
TAKE MORE TIME BUT I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR ATTENTION THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANKS.
HI GOOD MORNING A SURVEYOR WITH
CALIFORNIA LOCKS ME ONE ECHO A
LOT OF THE COMMENTS THAT MY
COLLEAGUE LINDA MADE FROM CAL BY
CAN JUST COSTA MOTHERS TO
ATTENTION.
AND I'LL TRY TO BE CONCISE -- SO
I DO WANT TO ECHO THE FACT THAT
THE PROGRAM NEEDS MORE FUNDING
AND THERE JUST ISN'T ENOUGH TO
GO AROUND FOR ALL THE NEEDS OF
THE STATE -- I WANNA APPLIED AT
DIRECTOR BRANSON AND LAURIE
WATERS WHO DO A PHENOMENAL JOB
OF MANAGING THE ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM AND
REALLY BEING INCLUSIVE AND AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY AS MENTIONED BY
THE DIRECTOR.
TRANSPARENT WITH THE PROCESS IN
WITH BUILDING UP THE GUIDELINES --
FOR THIS PROGRAM THE OTHER THING
I WANT TO CALL OUT THAT WAS
MENTIONED DEBATE I BELIEVE IN LA
RAIL AND THERE IS AN OFFICE OF
RESEARCH WHICH WE WERE ALSO PART
OF SAID THANK YOU BOTH FOR YOUR
TIME AND AND ATTENTION ON THAT --
BUT I WANT TO CALL OUT THIS AB
SORT OF THOUGHT AS YOU KNOW THE
MPO IS BEING ABLE TO PRIORITIZE
PROJECTS AND WHAT YOU'LLSEE IN
TERMS OF THE STATE COMPETITION
IS THAT THE PROJECT APPLICANTS
ARE VERY DIVERSE -- WHILE THEY
ALL AS DIRECTOR BRANSON CALLED
OUT FALL WITHIN THE REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION PLAN BUT WE DO
SEE IS THAT SOME OF THOSE MAY
NOT BE HIGHLY PRIORITIZE BECAUSE
THEY'RE SMALLER PROJECTS PHYLLIS
SIDEWALK.
AND THINGS LIKE THAT BUT THINGS
THAT ARE HELPING CHILDREN WALK
TO SCHOOL BACK TO SCHOOL
COMMUNITIES ACROSS A BUSY STREET
TO GET TO A GROCERY STORE SO
THESE ARE PROJECTS THAT MAY NOT
FALL HIGH IN A PRIORITY FOR
REGIONAL PLANT.
BUT ARE VERY HIGH PRIORITY FOR
COMMUNITY AND ARE SOMETHING THAT
THE STATE STILL NEEDS TO ADDRESS
THE DIVERSITY OF THE STATE
PROJECTS AND WHAT GOES INTO THAT
50% OF THE PROJECTS THAT ARE YOU
KNOW FUNDED IS ALSO VERY
IMPORTANT.
AND WE SEE THAT AS A STRENGTH OF
THE PROGRAM TO FUND THESE
DIVERSE PROJECTS THAT MAY NOT BE
HIGHER ON PRIORITY BUT STILL
FALL WITHIN THE PLAN.
AND THEN HAVE THAT 40%
ALLOCATION AND PO'S TO
PRIORITIZE THOSE FUNDS AS THOUGH
WE DEFINITELY SEE THE BENEFIT OF
HAVING THE SPLIT AS IT IS.
I'M I THINK THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS AGAIN GOING
BACK TO JUST YOU KNOW THE EARLY
STAGES OF THIS PROGRAM ONLY ONE
CYCLE HAS BEEN IMPLEMENTED WE'RE
GETTING READY TO GO INTO THE
FIFTH CYCLE.
AND DOING ANY DRASTIC FUNDING
CHANGES AT THIS POINT MAY BE TOO
SOON I'M SO WE DEFINITELY URGE
I'M VERY HEAVY CONSIDERATION IN
TERMS OF ANY OF THOSE CMMENTS
THAT WERE INCLUDED IN BOTH
REPORTS -- JUST IN TERMS OF
BEING ABLE TO ADDRESS THE GREAT
NEED THAT EXIST THROUGHOUT THE
STATE WHAT THE POTENTIAL IMPACTS
COULD E. AS DIRECTOR BROWN SAND
LIMITED DATA IN TERMS OF HOW
THESE IMPACTS OF ROLLOUT. FOR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES FOR A
SMALL GROUP IN IN RULE I'M AND
ALSO FOR A LARGER URBAN SETTINGS
IN TERMS OF CHANGING THE
PRIORITIES SO THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME AND AGAIN WE WOULD
LOVE TO SEE A GREATER.
PRIORITY IN FUNDING FOR THE
ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
YOU'RE WELCOME AN WILL CLOSE THE
PUBLIC HEARING I AM ASSUME THE
WALKERS AND BIKERS ARE DELIGHTED
THAT WE DOUBLED THAT THE FUNDING
AND LAST YEAR.
IT'S NOT TO GET LOST IN THE BIG
PICTURE THAT WE'RE TRYING WE
APPS AS FOR TWO REPORTS WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE.
THAT WE IMPROVE THE PROGRAM
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND WE
DEMO LEVINE -- TO CALTRANS IN
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN
NATURALLY WE'LL START OFF WITH
CALTRANS WITH THE ROAD REPAIR
AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
IMPLEMENTATION THIS IS ITEM
NUMBER -- FIFTEEN THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION IS APPROVED AS
BUDGET [inaudible]
YEAH.
WELCOME DIRECTOR BERMAN
[inaudible]
GO AHEAD.
BEFORE YOU START.
HI MY QUESTION IS WHEN THIS IS A
SQUALL BECOME A CRACK.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE YOU KNEW I
READ THE CHART.
WHEN DOES THIS BOBBY COME ACROSS
IRAQ IN THIS IS THAT LIKE A
CALTRANS JOKERS?
IS THAT SOMEWHERE IN HERE.
YOU GET OUT A RULER.
LET'S HEAR YOUR ROUTE -- SURE
PULLS OFF.
OKAY I'M GONNA SAY GOOD
AFTERNOON AT THIS POINT.
THE DEPARTMENT OF CAPTION I'M
SORRY I'M LAURIE BERMAN I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF CALTRANS WITH MS
CLARK PAULSON.
ISN'T -- BUDGETS DIVISION CHIEF.
THE DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION
OR CALTRANS REQUEST TWO BILLION
DOLLARS IN STATE OPERATIONS
LOCAL ASSISTANCE AND CAPITAL
OUTLAY FUNDING. FOR
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS UNDER
THE ROAD REPAIR AND
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN ALSO KNOWN AS SB.
ONE THIS REQUEST IS FOR ROAD
MAINTENANCE AND REHABILITATION
ACCOUNT OR ARE AM ARE A FUNDING
TO ENSURE THAT FUNDING LEVELS
ARE CONSISTENT WITH ANTICIPATED
SB.
ONE REVENUES CREATED FOR THOSE
USES.
OUR IN OUR A APPROPRIATIONS TO
EXPAND SB ONE FUNDING ARE ALSO
INCLUDED IN THE STATE TRANSIT
ASSISTANCE BUDGET THIS THE
SECRETARY FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE TRANSPORTATION AGENCY BUT
BUDGET.
AND THE SHARED REVENUE BUDGET.
SB ONE PROVIDE STABLE ON GOING
FUNDING FOR STATE HIGHWAY AND
LOCAL ROADS MAINTENANCE AND
REPAIRS AS WELL AS MATCHING
PROJECTS TRANSIT AND INTERCITY
RAIL ALSO RECEIVE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING -- SP ONE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WILL HAVE ACCESS TO
FUNDING FOR ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS.
THIS REQUEST SEEKS TO CONTINUE
IMPLEMENTATION CONSISTENT WITH
THE LEGISLATION THIS BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL HIGHLIGHTS
EXPENDITURES IN THE CALTRANS
BUDGET.
FROM THE ARMORY RESOURCES WHICH
PRIMARILY FUND HIGHWAY
MAINTENANCE MAINTENANCE AND
REHABILITATION THIS SUPPORT
REQUEST INCLUDES AN INCREASE OF
TWENTY EIGHT POINT EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS AND I'M GOING RESOURCES.
AND TWENTY SIX POINT EIGHT
MILLION LIMITED TERM RESOURCES
TOTALING FIFTY FIVE POINT SIX
MILLION IN.
NINETEEN TWENTY THIS REQUEST IS
AN INCREASE IN POSITION
AUTHORITY FOR THREE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY THREE MAINTENANCE AND
THIRTEEN EQUIPMENT PROGRAM
POSITIONS.
AS WELL AS TO TO YOUR POSITIONS
FOR EQUIPMENT ENGINEERING WORK.
THAT'S ALL I HAVE.
HELLO YOU HAVE COMMON.
MEMBERS.
QUESTIONS A GOOD QUESTION CENTER
STERN.
THANK YOU DIRECTOR ROMAN AND I
JUST WAS [inaudible]
REMARKING.
HOW MUCH TROUBLE WE'D BE IN
WHERE THIS REVENUE STREAM NOT
HERE AND IT'S JUST SHOCKING TO
ME JUST TO THINK OF WHAT THE THE
WORLD WOULD LOOK LIKE?
WITHOUT THAT SO IT'S JUST IT'S
GOOD TO HAVE YOU HERE TODAY GOOD
TO SEE THE WORK BEING PLANNED
AND DONE THESE ROADS BEING
REPAIRED SO.
I GUESS THANK YOU US WE'RE HERE.
I'M JUST A LITTLE PERSPECTIVE --
IN TERMS OF HOW YOU'RE LOOKING
AT THE NEW EMERGENCY RISK ISSUES
EMERGING. FOR US YOU KNOW PCH
DURING THE FIRE WAS.
A MESS -- AND THE STOP LIGHTS
BEING OFFER GONNA SEE MORE THIS
HAPPENING AS THESE FIRES
CONTINUE JUST A LITTLE INSIGHT
IN TERMS OF HOW LIKE.
PRIVATIZATION WITHIN SOME OF
THIS MAINTENANCE AND HOW YOU'RE
SORT OF TRYING TO INTEGRATE.
THAT EMERGENCY PLANNING INTO IT
I'M EVEN THINKING ABOUT IS IS IS
IS HAVE SUFFICIENT FUNDING OR OR
OR FOCUS ON THINGS LIKE --
BACKUP POWER SYSTEMS FOR OUR
STOP LIGHTS OR MAYBE IT'S MORE
ABOUT ADMINISTRATION DURING
THOSE EVENTS JUST WANTED YOUR
TAKE ON SOME OF THAT ARE.
SO YES WE DO HAVE A LOT OF
EMERGENCIES WE'VE HAD WE'VE HAD
AN UNPRECEDENTED NUMBER OF
EMERGENCIES AND FIRES.
AND WE ALL KNOW THAT.
IT JUST SEEMS LIKE ONCE WE HAVE
A FIRE WE'RE GONNA HAVE A LOT OF
RAIN.
WE'RE GONNA HAVE THE MUD AND
DEBRIS FLOWS WE'RE LOOKING AT
DIFFERENT WAYS TO MANAGE THAT.
AND I DON'T WANT TO GO TOO FAR
OF COURSE THERE WERE ACTUALLY
SOMETHING WE'RE DOING THAT'S
PRETTY COOL THAT WE STARTED
DOING ON STATE ROUTE ONE FORTY
INTO YOSEMITE THIS YEAR.
WHICH IS WE ARE WORKING WITH THE
NATIONAL WEATHER SERVICE TO LOOK
AT THE EXPECTED INTENSITY.
AND TIME OF RAIN AND THEN WE ARE
PROACTIVELY CLOSING ROADS.
WHICH WHEN YOU DO THAT AND IT
WORKS OUT IN YOUR RIGHT.
IT'S GREAT IF IT IF YOU IF
YOU'RE WRONG IT'S NOT GREAT BUT
WE WE WORK FOR THE NATIONAL
WEATHER SERVICE AND WHAT IT'S
MEANT IS THAT WE ARE CLOSING
THAT THE ONLY ALL WEATHER ROAD
INTO YOSEMITE -- IN ADVANCE OF
THE MUD FLOWS WHICH MEANS
THERE'S A PROTECTING PROPERTY IN
LIFE AND IT'S AND IT'S WORKING
WELL AND WE'RE GONNA LOOK AT
CHANGING THE AT DOING THAT
STATEWIDE SINCE IT HAS WORKED
OUT -- WE'RE LOOKING AT OTHER
THINGS TO DO ALL OVER THE STATE
TO PROACTIVELY MANAGE FOR THOSE
TYPES OF EMERGENCIES -- WE ALSO
HAVE -- OBVIOUSLY OUR SYSTEM IS
OLD YOU ALL KNEW THAT WHEN YOU
UP.
APPROVED SB.
ONE OF THEM.
AND AND SO THAT'S BEEN KIND OF
JUST IN TIME AS WE CONTINUE TO
NEED MORE MONEY TO PROACTIVELY
MAINTAIN THE SYSTEM.
AND SO WE LOOK AT ALL KINDS OF
THINGS ARE MAINTENANCE CREWS ARE
OUT THERE WE HAVE REPORT BY ANY --
REPORTS THAT THE BRIDGE FOLKS TO
TO LOOK AT WHAT NEEDS TO BE
FIXED ON BRIDGES TO IS THAT.
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION.
SO YEAH A LOT OF STRESSES ON THE
SYSTEM FROM -- YEARS OF NOT
INVESTING PROPERLY AS AS WELL AS
CLIMATE CHANGES.
AND THE POWER SIDE OF THINGS IS
THAT SO THAT'S I'LL HAVE TO LOOK
INTO THAT MORE BECAUSE GENERALLY
WE HAVE ON THE STATE SIDE WE
HAVE BACK UP -- BUT YOU MAY NOT
SEE THAT AS MUCH ON THE ON THE
LOCAL SIDE BUT LET ME LOOK INTO
THAT A BIT MORE.
YOU HEARD IT HERE AND SENT TO
THE NEW NIMBLE CALTRANS CENTER
MINING THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
DETECTIVE.
I JUST WANT TO BUILD ON SENATOR
STERN'S COMMENTS TO THE THE NEW
ABNORMAL AS IT'S BEEN CALLED IN --
I KNOW PART OF MY DISTRICT
KEEPING HIGHWAY ONE OPEN --
THROUGH FIRE AND FLOOD IN SOME
OF THE USE OF WHETHER PATTERNING
THE PRO PROACTIVE -- PREVENTIVE
CLOSURES SENT THE MUD CREEK SIDE
AREA TO MAKE SURE THERE'S NOT A
AND EXPECTED THEM.
ENGINEER DISASTER DOWN THERE I
KNOW WE'RE GONNA BE HEARING FROM
OUR HIGHWAY PATROL COLLEAGUES
SOON BIT. TO DRILL DOWN A LITTLE
BIT ON ANTICIPATING -- AT RISK
AREAS THE GOVERNOR'S TASK FORCE
IN FIRE PREVENTION SOAKING IT I
THINK THIRTY FIVE OR THIRTY
EIGHT PRIORITY AREAS.
IS ANY THAT COORDINATED WITH
CALTRANS IN I ASSUME YOU'RE
COORDINATING WITH C. H. P. AS
YOU LOOK AT THESE.
CENTRAL ROAD CHALLENGES OR SO A
LOT OF THE WORK WE DO IS IN
COORDINATION WITH C. H. P. WE
ALSO ARE ENGAGED WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES AS WELL IN TERMS OF
MANAGING.
EVERYTHING IN THE STATE AND SO
DOES THAT INCLUDE -- THE TRAGEDY
AT PARADISE.
WE'VE HEARD FROM.
SOME OF THE EMERGENCY PLANNERS
THERE THAT DESPITE THE HIGH
NUMBER OF FATALITIES IN THE
MASSIVE PROPERTY LOSS.
PERHAPS MORE IVES WERE SAVED BY.
FOUR LANE ESCAPE ROUTE AND IN TH
FIRE FORTIFICATION NEXT TO THAT
FOUR LANE THOSE TWO LANES EACH
WAY THEY TURNED IT INTO. FOUR
LANE ESCAPE ROUTES.
DO YOU GET INVOLVED IN THAT
PLANNING TO SOME EXTENT WHERE MY
MAINTENANCE FOLKS ARE OUT THERE
AND THEY WERE DOING A LOT OF
WORK WITH HELPING TO MANAGE
TRAFFIC CONTROL TO GET FOLKS OUT.
WORKING.
IN CONJUNCTION WITH C. H. P. AND
WITH THE LOCAL FOLKS IN BUTTE
COUNTY AS WELL.
IN.
OTHERS HAVE POINTED OUT THAT NAM.
WELL PARADISE THERE WAS
PREPARATION THAT ALLOWED FOR
THAT FOUR LANE EXIT.
THERE'S OTHER RURAL AREAS THAT
DON'T HAVE THAT TO WORK WITH --
SO.
WE'RE FACE AN UPCOMING
CHALLENGES AS WELL BUT THANK YOU
FOR THE WORK THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR.
OKAY -- ANY CONCERNS REYES SAID
MAINTENANCE EQUIPMENT REQUESTED
[inaudible]
OKAY.
THISIS A MATTER IS SET
REQUESTED TO PROVE HIS BUDGET
LET'S OPEN THE PUBLIC HEARING
THIS IS A THE ROAD REPAIR AND
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT
IMPLEMENTATION.
FOR CALTRANS.
THIS IS A WE HAVE A YEAH. ONE
WITNESS IS LIKE THE NATION
[inaudible]
RIGHT GEN.
THIS IS ON THE ROAD REPAIRS AND
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT.
HAVING PARTICIPATED WITH THE
INFORMATION ABOUT PRETTY.
PREPPING DISABILITIES DEALING
FOR WILDFIRES.
KNOWLEDGE MINT THROUGH THERE IS
IS THAT INDEED MORE PLANTS NEED
TO BE AND MORE THAN JUST SIMPLY
PREPARING FOR WILDFIRE.
NEEDS TO BE DETERMINED WHETHER
IT'S HOUSING IN THE OTHER THINGS
YOU NEED TO LOOK AT BETTER
PREPARATION. FOR DON ONLY
EVACUATING BUT ALSO FOR WHERE
YOU PRE APPROVED POSITION YOUR
RESOURCES TO DEAL WITH THE
EMERGENCIES.
THAT WE IN CALIFORNIA NOW
CONTINUALLY HAVE A ANNUAL YEARLY
[inaudible]
FIRE SEASON.
THANK YOU CLOSE PUBLIC HEARING
BRING IT BACK.
THERE'S A MEDIATION THERE'S A
MOTION TO APPROVE HIS BUDGET
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CASKEY HI JONES WIRE BONDING.
STERN.
HAS FISHING BOATS WILL KEEP TO
MATTER OPENFOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS MOVING ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER -- SIXTEEN THIS IS THE
PROJECT INITIATION DOCUMENT ZERO
BASED BUDGET.
THE DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION
REQUEST RESOURCES ASSOCIATED
WITH THE BIENNIAL ZERO BASED
BUDGET PROCESS. FOR THE PROJECT
INITIATION DOCUMENT PROGRAM IN
FISCAL YEAR NINETEEN TWENTY THIS
REQUEST INCLUDES A TOTAL OF FOUR
HUNDRED AND SEVEN POSITIONS.
FORTY FIVE FULL TIME EQUIVALENTS
FOR ARCHITECTURE AND ENGINEERING
CONTRACTING AND CASH OVER TIME
EXPENSE TOTALLING EIGHTY FIVE
POINT.
SEVEN MILLION TO DEVELOP TOTAL
PROJECT INITIATION DOCUMENT FOR
PERIODS.
THIS REQUEST MAINTAINS CURRENT
STATE STAFFING LEVELS AND
REFLECTS A 5% INCREASE OF FOUR
POINT FOUR POINT NINE MILLION IN
STATE HIGHWAY ACCOUNT RESOURCES.
FOR ARCHITECTURE AND ENGINEERING
CONTRACTING CAPACITY THIS WILL
INCREASE THE ARCHITECTURE AND
ENGINEERING A THIRTY FROM 5%
210% OF THE TOTAL.
HIT PROGRAM BUDGET.
CALTRANS BEGAN USING A ANY
RESOURCES FOR THE PAID PROGRAM
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN AT
THE TIME WHEN SB ONE WORKLOADS
STARTED.
THESE RESOURCES HAVE PROVIDED
THE PROGRAM NEEDED FLEXIBILITY
SPECIFICALLY THE INCREASE WILL
ALLOW THE PAID PROGRAMS. TO
EXPEDITIOUSLY BRING ON
EXPERIENCED CONSULTANTS TO
DELIVER PIDS FOR THE MORE
COMPLEX MULTI OBJECTIVE PROJECTS.
HELPING ACHIEVE THE PROJECT
PERFORMANCE TARGETS IDENTIFIED
IN THE STATE HIGHWAY SYSTEM
MANAGEMENT PLAN.
HELLO YOU HAVE A COMMON REPORT.
I MISS YOU GUYS.
AS FOR OKAY.
THEY WERE GONNA HOLD THIS MATTER
OPENS ALL HAVE THE PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THE END OF THE THE
THE SESSION SEEING NO.
COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUES.
ISSUE NUMBER. SEVENTEEN THIS IS
PAYMENT OF ALL OUTSTANDING
GENERAL FUND TRANSPORTATION
LOANS.
YES GOOD AFTERNOON A DEMON ON
PART IN A FINANCE AS PART OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
ADMINISTRATION OPPOSES TO BE PAY
ALL OUTSTANDING LOANS FROM
SPECIAL FUNDS TO THE GENERAL
FUND.
THIS IS CONSISTENT WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION'S BROADER
APPROACH OF PAYING OFF THE
STATE'S BUDGETARY THAT.
BUILDING ADDITIONAL RESERVES AND
PAYING DOWN OTHER LIABILITIES
UNDER THIS PROPOSAL THE GENERAL
FUND TO PAY THE OUTSTANDING LOAN
OF APPROXIMATELY EIGHT HUNDRED
SEVENTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS.
OF PREVIOUSLY LOAN WAIT THE
REVENUE TO THE TRANSPORTATION
THAT SERVICE FUND IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY WHERE
WE USED TO BE ELIGIBLE
TRANSPORTATION BOND AT SERVICE.
AND NO PROP TO ACT.
ARE YOU THERE IS A PROPER
ELEMENT OF THE TRAILER BILL AS
WELL OKAY WOULD BE THAT THE
THIRD YEAR OF THE REPAYMENT OF
LOANS -- TO TRANSPORTATION
CONGESTION RELIEF FUND WOULD NOT
BECOME TOWARD THE PROP TWO
REQUIREMENTS ACTION.
ELIA NO COMMENT.
THIS IS ANOTHER HOLD OPEN
[inaudible]
A MATTER.
THE NEXT ONE IS TO PROVE HIS
BUDGET TO LET'S OPEN UP PUBLIC
COMMENT THIS THE PUBLIC COMMENT
FOR ISSUE NUMBERS SIXTEEN THE
PIG N. ISSUE NUMBER -- SEVENTEEN
THE PREPAYMENT OF OUTSTANDING
DEBT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
THE BAKER WITH THEIR NEW MISSES
HIS FOR THE PROFESSIONAL
ENGINEERS.
IN CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT ON THE
ISSUE OF PEDS.
WE SUPPORT THE BUDGETING AMOUNT
OF PITS WE DON'T SUPPORT AND
OPPOSE.
THE INCREASE IN CONTRACTING OUT
THE DOUBLING OF THE OUTSOURCING.
FOR THE PROJECT INITIATION
DOCUMENTS.
WOULD NOTE THAT UP UNTIL LAST
YEAR THESE -- PROJECTS WERE NOT
OUTSOURCED AT ALL.
RELUCTANTLY WENT ALONG WITH THE
OUTSOURCING BECAUSE OF THE S. B..
ONE INFLUX.
WE DON'T BELIEVE IT'S
APPROPRIATE ANYMORE WE THINK
THAT THIS IS -- IMPORTANT POLICY
DOCUMENT THE INITIAL DOCUMENT
THAT SHOULDN'T BE OUTSOURCED --
AND WE ALSO NOTE THAT THE
OUTSOURCING WILL COST DOUBLE OR
MORE THAN HAVING STATES HAVE TO
THIS WORK.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE TO ASK
FOR AN ADJUSTMENT AND HELPS
STATE STAFF TO THAT WORK THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
AS FOR HOLDING IT OPEN WILL HAVE
THOSE DISCUSSIONS.
THANK YOU FOR LYFT ALLOWING ME
TO SPEAK TODAY MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MARC WATTS ON BEHALF
TRANSPORTATION CALIFORNIA.
WE WERE ONE OF THE FORMS OF
MEMBERS OF THE FOR OF THE S. P.
ONCE POOR COMMUNITIES AND WE
FOLLOW EVERY SP.
ONE BUDGET ITEM.
WE HAVE A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE THAN THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKER ON THE PITS WE THINK HIS
OF LOOK MODEST AMOUNT OF
OUTSOURCING TO MINISTRATIONS
ASKING.
FOR WILL GIVE THEM MUCH MORE
FLEXIBILITY THE PIT
RESPONSIBILITY IS DIVIDED
BETWEEN HEADQUARTERS IN TERMS OF
THE PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
PLANNING PROVIDING GUIDANCE AND
RESOURCES.
AND THE DISTRICTS WHERE THE
ACTUAL WORK TAKES PLACE.
IN THE U. OUTSOURCING WOULD COME
WOULD BE COMPOSED OF
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CONTRACTS.
FOR YOU KNOW VARIOUS TECHNICAL
ITEMS THANK YOU FOR THE BACK
INTO A CALTRANS TEAM.
THE TEAM FINISH THE PIT
CIRCULATES THE PIPP WITHIN THE
DISTRICT GETS COMMENTS IN THE
DISTRICT DIRECTOR MAKES A
DECISION YES RENAULT.
ON WHETHER THE SCOPE AND COSTS
IN -- IDENTIFY CORRECTLY AND
THAT LEADS TO ACTUAL CENTRAL
FUTURE PROGRAMMING SO WE THINK
IT'S A VERY REASONABLE APPROACH
AND ENCOURAGE YOU TO SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
OKAY.
CLOSE PUBLIC HEARING ITS
AUTHORITY VERSUS ACTUAL CIVIL
MARK ON WORK ON THAT LET'S MOVE
TO NUMBER EIGHTEEN AND HAVE THE
GENERAL BY THE ACTING GENERAL
[inaudible]
THIS IS.
THIS IS EIGHTEEN THE OFFICE OF
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL.
GOOD AFTERNOON GENERAL.
I I MILLION LEWIS I'M THE
ASSISTANT DIRECTOR -- FROM THE
INDEPENDENT OFFICE OF AUDITS AND
INVESTIGATIONS.
OKAY PLEASE OKAY THANK YOU.
THE INDEPENDENT OFFICE OF AUDITS
INVESTIGATIONS OFFICE OF THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION REQUEST A
PERMANENT INCREASE OF TEN NEW
POSITIONS AND EIGHT HUNDRED
TWENTY EIGHT THOUSAND IN STATE
HIGHWAY ACCOUNT FUNDS TO
ACCOMMODATE THE SPECIFIED POWERS.
AND RESPONSIBILITIES INITIALLY
ESTABLISHED TO THE ROAD REPAIR
AND ACCOUNTABILITY ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THIS REQUEST
ALSO INCLUDES THE PERMANENT
REDIRECTION OF EIGHTEEN EXISTING
POSITIONS AND FUNDING TO THE O.
I. G. FROM THE CAPITAL OUTLAY.
SUPPORT LOCAL ASSISTANCE
MAINTENANCE AND ADMINISTRATION
PROGRAMS TO PRESERVE THE O. I.
G.'S INDEPENDENCE FOR ON GOING
OUT OF WORK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALTRANS PROGRAMS.
AN OVERALL INCREASE IN RESOURCES
ARE NEEDED TO ACCOMMODATE THE
SPECIFIED POWERS INCREASED
WORKLOAD AND RESPONSIBILITIES
ESTABLISH THROUGH THE ROAD
REPAIR AND ACCOUNTABILITY ACT OF
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN CHAPTER
FIVE STATUTES.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AND THE
RELATED BUDGET TRAILER BILL
CHAPTER NINETY FIVE STATUES OF
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN SENATE
BILL. ONE OF THREE SINCE THE
PASSAGE OF THE BILLS THE
INDEPENDENT OFFICE OF AUDITS AND
INVESTIGATIONS HAS ACQUIRED TWO
NEW PROGRAMS THE DEPUTY
INSPECTOR GENERAL FOR REVIEW OF
DIVERSITY.
AND SMALL BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT
EFFORTS AND THE ETHICS PROGRAM.
THESE TWO NEW PROGRAMS ARE. TO
THE TO POSITION NEW POSITIONS
ARE FOR THE S. B. ONE OH THREE
AND ONE IS FOR OVERSIGHT OF THE
ETHICS PROGRAM.
THIS REQUEST WILL ALSO PROVIDE
MORE INDEPENDENCE TO THE O. I.
G. BY TRANSFERRING RESOURCES
FROM THE EXISTING PROGRAMS. FOR
AUTO WORKER CURRENTLY DONE BY
THE AG ON BEHALF OF THE OTHER
CALTRANS PROGRAMS.
CURRENTLY THE CALTRANS PROGRAMS
FUND THE POSITIONS THAT PERFORM
THIS WORK.
THIS REQUEST WILL TRANSFER THESE
RESOURCES FROM OTHER CALTRANS
PROGRAMS TO THE O. I. G..
AND WE REACHED SPECTRALLY
REQUESTED GRANT THIS REQUEST
RIGHT.
HELLO THIS IS WHAT WE'RE
EXPECTING TO BRING EVERYTHING
AND THAT THE IG.
NOMINEES NO NO COMMENT MEMBERS.
ANY COMMENT ON THIS MATTER IT IS
A APPROVED HIS BUDGET IT.
FINANCE YOU GUYS ARE ALL GOOD
THE SWELLS.
OKAY LET'S OPEN UP THE PUBLIC
HEARING.
ON ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN THE
OFFICE OF THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
CLOSE PUBLIC HEARING WILL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION BY SENATOR
STERN TO PROVE HIS BUDGET PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
CASTING HI JONES WIRE BONDING
FIVE STERN.
WE'LL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR
THOSE MATTERS WERE NOT HERE AND
THANK YOU AND MOVED TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES
[inaudible]
OF BOOKS DATA.
MIGHT NOT KNOW THE FULL BUDGET.
COMMITTEE IS GOING TO BE HAVING
A HEARING ON THE DMV ON AT NINE
O'CLOCK ON APRIL TWENTY SECOND --
THE YEAH THIS YEAR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES FORTY MILLION DOLLARS --
WE AD EVIDENTLY A ROBUST
CONVERSATION AND THE ASSEMBLY
EARLIER THIS WEEK -- WE'RE GOING
TO TAKE A DIFFERENT.
APPROACH HERE AT LEAST EXPAND
THE WORK THAT NORMALLY -- SUB TO
WOULD YOU WILL WILL TAKE CARE OF
THE BC PEAS THAT ARE HERE BUT
THE LARGER DISCUSSION ON THAT --
DEPARTMENT MOTOR VEHICLES NOT
THAT WERE.
GIVEN ANYBODY FREE PASSED TODAY
BUT THE HILL.
ACTING DIRECTOR WEB WELCOME.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING US
[inaudible]
OKAY SO.
THE FIRST ISSUE IS.
ANTHONY WHAT THE L. L. WAS GONNA
TALK ABOUT THE THE A MOTOR
VEHICLE ACCOUNT SORRY FOR
ANTHONY SYMBOL FROM ILIO -- AS
YOU KNOW THE MOTOR VEHICLE COUNT
THEM VA RECEIVES REVENUE FROM
VEHICLE REGISTRATION FEES AS
WELL AS DRIVER'S LICENSE FEES.
THIS ACCOUNT PRIMARY SPORTS DMV
CH P. AND AIR RESOURCES BOARD.
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS OR
ACTION EVER OVER MANY YEARS THAT
THIS ACCOUNT HAS HAD SOME --
FISCAL PRESSURES THAT STORE IT'S
BEEN STRUGGLING.
IN MANY CASES THE AMOUNT
EXPENDITURES FROM THE ACCOUNT
HAVE A EXCEEDED THE AMOUNT OF
REVENUES COMING INTO THE ACCOUNT.
BECAUSE OF THIS THE GOVERNOR
JERRY BUDGET -- INCLUDE A VERY
PROPOSED ADDRESS SORT OF THE
CONDITION OF THE ACCOUNT -- SOME
OF THE POSES INCLUDED USING
GENERAL FUND OF TO FIND SOMEONE
TIME BECAUSE THAT I DIDN'T
TYPICALLY FIND AND FROM MVA.
ALSO PROPOSE CHANGING HOW WE
FIND SEIZE PEOPLE'S FACILITY
REPLACEMENTS.
SHIFTING FROM A PAY AS YOU GO
APPROACH TO FINANCING THEM OVER
TIME.
AND YOU ALSO PROPOSED TO SUSPEND
CERTAIN DMV SPEAK UP ALLEY
PROJECTS.
DESPITE THE PROPOSAL THE
GOVERNOR'S.
BUDGET PROJECTED THAT OF THAT
MOTOR VEHICLE COUNT WOULD BECOME
INSOLVENT BY TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO FISCAL YEAR -- AS
PART OF THIS APRIL FINANCE
LETTER THE GOVERNOR RECENTLY
INCLUDED OTHER PROPOSALS THAT
IMPACT THE NBA.
ON THE SPENDING SIDE AS YOU WILL
DISCUSS THE FULL BUDGET
COMMITTEE HEARING E'S PROPOSING
A SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN
FUNDING FOR THE TOP PART OF
MOTOR VEHICLES. TO ACCOMMODATE
THAT COSTS AS WELL AS THE
ADDRESS THE PROJECTED INSOLVENCY
INCLUDES OTHER PROPOSALS TO
BENEFIT THE MVA -- SOME IS
RECALL THOSE INCLUDE --
SUSPENDING FOR OF ON A FIVE YEAR.
BASIS A TRANSFERRED TO HAS GONE
ANNUALLY -- FROM THE NVA TO THE
GENERAL FUND THESE ARE FEES ARE
SORT OF MISCELLANEOUS FEES THE
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES
COLLECTS THAT ARE.
GOVERNED BY ARTICLE NINETEEN OF
THE STATE CONSTITUTION SO
THEY'RE NOT RESTRICTED TO BE
USED FOR CERTAIN PURPOSES ON
LIKE THE VEHICLE REGISTRATION
FEES FOR EXAMPLE -- YOU ALSO
PROPOSES.
TO WHEN YOU GO ONLINE WHAT THE
CUSTOMERS WANT OF SORT OF RENEW
THEIR VEHICLE REGISTRATION
ONLINE -- THE STATE FROM THE NBA
PACES PAYS THE CREDIT CARD
TRANSACTION FEES WHEN THOSE
INDIVIDUALS USE A CREDIT CARD.
SO IN ORDER TO BENEFIT THE NVA
HE'S PROPOSING THAT WE PASSED
THAT CREDIT CARD CHARGE ON TO
THE INDIVIDUAL WHO USES A CREDIT
CARD.
BASED ON ALL IS VERY PROPOSALS
BY THE ADMINISTRATION PROJECTS
THAT OVER THE NEXT FIVE YEARS
THEM VA WILL HAVE A PRETTY GOOD
RESERVE.
RANGING OR NEXT FIVE YEARS FROM
AND F ABOUT. THREE HUNDRED
FIFTEEN MILLION TO BEHIND FIFTY
FIVE MEN SO MUCH BETTER THAN
WHATTHE OUTLOOK LIKE THAT
LOOKED IN JANUARY.
I'M HELP YOU UNDERSTAND HOW TO
THINK ABOUT THE GUMS OPOSE I
DIDN'T WANT TO JUST PROVIDE IF
YOU COM IS FOR YOU TO THINK
ABOUT.
FIRST IN TERMS OF WHATACTIONS
YOU NEEDED YOU TO HELP THEM THEY
REALLY KIND OF THE FIRST ARTS
WITH YOUR EXPENDITURE PRIORITIES --
DO YOU WANT TO FIND AT A HIGHER
LEVEL THE GOVERNOR BECAUSE
THERE'S OTHER THINGS YOU WANT TO
FIND AT THE GOVERNOR PROPOSING
OR DO YOU WANT TO FIND AT A
LOWER LEVEL MEANING YOU MAY NOT
APPROVE ALL THE INCREASES YOU
WANT TO PROVIDE TO THE DMV OR
OTHER.
OTHER DEPARTMENTS.
THE SECOND THING IS REALLY THINK
ABOUT THE LONG TERM OUTLOOK OF
THE NB AS I MENTIONED THE NB AS
HAD PROBLEMS OVER MANY YEARS.
AND NOT JUST THIRDS SORT OF
THINK ABOUT THE SHORT TERM OR
REALLY THE LONG TERM. ONE OF THE
PROPOSED THE GOVERNOR'S HAS
SUSPEND FOR FIVE YEARS
FUNDAMENTAL PENSION PAYMENTS I'M
FROM THE NBA THIS IS RELATED.
TO AN ACTION TAKEN AS PART OF
THE TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN BUDGET ACT WERE WE
BORROWED.
BY SIX BILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
STATE'S I'M CASH BALANCES TO
MAKE A SUPPLEMENT OF A PAYMENT
TO THE CALPERS RETIREMENT SYSTEM.
THE IDEA WAS THAT THE VERY
SPECIAL FUNDS THAT MAKE EMPLOYER
CONTRIBUTIONS TO CALPERS WILL
REPAY THIS LOAN OVER TIME.
THE GOVERNOR SAYS THE SAME
BECAUSE A LOT OF THAT.
HE'S PROPOSING IN FOR DMV ARE
REALLY FOR LIKE REAL ID
IMPLEMENTATION OF SOME MORE OF
THE NEAR TERM HIS PROPOSED THAT
WE DON'T MAKE ANY PAYMENTS FOR
THE NEXT FIVE YEARS AND PUSH US
OUT WORK.
WELL WHAT THAT MEANS IS IT DOES
HELP YOU IN THE NEAR TERM BUT
THAT MEANS YOUR PAYMENTS IN THE
I. YEARS AFTER THE FIVE YEARS GO
UP AND WE HAVE TO PAY THIS LOAN
BY -- G. JUNE THIRTIETH.
TWO THOUSAND THIRTY IT ALSO YOU
NEED TO THINK ABOUT IS THE WHILE
SOME OF THE COSTS ARE REALLY
IDENTIFIED MAYBE ME NEAR TERM
FOR TEAM VIA NEXT FIVE YEARS WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE COSTS ARE
GOING TO BE AFTER FIVE YEARS YOU
COULD HAVE INCREASE BECAUSE FOR
C..
SHOULD TEACH BE IMPORTING CARS.
THE DMV IS TRYING UNDERTAKEN
VARIOUS IT PROJECTS THOSE COSTS
TO BE INCURRED AFTER THE FIVE
YEARS AGO AGAIN YOU REALLY WANT
TO THINK ABOUT MORE LONG TERM.
THE SECOND PROPOSAL COMING ON
ABOUT THE GOVERNOR'S ENVY IS
REALLY HIS REPOSE AT THE SUSPEND
FOR FIVE YEARS THIS TRANSFER
THAT I MENTIONED EARLIER FROM
THE NBA DID TO THE GENERAL FUND.
THIS TRANSFER BEGAN IF IT
DOESN'T NINE TEN IT WAS
PRIMARILY BECAUSE OF THE STATE'S
GENERAL FUND CONDITION.
THE LECTURE DRESSY TOOK THE%
INITIATIVE AND TOOK THIS ACTION
ON A ONE YEAR BASIS AND THEN THE
FONG YOUR BECAUSE THE STATE'S
CONDITION.
WAS WAS STILL ABOUT ON THE
GENERAL FUND SIDE WE DID IT FOR
ANOTHER YEAR.
BUT AFTER THAT IS SORT OF GOT
BUILT IN -- TO THE ANNUAL BUDGET
SO BECAME MANUAL TRANSFER.
AGAIN THE GOVERNOR WAS HAS BEEN
FIVE HAS BEEN GIVEN THE
CONDITION OF THE NBA GIVING
FUTURE COST PRESSURES YOU MAY
WANT TO CONSIDER JUST ELIMINATE
THE TRANSFER ALL TOGETHER -- THE
TRANSFERS AND LIKE I MENTIONED
EARLIER ABOUT NINETY MILLION
DOLLARS.
SO STOP THERE'D BE HAPPY AS A
QUESTION BEGIN I THINK OUR
APPROACH AND GUIDANCE TO YOU
SORT OF THINK LONG TERM RATHER
THAN JUST SORT OF PUSHING A
PROBLEM DOWN THE ROAD WHICH
WE'VE BEEN DOING OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS.
BUT I CAN'T HELP BUT ASKING
ABOUT THE VLF -- BECAUSE IT IT'S
BE IT'S BECOME A POLITICAL HOT
POTATO BUT GOING FROM 2%. TO
POINT 6% OR WHATEVER WHATEVER IT
IS RIGHT NOW A STE CREATE A HUGE
HIT ON THE ON THE AT THE ACCOUNT.
I MEAN ISN'T.
NOT THE B. L. L. OF THE
REGISTRATION FEE I JUST RECENTLY
SORRY.
BUT THE CARD CAPTOR TAX PEOPLE
TALK ABOUT THE CAR TAX WHEN YOU
PAY YOUR 2%.
REGISTRATION FEE.
THAT GOES INTO THE THE THE
ACCOUNT RIGHT.
NOT THE VLF NOW YOU KNOW IT THE
MATH OMITTED APARTMENT A FINANCE
THE WHAT GOES INTO THE COUNT IS
A BASE REGISTRATION FEE OF SIXTY
DOLLARS AND THEN A TWENTY SIX
DOLLAR CHP FEE.
I I BELIEVE YOU'RE THINKING OF
THE VEHICLE LICENSE FEE AND THAT
GOES INTO -- AND THE LFA THE
MOTOR VEHICLE LICENSE FEE
ACCOUNT OKAY.
WHICH IS THE FROM ACCOUNT ALL
RIGHT.
I DO NOT HAVE THIS FIGURES IN
FROM ME I CAN I'LL HAVE TO CHECK
THAT OUT.
YEAH TWO THIRDS WENT DOWN.
THAT'S A BIG BIG DEAL ONCE UPON
A TIME STILLS BIG DEAL BECAUSE
WE'RE STUCK THERE -- HOW BOUT?
DE LEASE REVENUE PLEASE REVENUE --
CHANGES THE IDEAS YEAH WE'VE GOT
USED TO PAY AS YOU GO.
BACK I WILL PATROL -- BUILDINGS
THAT WE NEED AS PAY OUR DEBTS AS
THEY COME UP AND NOW WE'RE GOING
TO GO TO A DIFFERENT
[inaudible]
SCHEME.
YES WE GIVE YOU MENTION WHICH
INITIALLY FIND BOTH FOR DMV SEES
P. ON A PAY AS YOU GO BASIS THE
GOVERNOR'S OPPOSING.
FOR A SELECT GROUP OF PROJECTS
TO NOT BECAUSE OF THE COMMISSION
AND BE TO FINANCE THEM OVER TIME.
I HAVE TO SEE YOUR YOUR
SPREADING THE COSTS OVER TIME
WHICH ARE GONNA BE PAYING
INTEREST ON THOSE BONDS IT'S NO
DIFFERENT THOUGH HOW WE FIND A
LOT OF INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS I
WOULD KNOW THAT THE GOVERNOR HAD
A SIMILAR PROPOSAL LAST YEAR
THAT THE LEISURE REJECTED.
RIGHT I REMEMBER THAT IT WAS
REJECTED HERE -- EACH ART LET'S
HEAR FROM.
FINANCE.
MEMBERS QUESTIONS ON THIS IS
ISSUE NUMBER NINETEEN THE MOTOR
VEHICLE ACCOUNT FUNDS
[inaudible]
CENTER STERN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
WELCOME.
TAMBIéN LA ODIO APPRECIATED --
WANTED JUST GET YOUR FEEDBACK ON
SOME OF THE THE STAFF COMMENTS
IN TERMS OF DIFFERENT OPTIONS SO
WE'VE TALKED A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THE TRANSFER ISSUE --
EFFICIENCIES.
WE TALKED WITH THE SCHEDULE A
LITTLE BIT ON THE PENSION --
REPLACEMENT PLAN BUT JUST FROM
DMV'S PERSPECTIVE ONE HERE WITH
EUROPE YOUR TAKE ON WAS ON ALL
THAT [inaudible]
REYES [inaudible]
THE DEPARTMENT.
YOUR IS TO GET YOUR TAKE ON SOME
OF THESE OPTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
LAID OUT.
GLADNEY ROBBIE CROCKETT NOT
DIRECTOR MANAGER SERVICES.
AS IT RELATES -- TO A LOT OF
THESE OPTIONS AS AS A DEPARTMENT
WE COORDINATE AND AND WORK WITH
DEPARTMENT FINANCE ON AS IT
RELATES TO TWO METHODOLOGIES IN
REGARDS TO HOW THE FACILITIES
AND THINGS LIKE THAT -- ARE
PICTURED.
IN REGARDS TO EFFICIENCIES THE
DEPARTMENT IS ALWAYS.
LOOKING AT OPPORTUNITIES -- FOR
EFFICIENCIES ARE ACTING DIRECTOR
WILL WILL SPEAK TO THAT ALL THE
MORE THAT'S FROM THAT'S
DEFINITELY IN HER WILL HOUSE.
AS IT RELATES TO SOMETHING THAT
SHOULD BRING THE TABLE HAS.
A LOT OF SKILL SETS TOWARDS.
IN REGARDS -- TO TAMBIéN
TOTALITY.
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT THAT
WE WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ON AS IT
RELATES -- TO PROJECTIONS
PROVIDING THEM THE DATA TO
STICKS.
MAYBE WE CAN GO IN TWO STEPS
THEN -- I I GUESS WE ARE DEAL
WITH FIRST AND THEN.
GO BACK TO THE ACTING DIRECTOR.
YES THANK YOU THE I WOULD JST
POINT OUT ON IN THE AGENDA ON
PAGE.
TWENTY FIVE WE HAVE A FIVE YEAR
OUTLOOK HERE.
AND WHILE WE ARE PUSHING OUT THE
SUPPLEMENT PENSION PAYMENTS
REQUIRED BY -- SENATE BILL
EIGHTY FOUR WE BEGIN.
MAKING THE PAYMENTS AGAIN AND
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR YOU'LL
SEE.
THE BOTTOM LINE A RESERVE OF TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS THAT HAS GROWN FROM YOU
SEE THE BOTTOM THERE ON BUT
YOU'RE CLOSE TO TWO IN.
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO FROM A
HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE MILLION SO
[inaudible]
WE'RE GROWING FAVORITE THE
RESERVE.
DESPITE PUSHING THE PAYMENTS OUT
AND WE'RE MAKING YEAH.
BIGGER PAYMENTS.
IN THE OUT YEARS SO.
THAT WAS DONE TO ACCOMMODATE.
THE RELY DE APRIL ONE BUDGET
REQUEST -- WHILE KEEPING THE THE
FUND SOLVENT AND KEEPING THE
RESERVE ABOVE.
A HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS.
WHEN I COULD WE'RE GONNA GET TO
THE?
REAL ID ON THE TWENTY SECOND BUT
IF IT COSTS MORE MONEY TO GET
THE IDENTIFICATION AND THE
PERSON TO FORGET THE ADDED THAT
AT THAT ACT.
WOULDN'T WE EXPECT FINANCED AS
SAY LET'S RESTATED.
DE ID.
EITHER WE HAVE TO TO HELP WITH
THE NBA.
WHEN I HEARING THAT?
IT'S AN OPTION.
I THOUGHT IT IT CERTAINLY WOULD
BE AN OPTION.
I'LL POINT OUT THAT.
THE REGISTRATION FEE IS BY FAR
THE BIGGEST REVENUE SOURCE FOR
THE FUND.
D. D. DRIVER'S LICENSE
APPLICATION FEE IS BELIEVE
THIRTY SIX DOLLARS RIGHT NOW YOU
YOU'D HAVE.
TO LIKELY REYES SAYS
SIGNIFICANTLY TO COVER ANYTHING
ANY OF THOSE COSTS [inaudible]
DIRECTOR.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR CASKEY AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS KATHY WEBB
ACTING DIRECTOR WITH THE COURTS.
TO RELY DA YEAH I THINK THAT'S
AN INTERESTING -- PROPOSAL TO
CONSIDER THE WAY WE'VE
APPROACHED REAL ID IS THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THROUGH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY.
THE REQUIRED ALL STATES TO MOVE
OVER TO THIS FORM OF AN
IDENTIFICATION CARD
I'M WE RECOGNIZE TO DO THAT IN
EVERY STATES FACE WITH THE SAME
ISSUES NOT JUST CALIFORNIA
THERE'S A ONE TIME KIND OF
WORKLOAD THAT WE HAVE TO ADDRESS.
TO GET ALL OF OUR CURRENT FOLKS
THAT HAVE CARDS WITH THE NEW
CARD WE WILL ALWAYS HAVE PEOPLE
COMING IN FOR NEW CARDS WHETHER
IT'S PEOPLE MOVING TO OUR STATE.
INTO OUR MIX THAT THAT'S JUST A
NORMAL PROCESS AND THEY WILL BE
SUBJECT TO THE REGULAR REAL ID.
BUT IT IS THIS ONE TIME EFFORT
AND AND I DON'T SEE IT AS BEING
AN ONGOING I THINK ONGOING WE
SHOULD ALWAYS BE LOOKING AT ARE
WE ACTUALLY -- SECURING THE
APPROPRIATE FEES TO PAY FOR THE
COST TO RUN THE DMV THAT'S
PROBABLY SOMETHING WE CAN ALWAYS
TALK ABOUT.
BUT FOR THE PURPOSES OF REALLY
DE IT'S TRYING TO MANAGE I THINK
THIS ONE TIME EFFORT THAT WE
HAVE TO ADDRESS.
AND WHAT'S THE BEST AND MOST
APPROPRIATE FINANCIAL WAY TO DO
THAT.
I'M I'M JUST CONCERNED WE KEEP
DANCING AROUND HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE ABOUT WHAT THE NEEDS
ARE IN THE FUN.
PUTTING PUTTING ASIDE RELY DE.
IT ON WHAT THAT COST SHOULD BE
IN ALL THAT WE'VE THIS IS BEEN A
PROBLEM SINCE I ARRIVED AT THE
IN THE LEGISLATURE IT WAS.
MUSHROOMS IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN
BECAUSE OF THAT THE BUDGET
PROBLEMS BUT IT HASN'T GONE AWAY
AND YOU KNOW WE DANCE AROUND.
WHAT THE ACTUAL NEEDS ARE WE'VE
GOT THIRTY THREE MILLION CARS
ARE REGISTERED ON THE -- ON ON
IN CALIFORNIA WE'VE GOT A THOMAS
VEHICLES COMING IN WE GOT.
YOU KNOW. ZERO EMISSIONS
VEHICLES EVERYBODY WANTS A DEAL
AT THE TO USED TO ROADS RIGHT
THAT WE DON'T WE DON'T GET ON
THE GASOLINE FROM.
OUR ELECTRIC VEHICLES IN THE
REGISTRATION IT'S AN EXTRA
HUNDRED THAT'S WHAT WE DID
POLITICALLY BUT I DON'T KNOW IF
ANYBODY DID THE DATA TO SAY WELL
YOU'RE. ZERO AM HERE TESLA IS.
HAS THIS MUCH WEAR AND TEAR WHEN
YOU RUN SO MANY MILES SO WE NOT
WE'RE NOT WE'RE DANCING AROUND.
THE HEALTH OF THE THE FUN -- BUT
WE HAVE AN ILL WE TALKED ABOUT.
THE EXPENDITURES IN THE OTHER
SIDE IS THE REVENUES HOW DO HOW
DO WE CHANGE THAT TO MAKE IT A
HEALTHY ROBUST FUN SO -- THIS IS
JUST A HOLD OPEN ITEM.
IF YOU HAVE ANOTHER QUESTION
CENTER STERN.
OKAY WE WILL HOLD HOLD MATTER
OPEN AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
TWENTY WHICH IS CAPITAL OUTLAYS
[inaudible]
ARE THE POLICING.
HELLO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO VISIT WITH ALL OF
YOU AND CERTAINLY I AM EXCITED
ABOUT THE OPPORTUNITY. TO
MODERNIZE DMV ON ON A MULTIPLE
LEVELS BUT BEFORE YOU RIGHT NOW.
FOR EACH PROPOSALS WERE -- THAT
WE'RE REQUESTING -- OF I
UNDERSTAND STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS
TO HOLD THESE OPEN SO I'D LIKE
TO JUST PROVIDE YOU AN OVERVIEW
OF WHAT WE'RE REQUESTING.
THE FIRST REQUEST IS FOR THE
WALNUT CREEK FIELD OFFICE
RELOCATION.
THE CURRENT FIELD OFFICES A
LEASE FACILITY THAT HAS CHANGED
OWNERSHIP AND THE NEW OWNERS ARE
NOT WILLING TO INCLUDE DMV AND
THEIR FUTURE PLANS -- SO AT THIS
POINT TIME THE CURRENT LEASE WAS
DUE TO EXPIRE NOVEMBER THIRTIETH
OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE WERE ABLE
TO GET AN EXTENSION WITH THE
OWNER FOR A TWO YEAR LEASE TO
YOUR ADDITIONAL LEASE -- BUT
WE'RE ALSO GOING TO BE LOOKING
FOR A NEW LOCATION AND SO WE'RE
MAKING A ONE TIME REQUEST FOR
FUNDING OF ABOUT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS FROM THE MOTOR VEHICLE
COUNT. FOR THIS FISCAL YEAR
NINETEEN TWENTY TO PROCURE A NEW
LEASE FACILITY.
THAT WILL ALLOW THE INDEED
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE SERVICES IN
THE WALNUT CREEK AREA AND FOR
THE SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES.
THE NEXT THREE REQUESTS ARE
SPECIFIC TO CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROJECTS THE DMV IS REQUESTING
ABOUT ONE POINT ONE MILLION. TO
FUND THE WORKING AT DRAWING
PHASE OF THE RIDLEY FIELD OFFICE
REPLACEMENT PROJECT.
THE RIDLEY FIELD OFFICE IS A
FIFTY TWO YEAR OLD FACILITY THAT
IS UNDERSIZED.
AND HAS NOT BEEN PROPERLY
MAINTAINED BY THE LESSOR.
THE CURRENT LEASE WAS DUE TO
EXPIRE FEBRUARY TWENTY TWENTY
TGS WAS ABLE TO WORK -- FOR AN
ADDITIONAL EXTENSION TO DECEMBER
OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO THAT WILL
ALLOW US TO PROVIDE A NEWLY
CONSTRUCTED OFFICE IN THAT AREA.
THE PROJECT THAT WE ARE PURSUING
WILL PROVIDE A NEW SAFE AND
APPROPRIATELY SIZED OFFICIALLY
DESIGN.
THEIR OWN ENERGY FACILITY.
THE OTHER TWO CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROPOSALS ARE ACTUALLY
REQUESTING THE RIVER MONEY BACK
TO THE MOTOR VEHICLE ACCOUNT.
WE ARE CRESTING TO RIVER THE
CONSTRUCTION FUNDING FOR TWO
PROJECTS BACK TO THE NBA ONE
INCLUDES THE INGLEWOOD FIELD
OFFICE FOR PLACER PROJECT --
THAT IS TO A TUNE A FIFTEEN
POINT ONE MINUTE FIFTEEN POINT
MILLION DOLLARS BACK.
AND THEN THE SECOND BEING NINE
POINT SEVEN MILLION BACKON FOR
THE DESIGN AND CONSTRUCTION
PERIMETER FENCES FOR TWENTY OF
OUR STATE OWNED DMV FIELD OFFICE
LOCATIONS -- THAT IS MY
RECOMMENDATION TO ALL OF YOU ARE
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
YOU.
LA ONLY EVER.
WHILE MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONWE'RE
GONNA HOLD THIS OPEN OBVIOUSLY
THE MAIN EVENT IS ON THE TWENTY
SECOND.
OKAY SCISSOR THE LAST TWO ITEMS
FOR THE DMV OR THE ONLY TWO
ITEMS FOR THE DMV WILL OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC HEARING.
ANYBODY HAVE AN OPINION ON THE
DMV THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA LIKE.
TO ADDRESS.
I HAVE NOTHING BUT GOOD THINGS
TO SAY ABOUT THE DMV I A GREAT
HAYES HERE ON BEHALF OF
INTELLECTUAL TECHNOLOGY INC.
THE MAKERS OF THE SELF SERVICE
TERMINALS AND WE JUST WANT
EXPRESSED GENERAL SUPPORT FOR
ALL THE EFFORTS THAT DIRECTOR
WEB THE STRIKE TEAM ARE DOING --
TO DEAL WITH THE NUMBER OF THE
ISSUES THAT ARE OUTSTANDING.
HI AT THE DMV LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO PARTNER WITH THEM
THAT CREATES SOLUTIONS FOR A
REAL IDEA ANOTHER ISSUES MOVING
FORWARD.
THANK YOU THANK YOU WILL CLOSE
THE PUBLIC HEARING SEE IN TEN
DAYS.
MORE TO CONTINUE LET'S MOVE TO
THE HIGHWAY PATROL.
THIS IS ISSUE NUMBER.
TWENTY ONE CONTINUE ON THE THEME
OF THE THESE [inaudible]
CONSTRUCTION.
CAPITAL OUTLAY POLLS.
AND IF IT'S MISTER WARREN. ONE
STANLEY EXCUSE ME [inaudible]
WELCOME [inaudible]
OKAY.
MORNING CHAIRMAN MY CASKEY
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
THE STATE I'M COMMISSIONER WAR
SALINE APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY BE WHICH IS MORE
THAN TALK ABOUT IT TWENTY
NINETEEN BUDGET.
BUT BEFORE I BEGIN I WANT TO
THANK ALL OF YOU IN THE
LEGISLATURE FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
AT AN OUTPOURING OF CONCERN FOR
SERGEANT STEVEN MARK STONE WHO
WAS KILLED IN RIVERSIDE
CALIFORNIA INTERSTATE.
FIFTEEN ON SATURDAY APRIL.
SIX BY A DRIVER WAS DRIVING ON
THE INFLUENCE.
CONSTRUCTING MOLLY WAS ON THE
SHOULDER A DOING ENFORCEMENT
STOP BUT HE GAVE THE ULTIMATE
SACRIFICE. FOR THE DEPARTMENT
AND THE PEOPLE STATE A
CALIFORNIA THIS WAS A PRE SHE
THIS BODY SUPPORT.
I'M PROUD OF THE GREAT WORK THE
WOMEN AND MEN DO UNDER SIEGE
BEING ON A DAILY BASIS.
AND WE RECOGNIZE THERE.
THERE WERE ENTRUSTED WITH THESE
FUNDS THAT YOU GIVE US FOR OUR
BUDGET.
I LIKE TO EXPRESS MY GRATITUDE
FOR YOUR STAFF IN GETTING US
READY FOR THIS PROCESS THE BEEN
A BIG HELP TO US. FOR SOMEONE TO
START OUT WITH THE CAPITAL
OUTLAY WHICH YOU MENTIONED JUST
BRIEFLY.
WE HAVE A FIVE PROPOSALS ON
DISCUSSION TODAY REGARDING
CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECTS.
BECAUSE OF THE VARIOUS
CONSTRAINTS ON THE MOTOR VEHICLE
COUNT WE'RE PROPOSING THE
SUSPENSION OF THE FACILITY
REPLACEMENT PROJECTS FOR THE
QUINCY.
AND THE SANTA ANNA AREA OFFICES.
THIS WOULD RESULT IN A ROW --
REVERSION OF THIRTY SEVEN POINT
TWO MILLION DOLLARS. TO THE
MOTOR VEHICLE COUNTY. FOR THE EL
CENTRO HEY WE'RE IN SAN
BERNARDINO.
OFFICE REPLACEMENT PROJECTS.
WE'RE REQUESTING SHIFTING THE
FUNDING FROM THE NBA TO THE
PUBLIC BUILDINGS CONSTRUCTION
FUND.
THESE THREE PROJECTS WERE
PREVIOUSLY APPROVED IN THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUDGET ACT.
IN EACH OF THE PROJECTS ARE
READY TO PROCEED FOR BID. FOR
THE DESIGN A BILL FACE -- FOR
CONTRACTS AS SOON AS FUNDING
AUTHORITY IS AVAILABLE.
AND I WILL DEFER TO OUR PARTNERS
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
TO PROVIDE MORE INFORMATION
ABOUT THE FROM THE STRUCTURE ON
THESE PROJECTS.
HELLO RANDY CATS THE PART OF
FINANCE.
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY.
SO THE PUBLIC BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION FUND IS IT WAS
ESTABLISHED. TO SIXTY SIXTY FIVE
YEARS AGO AND CURRENTLY THERE'S
A HUNDRED AND THIRTY SIX
PROJECTS STATEWIDE THAT UTILIZES.
THIS MECHANISM IN ORDER TO
FINANCE PROJECTS BECAUSE THEY'RE
IN A CASH CONSTRAINED
ENVIRONMENT -- FACTS IN THE
COUPLE CASES SUCH AS A MILITARY
HEADQUARTERS OR IT RESOURCES
BOARD SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA -- LAB
THESE ARE DEPARTMENTS THAT FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN USED PLEASE REVENUE
BONDS. ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
I'VE BEEN HEARING LAST YEAR AND
AND THIS YEAR IS THAT FINANCING
COSTS MORE AND WHILE THAT'S
GENERALLY TRUE WE CALCULATED
IT'S A OUT IF IF YOU DISCOUNT IT
TURNS OUT TO BE ABOUT 20%
GREATER THAN CASH FUNDING.
HOWEVER THAT ASSUMES CASH AND
LEASE FINANCE PROJECTS WITH
START THE SAME TIME.
WITH THE CHALLENGES FACING THE
NBA IN THE ABSENCE OF LEASE
FINANCING THE MOST LIKELY
OUTCOME IS THAT THESE. THREE
PROJECTS TO BE DEFERRED. FOR
THREE FOUR FIVE YEARS.
IN WHICH CASE BECAUSE ESCALATION
ON CONSTRUCTION HAS BEEN
EXCEEDING CPI.
YOUR INCREMENTAL COSTS OF OF OF
FINANCING DECLINE EVEN FURTHER
OR MAYBE EVEN EVEN DECLINE ALL
THE WAY TO BE EQUAL PLUS.
THE H. P. WOULD HAVE TO SPEND
THREE FOUR FIVE MORE YEARS IN
FACILITIES THAT HAVE CRITICAL
DEFICIENCIES.
THANK YOU.
LEN TO GROUP THAT.
I WOULD HAVE TO CHECK WITH OUR
OFFICE IN A JUST A 20% INCREASE
IN AND AND COST.
OVER WITH THE DISCOUNT AND THEN
THIS CONCERNED AT THAT SINCE THE
VULNERABILITY OF THE MBA THAT IF
YOU CAN'T GO OUT TO BID TOMORROW.
YOU MADE THE LADIES IN.
NOTHING GETS CHEAPER HERE RIGHT.
I'M -- I WOULD HAVE TO CHECK
WITH MY COLLEAGUES AT OUR OFFICE
WHO ARE MORE EXPERT IN THE AREA
HOW MUCH YOU DISCOUNT.
DUE TO INFLATIO AND ULTIMATELY
THE WAY YOUR COSTS ARE FEES
PROJECTS AND THEN HAVE OUR
DISCUSSIONS WITH THEM ABOUT THE
LIKELIHOOD THAT WITH DESPITE
REFINEMENT.
FINANCE ABOUT THE LIKELIHOOD
THAT THIS PROJECT WOULD BE
DELAYED IF WE SWITCH TO A FRONT
THAT PAYS YOU GO APPROACH TO THE
LEASING APPROACH.
I JUST YOU KNOW.
WE ARE ONLY UP HERE IN THE THE
CALIFORNIA CENTER FOR A WHILE
AND HE DID THIS IS A CHRONIC
PROBLEM WITH THE NBA.
AND IT A WELL IT'S A TOUGH TOUGH
OF FOR PEOPLE I'D LIKE TO TO GET
US ON A PASS THAT WE FIX IT.
THERE'S YOU KNOW THIS IS A
CREATIVE WAY TO CONTINUE THE
PROJECTS THAT ARE UNDER.
UNDER UNDER YOUR SCORE WE NOBODY
HAS SAID ABOUT THE NBA IS GONNA
COME BACK IT'S GOING TO MAKE IT.
TO MAKE A CHANGE IS JUST THIS IS
THE FUN THAT WE USE WERE NOT
PROPERLY FUNDING IT SO.
IT'S GOING TO HOLD THE MATTER --
MEMBERSHIP ANYBODY HAVE I MEAN I
HAVE NO POBLEMS ON THE ACTUAL
PROJECTS WE WENT THROUGH THAT
LAST YEAR AND WE LOOK AT THAT
THAT'S IT'S THE WELL
[inaudible] SEVENTY RIGHT I'LL
HAVE THE PUBLIC HEARING AT THE
END OF THIS SESSION WAS MOVE THE
ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY TWO THIS IS
RETAIL CRIME TASK FORCE IS
IMPORTING A. B.. TEN SIXTY FIVE
YES WE'RE ALSO REQUESTING FIVE
POINT SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS TO
FUND THE REGIONAL PROPERTY
CRIMES TASK FORCE.
AS DIRECTED BY THE LEGISLATURE
AND ASSEMBLY BILL AT TEN SIXTY
FIVE ACCORDING TO THE NATIONAL
RETAIL FEDERATION ORGANIZED
CRIME COSTS.
UNITED STATES RETAILERS NEARLY
THIRTY BILLION DOLLARS HERE.
RETAILERS NATIONWIDE HAVE BEEN
TARGETED BY ORGANIZED CRIME AND
SOPHISTICATED SHOPLIFTING RINGS.
THESE ORGANIZATION CONSISTENT
TEAMS OF THESE THAT STEAL FROM
RETAIL STORES AND THEN BRING
STONE GOES TO A CENTRAL LOCATION.
THE ITEMS ARE SOLD ONLINE AND MY
ONLINE VENDORS WERE SHIPPED TO
LOCATIONS -- OTHER LOCATIONS FOR
SALE.
HISTORICALLY VARIOUS LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES IN
CALIFORNIA RESPOND TO RETAIL
CRIME.
PROBLEMS INDEPENDENTLY.
AND ACCORDING TO AB THE CRIME IS
OF AB TEN SIXTY FIVE DISEASE
PLEASE REQUIRED TO ESTABLISH A
REGIONAL PROPERTY CRIMES TASK
FORCE.
IN COORDINATION WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO ENHANCE
AND IMPROVE CALIFORNIA'S
RESPONSE TO ORGANIZED RETAIL
CRIME.
IN THE MOST HEAVILY IMPACTED
REGIONS OF THE STATE.
NOW LAST YEAR THE SIEGE BE WE
COMBINED EFFORTS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO SAN
FRANCISCO POLICE DEPARTMENT THE
SAN FRANCISCO DIS OFFICE.
IN THE UNITED STATES POSTAL
SERVICE TO CONDUCT A COMPLEX
INVESTIGATION.
INTO RETAILS AT PEPPERING IN THE
CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO.
THIS OPERATION FOCUS ON THE FACT
OF OVER NINE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN STOLEN PROPERTY.
AND RESULTED IN THE ISSUANCE OF
EIGHTEEN ARREST WARRANTS AND
BREAKING UP OF THE COP COMPLEX.
THAT BRING.
BUT RETAIL THEFT IS NOT.
YOUR LIMITED TO JUST SAN
FRANCISCO.
WE WORK WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AND OTHER ALLIED
AGENCIES.
TO IDENTIFY OTHER PROBLEM AREAS
IN THE STATE.
AND WE'LL WORK IT OUT AGENCIES
TO INCLUDE THE LOCAL DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICES TO DETERMINE
THE BEST AREAS TO DEVOTE OUR
RESOURCES AND FOCUS COMBINED
EFFORTS.
NOW WE'VE ALREADY IDENTIFIED
AGENCIES SUCH AS SAN FRANCISCO
POLICE DEPARTMENT IN THE DA'S
OFFICE.
THE SAN DIEGO DIS COUNTY DIS
OFFICE ESCONDIDO PD.
AND THE LOS ANGELES POLICE
DEPARTMENT THAT HAVE EXPRESSED
AN INTEREST IN PARTICIPATING.
IN A REACH OUT THAT AT THE OF
TASK FORCES. TO COMPLY WITH AB
SIXTY FIVE WERE PROPOSING THE
FUNDING FOR SIXTEEN POSITIONS
ALONG WITH THE ASSOCIATED COSTS.
FOR ASKING FOR THREE SERGEANTS
POSITIONS TO SUPERVISE THE
OPERATIONAL UNITS.
AND NINE OFFICER POSITIONS TO
PERFORM SPECIALIZED
INVESTIGATION.
AND ENFORCEMENT.
TARGETING ORGANIZE RETAIL THEFT.
THESE OFFICERS AND SERGEANTS
WILL WORK PROPERLY -- WITH THE
DOJ AND LOCAL AGENCIES TO COMBAT
ORGANIZED CRIME.
THIS REQUEST BUT WILL ALSO
PROVIDE FUNDING FOR ONE ANALYST
POSITION TO PROVIDE STATEWIDE
COORDINATION.
AND ADMINISTRATIVE SUPPORT TO
THE TASK FORCE.
ALONG WITH THAT THREE OFFICE
TECHNICIAN POSITIONS TO SUPPORT
THE DAILY ADMINISTRATIVE
FUNCTIONS OF THE TASK FORCE.
WE'RE ALSO ASKING FOR THE
ABILITY TO THE CONTRACT WITH D.
O. G. AGENTS WHEN FEASIBLE.
SAYS SPECIFIC WORKING AREAS ARE
GONNA FIGHT THE AVAILABILITY OF
THE DEAL A DEAL J. AGENTS.
AND THEIR ABILITY TO PROCESS
DISSIPATE THE TASK FORCE WILL BE
DETERMINED.
THIS PROPOSAL WILL ESTABLISH
RESOURCES INCLUDING PERSONAL
APPOINTMENT AND ADMINISTRATIVE
SUPPORT NECESSARY. TO PROPEL --
FOR THE SEIZE PETE TO PROPEL THE
REQUIREMENTS AS OUTLINED IN A.
B. [inaudible]
TEN SIXTY FIVE LEóN.
I NEED ONLY WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WE DO HAVE A
COUPLE OF COMMENTS TO HIM --
THIS THE FIRST IS THAT DOJ HAS
SUBMITTED A B. C. B. ON THIS
ISSUE AS WELL AS FOR ONE
POSITION AND THREE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
THAT'S COMING CONSIDERED AND
YOUR BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE.
FIVE THE OTHER ISSUE IS ON THE
TWO POINT ONE MILLION TO
CONTRACT WITH DOJ IT'S OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT IT IS
UNCERTAIN WHAT LEVEL OF
RESOURCES IF ANY THE OJ WOULD BE
PROVIDING.
AND SO THE COMMITTEE WILL REALLY
WANT KIND OF A FIRM ANSWER TO
HOW THE RESOURCES WILL BE USED
BEFORE TAKING ACTION ON THIS
ITEM.
IT CAUGHT MY EYE DID IT'S FIVE
POINT EIGHT MILLION IN.
GENERAL FUNDS PURSES THEM THE
OTHER.
PARTS OF THIS PROP FORTY SEVEN
ISSUE SAID THERE'S OTHER POTS OF
MONEY AROUND FINANCED YOU HAVE.
IT WILL FINANCES FINANCIER.
WHY GENERAL FUNDS?
MAN MARTIN DEPARTMENT FINANCE --
AS YOU KNOW SEATS PEACEABLY FUND
WITH NBA AND THIS WOULD NOT BE
AN APPROPRIATE USE OF THE MPA
RESOURCES.
GO AGAIN -- THIS RAISES THE
QUESTION WHAT THE LA -- WAS WHAT
THE WORKLOADS ACTUALLY GOING TO
BE.
IF I COULD ADDRESS THAT -- PART
OF THE REASON WE BUILT IN THE
MONEY FOR THE DEAL.
J. AGENTS INTO C. H. P.'S BUDGET
IS BECAUSE OF A LITTLE BIT OF
THIS UNCERTAINTY OF HOW MANY
AGENTS WHERE THEY WERE THEY BE
LOCATED.
SINCE THE BILL MAKES THE C. H.
P. RESPONSIBLE FOR THIS TASK
FORCE AND FOR IMPLEMENTING IT
THIS GIVES EACH BE A FLEXIBILITY
THAT IF THEY CAN'TGET.
A DOJ AGENT THEY COULD THEN USE
THE MONEY FOR AN ADDITIONAL CHP
OFFICER AND IF THEY GET IF IF I
DO CHANGES AVAILABLE THEY COULD
PROVIDE DOJ WITHOUT MONEY AS
REIMBURSEMENT SO IT'S FOR THE
SAME NUMBER OF POSITIONS.
ON THE TASK FORCE -- BUT THE MIX
BETWEEN WHETHER IT'S A C. H. P.
POSITION OR DOJ POSITION ON THE
TASK FORCE THAT'S WHY WE WANT
THAT THE FLEXIBILITY THERE.
ARE STAFF REPORT MAKES NOTE OF A
BALLOT INITIATIVE UP NEXT YEAR.
ON THE SUNSET SO THAT'S ADDS OF
YET ANOTHER LITTLE WRINKLE TO
THIS MATTER CENTER OF MONEY.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR AND I JUST WANT TO
START BY.
THINKING COMMISSIONER STANLEY
FOR BEING HERE AND ALSO.
TO THESE EXPRESS OUR CONDOLENCES
TO ALL OF YOUR OFFICERS AND
STAFF I WILL ON THE LOSS OF
SERGEANT LIKE KERN.
THE RETAIL THEFT ISSUE SO PART
OF PROP FORTY SEVEN REDUCES.
SOME CHARGING A SORTIE FOR
SHOPLIFTING NOT TO INCLUDE
BURGLARY.
THEFT CHARGES IF IT'S UNDER NINE
HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS BUT YOU'RE
FOCUSED.
ON ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT WERE
CLEARLY THE AMOUNT IS.
THAT'S NOT THE ISSUE IT'S IT'S
THIS IS ORGANIZED CRIME IS DOING
MASSIVE THEFTS.
YES IN IN THE IN THE THE ONE
CASE THAT WE PUT TOGETHER A TASK
FORCE THAT WE WORK WITH THE SAN
FRANCISCO DA IN SAN FRANCISCO PD.
AND US POSTAL SERVICE THAT.
PRIMARY WAS OVER NINE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS THAT THEY'RE
STILL IN GOOD STEAD A GOTTEN.
I KNOW IN THE DISTRICT I
REPRESENT WE'VE HAD.
MOLD ON THEFTS OF APPLE STORES
IN YES BROAD DAYLIGHT.
IN ALSO OF HIGH END MERCHANDISE.
BREAKING WINDOWS AND MOVING OUT
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS WORTH
OF MERCHANDISE BUT THEN THEY
SHOW UP ON THE INTERNET AS YOU
SUGGESTED. ONE MOVE STUFF INTO
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THEY WERE
SELLING IT ON THE INTERNET IN
THAT THE THAT LED TO THE
DETECTION AND THE ARREST.
WHEN THEY GO ON THE INTERNET IS
THAT MOVED INTO A FEDERAL CRIME --
YOU KNOW JUST FBI OUR FEDERAL
RESOURCES GET INVOLVED.
BASED ON HOW THEY'RE MOVING THE
MERCHANDISE THAT I I I DON'T
KNOW A SPECIFICALLY BUT I WITHIN
AT THE AT THE ABBEY GET INVOLVED
BUT HOWEVER BEAD.
YOU'RE RIGHT ON ONE ASPECT THEY
DO SELL THE GOODS ON WEBSITES
LIKE EBAY.
CORUM FOR CRAIGSLIST TAMPA
BIGGEST SEPARATE SELF FOR PEOPLE
BEEN ON IN ANY MENTION POSTAL
SERVICE WHICH IS FEDERAL.
HARDENING WITH THEM HAS THE
POSTAL SERVICE GET INVOLVED IN --
IS CRIMES TINA YEAH IF THE IF
STATEMENT SHIP SOME OF THE GOODS
VI<c.cyan> VIA US POSTAL SERVICE TO</c>
BE THE US MAIL THEY CROSS THAT
LINE ACROSS THAT LINE.
AND THAT'S WHERE THE US POSTAL
SERVICE.
THAT'S THE FEDERAL PART OF IT
THAT THEY GET INVOLVED IN.
AGAIN I HAVE NO PROBLEM WITH
THIS RECOMMENDATION I'M JUST
THIS IS A NEW ON JUST AS WE'RE
DEALING WITH A NEW LEVEL OF
FIRES WERE DEALING WITH A NEW
LEVEL OF KIND OF ORGANIZED CRIME.
HE'S HITTING RETAIL LEVEL AND
IT'S PUTTING.
SHOPPERS AT RISK IT'S PUTTING
YOUR OFFICERS AT RISK IF THERE'S
CHASES INVOLVED WITH IT -- AND
AGAIN.
THESE THREE IS THERE ANY DO YOU
PARTICIPATED ON TRYING TO HELP
RETAIL AREAS TO HARDEN THEIR
DEFENSES THESE APPLE STORES.
THEY THEY HAVE THEIR PRODUCTS --
TETHERED.
THE THIEVES COME IN AND JUST CUT
THE TETHERS AND GRABBED THE I AM
THE MERCHANDISE THE NEW.
IS THERE ANY.
OUTREACH TO RETAILERS HOW THEY
CAN.
BETTER PROTECT THEMSELVES FROM
THOSE OR IS IT JUST.
SUCH A RARE PHENOMENON THAT IT
WOULDN'T -- WARRANT A BROADER
RETAIL AVERAGE.
I KNOW WITH THE LOCAL POLICE
DEPARTMENTS IN THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT THEY'VE THEY'VE HAD
OUR REGION IN THIS SPECIFIC CASE
THAT WE WORK IN SAN FRANCISCO.
THAT TASK FORCE THAT WE HAVE BE
REACHED OUT TO RETAILERS IN IN
THAT AREA SAN FRANCISCO WERE
THIS WAS HAPPENING.
THANK YOU MISS MARTIN FINANCE
SHIP IS ON AT ON I'M SURE THE
BILL ISSUE -- SPECIFICALLY WE
HAVE THE TREBLE EXTENDS BY SIX
MONTHS THAT THE PROVISIONS -- TO
ALIGN WITH A FULL TWO YEARS
WORTH OF RESOURCES IF THE
TRAILER BILL WERE REJECTED GIVEN
THE BALLOT MEASURES WE WOULD
WORK WITH YOUR STAFF TO REDUCE
THE RESOURCES ACCORDINGLY.
THANK YOU FOR THAT CLARIFICATION.
WE'RE GONNA KEEP THIS MATTER
OPENING GO TO OUR FINAL MATTER
ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY THREE THIS
IS A PUBLIC RECORDS ACT.
YES THE WE ARE ASKING FOR FIVE
HUNDRED SEVENTY SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO FUND. FIVE FIVE TWO
YEAR LIMITED TERM POSITION TO
ASSIST WITH THE INCREASE.
PUBLIC RECORDS A REQUEST RELATED
TO THE PASSING OF SENATE BILL.
FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE HAND
ASSEMBLY BILL.
SEVEN FORTY EIGHT AS ARTICULATED
THAT IN THE COMMITTEES ANALYSIS
AB SEVEN FORTY BEGINS ON JULY
ONE OF THIS YEAR.
NUMBER REQUIRE UNDER SPECIFIED
CONDITIONS THE RELEASE OF VIDEO
OR AUDIO RECORDINGS.
OF ANY CRITICAL INCIDENT
INCLUDING OFFICER INVOLVED
SHOOTINGS. FOR USE OF FORCE
INCIDENTS RESULTING GREAT BODILY
INJURY.
AB FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE REQUIRES
THE RELEASE OF INFORMATION FROM
OFFICERS PERSONNEL RECORDS.
THAT HAVE BEEN PREVIOUS
PREVIOUSLY DEEMED CONFIDENTIAL
THE REQUIREMENTS OF AB FOURTEEN
TO ANYONE.
THAT BECAME EFFECTIVE JANUARY
ONE OF THIS YEAR.
THE SIEGE BE PUBLIC RECORDS UNIT
CURRENTLY CONSIST OF ONE
SERGEANT. ONE OFFICER FOR A GPAS.
IN PRIOR TO JANUARY ONE THE
UNIVERSE HAILING AROUND.
NINETY FIVE LAST A MONTH.
IN ADDITION TO FIELDING SEVENTY
EIGHTY FIVE SEVENTY TO EIGHTY
PHONE CALLS A DAY.
IN ADDITION TO THE BASELINE
WORKLOAD WE HAVE RECEIVED
APPROXIMATELY ONE HUNDRED PEORIA
REQUEST SINCE JANUARY.
ONE SPECIFIC TO THE CRITERIA
ESTABLISHED IN SB.
FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE AND WE'RE
STILL RECEIVING REQUESTS ON A
DAILY BASIS.
MANY OF THE REQUEST FOR RECORDS
RELATED TO SB FOURTEEN TWENTY
ONE ARE ALL INCLUSIVE.
IN OTHER WORDS WE ARE BEING
REQUEST TO PROVIDE EVERY RECORD
WE HAVE THAT MEANS TO ESTABLISH
CRITERIA.
WE HAVE IDENTIFIED THOSE RECORDS
SENATE AND ARE IN THE PROCESS
AND ARE IN POSSESSION OF TWO
HUNDRED AND EIGHT RECORDS THAT
MEET THE CRITERIA ESTABLISHED BY.
FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE THESE
INCLUDE COMPLEX OFFICER INVOLVED
SHOOTING INVESTIGATION IT'S AN
INTERNAL INVESTIGATIONS THAT
RESULTED IN ADVERSE ACTION
AGAINST AN EMPLOYEE.
AS AN EXAMPLE ONE SHOOTING
INVESTIGATION CONTAINS OVER ONE
THOUSAND PAGES OF INFORMATION.
VIDEO RECORDING AND DIGITAL
IMAGES.
THE DISEASE MUST BE HAND
SEARCHES AND PERSON PERSONAL
INFORMATION OF INVOLVED PARTIES
MUST BE REDACTED.
THIS TAKES A CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT
OF TIME. FOR EVERYONE MINUTES OF
VIDEO RECORDING IT TAKES ONE OF
OUR EMPLOYEES FIVE MINUTES TO
REVIEW A REDACT THE NON
RELEASABLE INFORMATION. ONE OF
OUR SHOOTING INVESTIGATIONS HAS
TWENTY TWO DIFFERENT VIDEO
RECORDING.
WE RECOGNIZE THAT THIS WORK WILL
REDUCE OVERTIME AND STABILIZE.
FOR THIS REASON WE'RE REQUESTING
THE FIVE POSITIONS ON A TWO YEAR
LIMIT TERM BASIS TO ALLOW US TO
EVALUATE THE WORKLOAD AND
DETERMINE THE ACTUAL NUMBER
POSITIONS.
THAT WILL BE NEEDED TO COMPLY
WITH THE A PR A REQUEST MOVING
FORWARD.
THE FIVE POSITIONS INCLUDE --
ONE STAFF SERVICE MANAGER. ONE
THREE A. G. P. A.'S AND WHAT
OFFICE TECHNICIAN.
CAN NOW HAPPEN ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
COMMENT WE DIDN'T HAVE ANY
ISSUES.
COLLEAGUES QUESTIONS ON D.
UPDATE THE PUBLIC RECORDS ACT
HUNDRED REQUIREMENTS SET FORTH
IN LEGISLATION [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT [inaudible]
FINANCIAL.
RIGHT LET'S OPEN UP THE PUBLIC
HEARING THIS IS ALL THINGS AND
C. H. P.THIS WILL BE ITEMS.
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND TWENTY
THREE GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
I'VE BEEN ALL TOMORROW I'M HERE
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
OF ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT.
TASK FORCE FUNDING AS WELL AS
THE EXTENSION.
OF THE SUNSET DAY WE APPRECIATE
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AND WE
WOULD HOPE THAT YOU WOULD
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS NOT ASSEMBLY
ON BEHALF OF THE HOME DEPOT AND
TARGET IN SUPPORT OF THE A
BUDGET REQUEST. FOR IT TO EIGHT
IN THE IMPLEMENTATION OF AB TEN
SIXTY FIVE AS WELL AS THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WILL CLOSE PUBLIC
HEARING -- WE WILL KEEP ALL THE
MATTERS WITH C. H. P. ON TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NOW I'D LIKE TO OPEN A ROLL CALL
ON ITEM NUMBER. FOR FIFTEEN THIS
IS THE GUY CALTRANS.
ROAD REPAIR IN ACCOUNTABILITY
ACT PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
JONES MCGUIRE.
THAT MATTER IS APPROVED FOR TWO
ZERO AND NOW LET'S CALL THE ROLL
ON ITEM NUMBER -- EIGHTEEN WITH
THE OFFICE OF INSPECTOR GENERAL
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
JONES REQUIRE.
THAT MATTERS APPROVED CLOSE ROLL
CALL ROLL CALL MARISSA THROUGH --
FOUR ZERO WE ARE ADJOURNED SEE
YOU ON APRIL TWENTY SECOND FULL
BUDGET NINE AM GMT [inaudible]
THANK YOU